hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about java and kotlin
programming languages but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you're a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylaw now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session so first we will begin
with java programming languages in that
we will have a quick introduction to
java then we will understand the java
developer skills responsibilities rules
and salary
then we will understand the java
developer job opportunities later
followed by that we have the operators
in java then we have the operators in
java that is the automatic operators
unary operators comparison operators
bitwise and followed by that we have
loops in java where we will understand
do while loop while loop for loop later
we will understand the enhanced for loop
nested follow and then we have the
access modifiers in java once we are
done with the access modifiers we will
learn about the oops concepts in java
starting with encapsulation then we have
abstraction later we'll learn
inheritance then interface in java once
we are done with it we will enter the
polymorphism in java where we will
understand the method overloading and
method overriding once you are done with
the object-oriented programming
paradigms in java we will learn
exception handling in java once we are
done with exception handling we will get
into collections in java where we will
learn about array list linked list hash
set in java tree setting java map and
java hash map in java free map in java
and then once we are done with the
collections in java we will get started
with servlets in java and then we will
learn some advanced programming
paradigms in java later we will get
through the java interview questions
where we will learn some most frequently
asked java based programming questions
once we are done with java we will get
started with kotlin
in kotlin we will begin with
understanding a brief introduction to
kotlin then we will start the codelink
tutorial and in that we will learn about
qfl statements loops in kotlin codelink
functions courtland manipulations
courtland routines and finally coatland
jetpack tutorial so this will be our
agenda for today's session i i hope the
agenda was clear now without further ado
let's get started with our first concept
over to our training experts hi guys
welcome to this video that will tell you
everything you need to know about the
class-based object-oriented programming
language java
java is an object-oriented programming
language that is used in a distributed
environment on the internet it is a
high-level language that is easy to read
and understand
java is popularly used in console
graphical user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded systems apart from
these java is also used to develop
software for devices it is used not only
in computers and mobiles but even in
electronic devices like televisions
washing machines air conditioners and so
on online forms banking and shopping are
possible because of java
java is a computer-based programming
language invented by james gosling and
sun microsystems in 1991. he had a
single moto while creating the language
it was right once run anywhere this
meant that the code would have to be
written only once but it could be used
anywhere they named this language oak
because of the oak tree outside
gosling's office later it was named
green then to java coffee which was
named after the coffee from indonesia
and finally to java in 1995.
there are three editions of java each
programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have java
standard edition this edition contains
core libraries like java.lang java.util
etc secondly we have java enterprise
edition this edition has apis like jms
ejb jsp servlets etc and lastly we have
java micro edition which is used to
program java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on
java is an object-oriented programming
language based on c and c plus plus
however it is improved and simplified to
solve the errors in programming java
files are converted to bit code format
using a compiler and then executed by
the java interpreter the whole java code
is run on the java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main concepts in java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching tv you use the tv remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class classes are used
to organize code just like how fruits
vegetables and clinical products are
divided into different sections in a
supermarket
there are a lot of features in java
let's start by looking at them one by
one it has a simple syntax and is very
easy to understand and learn java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the c and c plus languages
java also has features like garbage
collectors and exception handling this
makes java very unique the most popular
feature of java is that it is platform
independent here compilation happens in
byte code and because of this java can
run on any machine it is a very secure
language as it contains no virus
java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
java do multitasking java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all java is not as fast
as c and c plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops concepts in java java has
four concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the java code secure
data is stored within the classes and it
is not easy to access the data the next
feature is inheritance as the name
suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ so
what is java
it is a fast reliable and secure
programming language that can be used in
several websites and applications
it can be used to create applications in
a single computer or one that could be
distributed across several servers and
clients
java can be used in several scenarios
independent of the system that it is
used on
so let's look into what java development
kit means
all the java applications and applets
are developed using the java development
kit that is jdk
now the jdk consists of the java runtime
environment
an interpreter
a compiler
an archiver
and a document generator and a few more
tools that go into developing a java
program
so now let us have a look at the
components of jdk
java runtime environment jre primarily
is a part of jdk and it can also be
termed as java rte
the jdk provides the minimal amount of
requirements needed to write and compile
a java program
jre consists of the jvm supporting files
and the core classes
the jvm is key to both jdk and the jre
because it is embedded into them
now whichever java program is being run
the jvm is that component of java that
executes a program line by line thus
giving itself the work of an interpreter
we are now in a position to deep dive
into the process with which jdk jre and
jvm work
let's take a source file
and save it with the extension dot java
this file is compiled and converted into
a set of byte code which changes the
file extension into dot class
this is done specifically by the jdk
now here are the steps that follow class
loader
it makes sure that all the necessary
classes are loaded in the time of the
execution of a program next
bytecode verifier that is jvm
the bytecode verifier checks the code
for errors or irregularities based on
access rights on objects or
implementation of pointers
it makes sure that the code fulfills the
specifications of jvm and does not break
the system integrity
and finally interpreter which is jvm
now while running the program the
interpreter loads checks and runs the
code the implementation is made by the
jre which is the final process
the latest release is jdk 9 and it was
released in october 2017
but it was in jdk 8 that a new feature
called the java lambda expression was
introduced that changed the face of java
now java lambda expression is a kind of
function which does not need any class
to be created
it has been included in the latest
version of jdk as it provides a clear
concise way to pass functions around
this also replaces earlier bulky
anonymous classes and reduces code
verbosity that is the length of the code
the syntax for the lambda expression is
this
argument list
arrow token body
now the syntax consists of three
components which are
argument list
this can be empty or non-empty
next the arrow token now this is used to
link argument to body and finally body
this contains the statement that works
with the function
let us now just see an example of using
lambda expression and contrasting it
with how code would have been written
with anonymous classes
this is the old method
and this is the new method with lambda
expression
just have a look at how lambda
expression syntax has been used over
here the jdk 9 has been released
recently and it seems promising with
respect to new features and abilities
here are some of the features
the first one is java platform module
system
this module allows strong encapsulation
and declare explicit dependencies
next
j shell
with the help of j shell one can
directly start writing the code on the
console and execute them
improve java doc
java docs have got the search right in
the api documentation and as an added
bonus the output is also compliant to
html5
next stream api
the stream api also introduced in java 8
allows programmers to easily parallelize
code for improved concurrency and
introduces functional programming
abilities to the language
the stream api in conjunction with
lambda expressions also comes in handy
while iterating filtering and extracting
large amount of data
the release of multi jar
makes it possible for codes to be run on
the newer versions of jdk to be released
welcome to this video where we'll be
telling you how you can install java on
your windows 10 operating system after
we're done with this installation we'll
also show you how you can run a very
simple program so now let's get started
so now let's download java let's go to
google and search for java download
we'll go to the link we see here
oracle.com so now here we have the web
page
here we can see java se13 so this is
version 13 but this isn't the one we are
going to download we are going to
download the eighth version version 8
which is here now we're doing this
because 8 is one of the more commonly
used versions of java
so let's click this
and here we'll go down we need to accept
the license agreement before we can
download it
now we have two versions here x86 and
x64 now you can download it depending on
what version your operating system is
now if you do have a windows 10
operating system it's highly likely you
have a 64-bit version of windows now if
you do have a 32-bit version of windows
you can take the x86 so let's download
this
so we've actually already logged in so
we just need to run the installer file
now let's go to downloads
and run the file
so here we have the installer we go to
the next step
we'll select this to next here we can
see where the file is being installed
too we'll go to next
now if you want to change where you want
to install java we can press the change
option i'm just going to keep it here
we'll press next and let's commence with
installation
and there we go the installation is now
complete so we don't need any tutorials
or api documentation so we'll just
finish off and go to close
now to see if java is installed in your
system
we can go to command prompt
and type the term java c
which refers to the java compiler
now as you can see here this shows a
number of different options you can
choose from this also indicates that
java has been successfully installed in
your system now if the installation was
not successful you'll see something like
java c is not recognized as an internal
or external command operable program or
batch file but since we've done it
successfully this is what will be shown
now
and now we're going to set an
environment variable now what exactly is
an environment variable now assume you
have a file which has a dot java
extension this environment variable
tells the computer that the java program
needs to be called to run this
particular file
so to set the environment variable we'll
need to go to control panel
here go into system and security
go to system
and select advanced system settings and
then this shows up now before we go into
environment variables we'll need to go
to where the java file was installed so
let's go to this pc
c drive
program files
and here let's go to java
so let's go to jdk which is the java
development kit let's go to bin here
and copy this path
we'll go back to environment variables
select path here
and then press on new
paste this
and okay now we'll go back
and go to jre to the path of jre which
is java runtime environment
we click on this
pin again
and copy this path
select this one
new
and paste that
and there we go the environment
variables are now set
now let's talk about running that simple
program i told you about now this is
possible with the help of an ide an ide
or integrated development environment
will give us a platform to code java we
will be using eclipse and intellij as
they are popular and commonly used that
being said there are several other ides
that are available in the market so now
let's work with eclipse let's go to
google and search for eclipse
we'll go to this
link press download and then this shows
up let's click on download
now we've already downloaded the
software so i'm just going to directly
go into the install phase
downloads and select eclipse with this
you can see that there are multiple
options for you to choose from so we're
going to select eclipse ide for java
developers now you have other options
like for cnc plus plus javascript php
and so on let's go to the first one and
here you have the details you can change
them if you want but i'm just going to
go ahead with installation now
press accept now
here we remember accepted licenses and
press accept
and then here as well we'll remember
accepted certificates select this one
and accept selected
and there you go the installation is now
complete let's click on launch now
so here we are setting up a directory as
a workspace i'm not changing it here so
i'm just going to go with launch
here we have the eclipse workspace now
let's close this first and here we have
the package explorer now in case this
doesn't show up you can go to window
show view
and select on package explorer
so now let's go to file
new and java project we need to set up a
project name i'm going to call it my
project
one
click next we'll go to source so this is
where the source code for your
program is going to be stored then let's
finish and now we'll click on my project
one
go to source
i click new
and create a class let me explain
i'll name the class my class
and create it
and here we have it so now let's write a
simple program to multiply two numbers
so now let's write the main function
open
bracket
now we're going to initialize the first
number
now the second one
and finally the output
and finally the variable that will store
the output
now we'll just give them a simple print
statement
now let's run the code by clicking this
option here
using my cluster java and there we have
it here the product is shown to be 100
indicating that the program is running
successfully
now we're done with eclipse now let's
move on to the other idea i was talking
about which is intellij so for that
again we'll have to go back to google so
that we can download it
search for intellij download go to this
link here so here you can see that we
have two options the ultimate edition
and the community version
now here the ultimate version has way
more options as you can see here but
it's a paid version and only has a free
trial now the community version is free
so that's what we're going to take so
we'll click on download here so i've
already downloaded the software so i
don't need to do it again
so i'm going to go to downloads
and
so here we go let's just click on next
select the location where you want to
install it press next now we will add a
64-bit launcher shortcut on the desktop
and create association so basically this
means that these are the different file
extensions that this will support so dot
java dot groovy and now let's go to the
next step we'll install now and we'll
wait and there we go the installation is
now complete
let's not import any settings
we'll accept the privacy policy we'll
set defaults
now let's create a new project so here
make sure your project sdk is set to the
version of java you've installed make
sure this isn't blank we'll go to next
here you need to select this option
which is the create project from
template and we are now going to create
a command line application
press next
name the project which i'm going to call
my approach
to
you can change the location if you want
i'm just going to keep it the way it is
and then click on finish
so now we're going to create a simple
program through which based on the
user's input we can determine whether a
number is even or odd so first we're
going to import the package scanner
through which we can take the user's
input
next let's go inside here let's create
the available
reader
now let's ask for the user's input
enter a number
we're taking in the value now
in the variable num
reader
dot next int
so this is with which we'll be taking in
the value from the user
so we're going to set up a condition to
determine whether the number is even or
not
so if the number
when
when divided by 2 provides the remainder
0 it indicates that it's an even number
we'll show them then
now for the else case
the number is not even
or in this case odd
there we go
we're done so let's run this program
so let's enter 12
the number is even
and there we go we have a successful
output this indicates that the program
is running successfully an ide is an
integrated development environment on
this computer programmers can perform
software development now eclipse is one
of several in the market like intellij
bluej doctor java and so on now to
install eclipse first you need to
install java this is because if you try
to run the eclipse installer this shows
up this shows that you do need java
before you can install eclipse on your
operating system so first let's go and
download java now let's search for java
install
and then go to this link now here we
have the latest version which is version
13. we're not going to pick that one up
we're going to go to version 8. now
we're choosing version 8 because this is
one of the most commonly used versions
of java so let's select this so we'll go
down all the way here and here we can
see two options the 64-bit and the
86-bit so this basically represents the
32-bit operating system so if you do
have one you can select this option
since we have a 64-bit operating system
i'm going to select this but before the
installation you need to accept license
agreement and select this now i've
already logged in so i'm just going to
install now select this go to downloads
click on this and then this shows up
we'll go to next we'll go to next and
let the install complete
so here we have another pop-up so if you
want to change the destination folder
you can select this option this is fine
with me so i'm going to go in next
that's it we'll let the installation
complete now so there you go the
installation is now complete so if you
want to look at tutorials or
documentation you can go to the next
steps i don't want to so let's close and
go back now just because we've installed
java we can't exactly run it yet for
that we need environment variables now
environment variables help the computer
understand that it needs to run java
when it sees a dot java file for that
let's go to the control panel
let's go to system and then let's go
here
and select advanced system settings and
then this shows up now before we can set
the environment variables we'll need the
path to where java is installed so let's
go to file explorer let's click c drive
let's go to program files so this is
where i install java let's go to java
first let's go to jdk and bin now let's
go back here click on environment
variables select a path here go back
let's copy that
and press on new and paste this now
likewise let's go back go to jre which
is the java runtime environment and jdk
which is the java development kit click
on this go to bin and select this path
go back go to path
select new and paste this as well and
there you go the environment variables
are now set let's click on ok and that's
done now let's install eclipse let's go
back again and search for eclipse
in here select this option click on
download select 64-bit so and this shows
up so i've already downloaded it so we
can directly go there i'm going to click
on this now so now we have the installer
show up so here you can choose from a
number of different options like cc plus
plus php and so on so you want this one
you click on this and here we can just
install we'll accept and there you go
the installation is going on right now
we'll remember accepted licenses except
this you need to accept these
certificates except selected and there
you go we're complete let's launch
so now we need to set up a directory so
i'm okay with this so let's launch
and there you go here's the workspace so
let's run a very simple program now so
we'll close this and here you have the
package explorer let's open this up so
in case you can't access the package
explorer go to window click on show view
and select package explorer now first to
run a program you need to create a java
project click on this and let's name our
project let's go to next and here you
see src or source now this is where the
source code of your program is now we'll
just finish
and that's that now we go to source
right click new and create class now
let's create a class
class
1 and finish and now we should be able
to run any program we want let's look at
the very simple code of writing hello
world
so let's open the main function
there you go let's open a bracket here
let's print
and that's that now let's run the
program by clicking on this icon let's
select the class and there we go we have
an output this means the program is
running successfully let's begin with
the fundamentals so the first one in the
fundamentals is the data types so every
programming language has a data type so
what exactly is a data type so whatever
the input you provide in your program is
a data type for example if you provide
numbers so in that particular numbers we
have a different variety of numbers if
you are given just 1 2 3 so on without a
decimal number then that particular type
of input which is a number will be
considered as integer type if you
provide the same number with a decimal
point then that will be considered as
float and if you have the range greater
than float it will be considered as
double and so on so this is how we have
multiple data types in every programming
language so the most frequently used
data types in java programming languages
are as follows at first we have the byte
followed by that we have short and long
next float then double boolean and
finally care apart from this we also
have few other data types but these are
the most frequently used ones for all
the basic programmings so this is made
for beginners basically so you can take
a quick screenshot of this particular
slide so that you can have a quick
overview or reference to all the data
types in java programming language so i
hope you have taken a screenshot of this
now let's begin with the next concept so
in the next concept we have the keywords
and variables so all the programming
languages have variables and keywords so
variables are used to store the values
so for example consider that you wanted
to run some automatic operation on two
different values that is 5 and 10. so in
order to do so you might want to create
a variable which stores them for example
you wanted to store the value of 10 in a
certain variable a and the 5 in a
certain variable b so if you apply the
arithmetic operation that is a is equals
to a plus b then the value of a which
was previously 10 will be updated to 15
so here you can see the value is varying
and also it is storing the result so
this is why the variables are used in a
program in order to store a value and
this particular term variable is used
because the value can change at any
instance of time once after a certain
arithmetic or a logical operation is
performed on that particular variable so
similarly we have keywords unlike
variables keywords have a special
meaning no matter whatever you try you
cannot change the meaning of that
keyword for example consider main so you
cannot use the term main for normal
things because the part or the term main
is dedicated for a different purpose so
whenever you try to execute your java
program the control flow will start
executing the program right when it
reads the term main
so it has a special meaning similarly
you have other keywords such as end so
that is dedicated for integer type of
values and float for float type of
values that is a decimal values and byte
for byte care for character type data
string for string
so every keyword or every term with
special meaning which is predefined and
cannot be changed is called as a keyword
now let's see the most frequently used
keywords in java programming language so
similar to the previous one we have a
table here so in this particular table
we have the most frequently used
keywords in java so you can see we have
boolean final byte
native and we have void switch so switch
is a
conditional statement so we have if if
it is also a conditional statement we
will go through this conditional
statements as we proceed in our tutorial
and you can also see the protected so
this term which is protected public so
this is basically the access modifier
even this particular keyword have
special meaning this public this
protected keywords
provide the information to the compiler
or the interpreter about the
accessibility of that particular data
member or data manipulating method so if
it is protected from your accessibility
or is it available for you it's provided
by these keywords so we will deal with
access modifiers in the upcoming parts
don't worry about that and as you can
see we have implements extends so
extension this term comes in inheritance
so inheritance is one of the crucial
concepts of object-oriented programming
can also see abstraction so this we will
be dealing in the next upcoming part
where we will understand the
object-oriented programming concepts
next we have interface return and so on
you can also see some keywords like
through so throw will come in exception
handling so we will also learn about
exception handling in the upcoming part
so these are the most frequently used
keywords in java so now we will move
ahead into our next concept so the next
concept is the operators in java so to
understand operators let's go through a
table so on my screen you can see a
table which has some arithmetic
operators which are most commonly used
that is the plus for addition minus the
subtraction similarly we have star
forward slash double plus double minus
so double plus and double minus say they
are increment and decrement operators
respectively as you can see we have a
plus plus here which means the post
increment so the first value will be
read after that the value will be
updated next we have the pre-increment
the value will be incremented first then
the updated value will be stored so
that's that's how the increment and
decrement operators work so we have the
modulus over here so to understand the
operators that we use in java in a much
better way let's try to execute a sample
program so on my screen you can see a
program which is based on operators so
we are currently on the eclipse ide
don't worry about the ids and java etc
etc so i will drop a link in the
description box below which will explain
you in a very detailed way about how to
install java into your local system and
how to install eclipse ide in your local
system and also how to create your first
project how to create your package how
to create a new class how to write your
program and how to run that how to see
the output and a complete overview of
the eclipse ide how that works so
everything will be linked in the
description box below you don't have to
worry about that so right now to save
time i have created the text document
which has all the programs that we will
be executing today so i will also drop a
link for that particular file so that
you can have complete access to that
file so that you can run the programs in
your personal
pcs or laptops and also understand the
programs in a much better way so now
let's begin with the program so this
particular program is basically designed
for automatic operations so you can see
we have the operators that is the
addition subtraction multiplication
division modulus and exit so basically
we will be taking input from mu so the
input will be taken by the user that is
we're using scanner class here so
scanner class takes the input from user
and that particular input will be
compared here so we are using the switch
case here so if you provide the option
as one then edition operation will be
run similarly second force abstraction
third for multiplication fourth for
division fifth for modulus and sixth to
exit so this is how the
loop or the program works for automatic
operations now let's quickly run this
program and see the output so you can
see the program got successfully
executed and we have the console asking
for the first input let's provide some
random number now
let's provide the second number so there
you go we have our options over here now
let's choose
division operation for that we need to
provide the number four so there you go
we have the result over here which is 4.
now the loop has started once again now
it's in the starting stage again it's
asking for numbers now let's provide a
25
and
five uh now let's choose some operation
that is addition so for that you need to
provide one so we have the result again
that is 30.
now
let's again choose some number 10
5. so basically that's how the program
works so we have the brief idea how the
program is running now so now let's
quickly continue with our next topic now
to terminate this loop you can provide
the option number six so we have
terminated it so i hope you understood
how the program flow is running so if
you did not understand don't worry i
have linked the
document in the description box below
you can take the access of that
particular document and you can check
the program and run in your local system
and also you can make some modifications
to it as you can see we don't have a
default case over here i've just placed
the case 126 and i'm seeing the default
because you can see that the options are
from one to six what if the user
provides the number as seven right so
the program might crash over here so for
that purpose you can write in another
case that would be the default case so
the default case will check if the
number is anything above or out of the
range of one to six then it should be
providing you with an output saying a
wrong input has been given or check your
input or something similar so that's how
you can make some modifications to it
you're free to modify the code as well
don't worry about that so now let's
quickly begin with our next concept so
in the next concept we have the
conditional statements so what are the
conditional statements or the control
statements so basically these are some
yeah these are conditions so what
happens is just imagine that
you wanted to do something or if you
wanted to drive a vehicle or if you
wanted to drive a bike so the condition
you will apply on your mind is if i know
driving then i will do it if not i'll
not do it so that's what you do right so
basically you apply a condition on your
mind and you do it if it is capable of
doing or if you are capable of doing it
so in the same way the conditional
statements play a major role in computer
logic so before writing a code or before
you start your program you provide the
condition perform this particular
operation if the provided condition is
satisfied so similarly you have
these three conditional statements in
java which are if if else and nested if
so we use these conditional statements
in java to implement our logic so we
will understand the conditional
statements particularly if if else and
nested if in a much more detailed way by
practically running some programs based
on these three types of conditional
statements so now you can see that we
are back on the eclipse right now so
this particular code segment is based on
the if condition i hope the program is
visible let's try to increase the font
size so i think it's better now so
basically we have
an input so we have the integer type of
input that is num and we have the number
as -100 so it is a negative number and
after that we have the if condition so
this is where the conditional statement
is provided so the condition is if the
number is greater than 0 if the provided
number is greater than 0 then the
control should enter the loop which is
this particular segment and execute the
statements present inside that
particular loop so here we have one
single statement that is a print
statement that says the number is
positive in case the condition fails
imagine that the condition
fails then what happens is that instead
of entering this particular code segment
this particular code segment the control
will skip and execute the next statement
that is another printf statement which
we have over here which says the if
condition is terminated control is
outside the condition block now since we
have provided a negative number the
second option should go ahead now let's
try to run this and see the output so
there you go as expected the program got
executed and we have only one statement
that is if condition is terminated
control is outside the block now let's
write otherwise let's just eliminate the
negative number and now check it again
there you go now you can see the program
got executed and now we have two print
statements you can see that the
condition here was true so the control
entered into the statement or the code
block and this particular statement got
executed successfully once the
statements are executed and there is
nothing else to do then the control will
automatically exit this particular
statement and it will enter into the
next statement which is another printf
statement and we have the same output
over there so this is how the single if
statement works so you can also modify
this with an else so that's the next
program that we are going to see we are
going to execute some similar kind of
example
for our next kind of conditional
statement that is if else so here only
we had one if condition so in case if
this particular condition fails then we
will be having another condition over
here which will be the else block so as
you can see we have another program so
this particular program is based on if
else condition so here you can see that
we have our first if condition which
states number should be greater than or
equals to zero if this particular
condition is true then this statement
should be executed which says the number
is positive else else if this condition
fails then what you must do the control
should avoid entering this particular
segment and it should directly hit the
next segment where we have the else
block which has another statement which
says the number is negative so this is
how the program works so here we will be
doing a little modification over there
instead of taking an input which is
previously defined as it was in the
previous example where we had given -100
previously we are going to do it a
little differently this time we'll be
taking or reading the input directly
from the user so for that we are going
to use this scanner class so this is the
particular library that we will be using
so we have imported java.util.scanner
so this particular code segment will ask
you for the input and you will press
some random number and it will read it
as its input now let's try to quickly
run this program and see the output
there you go the program was
successfully executed and now it is
asking for an input from the user now
let's try to provide a negative number
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that since we had given a negative
number the control did not enter this
particular code segment at all it
directly avoided to enter this code
segment and entered into the else block
and executed the statements present in
that particular else block which was a
simple print statement that had the
statement which read as the number is
negative now let's try to execute the
same program again and see what would be
the output so there you go now it's
asking for the input again now this time
let's provide a positive number so there
you go since we provided the number as a
positive number this condition was true
and this particular statement got
executed since one of the statements
executed there was no need for the else
block to be executed again so you can
see this particular code segment runs in
this way so once the condition is
checked so if the condition is true then
the true statement will be executed in
case if the conditions result is false
then the false statements will be
executed so you will be provided with
two options so one option for true
validity and another option for false
validity so this is how the if else
block works i hope you understood this
now with this let's continue with the
next type of conditional statement that
is the lzf ladder so on my screen you
can see there is a change of program we
have stepped into the next type of
conditional statement that is the lsf
ladder so basically everything will be
seen we will be provided with only one
condition so we will be checking the
validity of that particular condition so
if the provided condition is true then
the first one will be executed if it is
not then the second one will be executed
if the condition fails for the first two
the third one will be executed if the
first three failed and the fourth and if
all the four fails then we will have one
last else which will print the last
segment or statement so this is how the
else ladder works so basically it's
completely similar to if else but the
only difference is instead of one else
block we have multiple else blocks
that's the only difference now let's
quickly execute this program and say the
output so basically we are going to
take an input from the user so we will
be entering one for noodles two for
milkshake three for fruits four for
coffee so something like that and if we
provide anything else then one two three
four then we will be having an else
statement which says it's an invalid
input so the flow of this particular
relative statement is similar to the
switch statement having said that we
will also discuss something about switch
statement as well basically we'll try to
execute a program based on a switch
statement and we'll also understand the
control flow of that don't worry about
it now let's quickly execute this
particular program first so there you go
the program got successfully executed
now it's asking for an input uh let's
select noodles that's how it works we
have the output nodals so the choice is
equal to is equals to one so the first
one was true so it executed the first
code segment and everything else got
suspended because this was not necessary
to be executed because the condition was
true over here and according to that
only this particular statement was
supposed to be executed so that's how it
works now let's switch into the next
conditional statement which is the
switch so you can see that we have a
program on my screen which is based on
switch case so you can see that there is
some similarity between this particular
program and the first program we dealt
with that is based on operators so we
also have the default code segment over
here so this was what i was talking
about you can add a default code segment
in that particular program which is a
operators program and do some
modifications so this is what the
suggestion i gave over there now
basically what happens in this
particular code segment is so we have
monday as the day one of a week tuesday
at the day two of the week and so on so
uh to select one particular day of a
week you need to provide an input so
it's based on one two three four and so
on to seven and if you provide anything
else than one two seven you will be
provided with an message which says
invalid input so now let's try to uh run
this program and see the output so there
you go the program got successfully
executed now let's select the weekend
day
so which would be something between six
and seven so six is saturday and seven
is sunday let's go with seven so there
you go sunday now let's try to execute
this program once again and give a wrong
input and see if it works or not let's
provide eight
there you go the program identified it
as a wrong input so it gave us a message
invalid input so that's the use of
default code segment in switch case so
you can implement this in that operators
program and check out how it works can
be considered as a homework though not a
problem now this is how the switch case
works so with this let's move ahead into
the next concept in our java tutorial
for today so the next segment is about
the loops
so what are loops
so conditional statements are
some statements which get executed based
on a condition if the condition is true
if not then that particular condition
will not be executed loops are a little
different from conditional statements
how so basically you will be provided
with one single statement and you wanted
to execute that one single statement for
a particular number of times so in that
condition instead of writing the same
code segment for several number of times
you can just use a loop for example
consider that you wanted to print
numbers from 1 to 10. so the brute force
method or the simple or the first method
that fires to your mind is write that
print statement for 10 times that is
print 1 print 2 print 3 and so on to
print 10 but what if you had to print
100 numbers
ok
doable you can write the same print
statement for 100 times but what if you
had to print thousand numbers
imagine 1 billion can you do 1 billion
print statements no right so in that
scenario you can use loops so you can
just write one condition repeat this
particular print statement for one
billion times then the interpreter or
the compiler will take care of that so
that's the reason why we use loops in
java so basically we have three loops in
every programming language that is the
for loop while loop and do while loop so
a loop statement in java execute a set
of statements until a specific condition
is satisfied so here the one billion
example so here you will start from the
zeroth count so that will be the counter
variable which counts the number of
repetitions and followed by the counter
variable you will be having the
condition so you will be having the
count of variable i i is less than or
equal to the number 1 billion so until
that you have to print this particular
statement and followed by that you will
be having the increment or decrement
operator in this case you need to use
the increment operator for the first
time once the print is done you will
increment the value to 2 and the loop
will be iterated once again so this will
continue the loop will iterate itself
until 1 2 3 4 so on and until it reaches
1 billionth number so that's when the
condition fails i is greater than or
equal to 1 billion so that's when the
condition fails the condition was to be
i should be less than or equal to 1
billionth so when the number increments
above 1 billion then the condition fails
so the condition was the number should
be less than or equal to billion but the
number has exceeded the billion so
that's when the loop terminates and
executes the next statement after the
loop so i think this was a little clear
about the loop workflow now to
understand the loops in a much more
better way let's execute an example for
each one of these types of loops so we
have for loom while loop open do while
let's execute the programs for all of
these three so you can see that we have
a program on my screen so this
particular program is based on for loop
so you can see that the code part
highlighted on my editor is the follow
so you can see int i is equals to 1 so
this is the counter variable so i is the
counter variable which stores a number
from where the count should begin so
sometimes you can choose 0 sometimes 1
or the number of your choice so here i
have chosen the number one so after the
initialization part we have the
condition part so remember the one
billionth example we discussed before so
here we have i should be less than or
equal to 10. so this particular loop
segment will run until the condition
that is i value should be less than or
equal to 10 is satisfied once it turns
false the control will exit the for loop
so that's how it's designed to work with
now followed by the condition we have
the pre-increment operator once the
condition is checked the control will
jump to the next statement that is the
pre-increment operator and it increments
the value of 1 to 2. so this is how the
loop works now let's try to execute this
program and see the output there you go
the program got successfully executed
and the output has been printed so
basically what was the statement to be
executed it was a printf statement
looped plus here the plus symbol works
as a concatenation operator here too now
in between the printf statements we have
the value of i so in the first place i
was equals to 1 once the pre-increment
was taken place the value of i will be
increased to 2 so there you go you can
see the number 2 over there now in the
second iteration we print the value
looped two times similarly in the third
iteration looped three times so that's
how it works until the last iteration
that is looped 10 times so once the
condition is checked here the control
will enter into the next part where the
pre-increment takes place so the
pre-increment increments the value of 10
to 11. now the control will come back to
the initialization part here we have the
new value for i that is 11. now 11 will
be checked against the condition is 11
less than or equal to 10
no right so the condition here fails
now the loop is terminated the control
will exit the loop so this is how the
for loop works
now let us also consider another example
for follow for a better understanding so
in this particular program we are going
to
print the sum of n numbers
so in that particular n numbers we will
be having even numbers and odd numbers
for example consider that you have
provided the number as 5 so the numbers
in between 0 to 5 or 1 to 5 are 1 2 3 4
and 5. so the 4 is even number and apart
from 4 everything else are odd numbers
so odd numbers are the numbers which are
divisible by 1 or itself so now the sum
of odd numbers is 1 plus 2 is 3 3 plus 3
is 6 6 plus 5 is 11 so that's how you
print the sum of odd numbers and the sum
of even numbers that is only four so
that's how the loop works here you have
the condition if else condition and out
of that if else condition you have the
for loop so this particular loop should
be running until a given number that
will be given by you so that's how the
program works now let's quickly execute
this program and see the output so there
you go the program got successfully
executed and now it's asking for an
input let's check out five itself now
you can see we have another program on
my screen which is basically based on
the same for loop so here we have the
for loop we will be providing an input
which is num and inside that we have
another condition that is the if else
loop so basically if loop is dedicated
to find out the even numbers and l slope
is dedicated to find out the odd numbers
now the whole motto of this particular
program is to find the sum of even
numbers and the sum of odd numbers
between 0 to the input number which you
provide for example consider if we
provide the number 5 as the input then
in between 0 to 5 we have odd numbers
and even numbers so the even numbers are
2 and 4 and the odd numbers are 1 3 and
5. so basically what happens here is we
are going to add up the numbers so the
sum of even numbers that is 2 and 4 s 6
and sum of odd numbers that is 5 plus 3
is 8 8 plus 1 is 9. so that's how it
should work now let's quickly try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for an input now let's enter 5
itself and see the output so there you
go the sum of even numbers up to 5 is 6
and the sum of odd numbers up to 5 is 9.
so this is how the program works now
apart from for loop we also have another
way to declare the same for loop so that
particular type of for loop is called as
the enhanced for loop or in some cases
it's also called as advanced for loop
let's see how the for loop is declared
in a different way so instead of using
the typical for loop which has the
initialization state then the condition
then the pre-increment or post-increment
or decrement kind of operations we
simply have declared the for and inside
that we have end arr which is the name
of the variable of array type and inside
that we have the array so our array
consists of 10 numbers followed from 1
to 10 and now this particular loop will
execute for 10 times or until all the
values in the array are printed so now
let's try to print this so there you go
the program got successfully executed
and we have all our values from 1 to 10
which were the input or the saved part
of the array now with this let's
continue with the next kind of loop that
happens to be the while loop so you can
see an example based on while loop on my
screen so basically everything is same
there is no much of a difference between
for loop and while loop but the only
difference is the keyword instead of for
we have a vial over here so
so we have the while condition over here
which says i should be less than or
equal to num divided by 2 and if this
condition is true then the control
should enter into the conditional
statement if
num modulus i is equals to equals to 0
flag is equals to true and prick so
basically the whole motto of this
program is to find out if the given
particular number is a prime number or
not now let's quickly try to run this
program and see the output now you can
see the program got successfully
executed let us try to provide a prime
number and see if the program could
identify it correctly as a prime number
or not there you go the prime number we
provided was 5 and the program
successfully identified it as a prime
number so that's how the while loop
works now let's execute another program
based on while loop but this time we
will place the condition at the end of
the loop so yeah you guessed it right
this is do while loop the only
difference between while loop and do
while loop is that before the condition
is checked in while loop no statement is
executed but it's completely opposite
when it comes to do while loop first the
program or the code segment will be
completely executed after that the
condition will be checked surprising
right let's check out the practical part
yeah we have our program on my screen
right now so
in the previous program we had the
condition somewhere over here that's the
file condition but here we have the do
statement here so what we are going to
do is we are conveying the compiler or
the interpreter to execute this
particular statement first without
checking the
while condition so this is the only
difference between while loop and
do-while loop so we have run the program
successfully and it got executed and we
were supposed to actually print the
values of i from 1 to 20 and they have
printed over here that's how it works so
what are objects an object is an
instance of a class let's have a look at
an example in this example animal is a
class and dog is its object the object
dog has states and behaviors we can have
dogs with different breeds sizes and
colors these are considered as the
states of object dog on behavior side
dog has behavior like barking eating and
wagging tail so an object has its own
states and behaviors now let's look at
an example using java code there are
many platforms to run java program so
for this video i'll be using intellij so
let's create a new project let's name it
as project 1 and finish there we go we
have a new project with we have a class
with main and we have a main function so
the code that we write should always be
written in the main function so let's
create a new class to understand how the
object is used let's name it as student
we need variables so that we can access
the variables of this class so i am
going to use
student id with the integer type student
name
and student's age
there we go now we have these three
variables that we can use so let's go to
our main program and start our coding so
we have a class named student now let's
see how to create a object of a class
this is the syntax to create object now
the object here is s i created an object
as of class student now let's assign
values to the variables for this we use
the object s and use the dot operator
and we have options from which we can
choose from that we declared in the
class student so for this i'll use id
and give a value similarly i'll give age
and give a value and finally let's give
a name
now we'll print its value
now we are going to run this program
let's see what output will get
and there it is we have name
that's simply learn we have age and we
have id
now let us see an example how we can use
multiple objects for a single class so
let's get started let's create a new
project and i'm gonna name it as
vehicles because i'm gonna use cars and
bikes in this program so i'm gonna use
vehicles as a combined form and yes here
we have a class main and a function main
now i need two classes for this program
so i'm gonna create two classes first
i'm gonna name it as bikes and the
second class i'm gonna name it as cars
so let's create variables for these
classes so in cars first i need string
name
and i need the cost of the car so cost
can be integer as well because i'm going
to use dollar sign in that so i'm going
to use string because of that so same
thing i'm going to do with bikes
now that our classes are created let's
create objects for this class so the
process is same but we are going to use
different names for the object first the
car class and i'm gonna name as car1 and
yes we have created the first object now
to create the second object
similarly i am going to create five
objects of the class cars
and i'm gonna change the name for them
so i created five objects of the same
class so i'm gonna create five objects
of the bikes class as well so bike one
will be a bit longer so i'm going to use
b1 till b5
and i'm going to name them to from b1 to
b5 so now i'm going to assign values to
the variables that i created in classes
bike and cars so first i'm gonna go with
cars and let's name it as lamborghini
similarly
car to ferrari
so i'm gonna use names of the cars that
are very famous and costly so that
anyone over the world can understand
this so let's name car 3
i'm going to name it as bugatti
similarly car 4
pagani and car 5.
now i'm going to give names for bikes
i hope everyone will understand the
names that i give
b4
and b5
last one
yamaha
now let's assign the cost for bikes and
cars as well so the procedure is same so
let's do it 130 000
same b2 so b1 goes for harley davidson
b2 for ducati b3 for suzuki b4 for e cos
and b5 for yamaha i am going to assign
values for these values accordingly for
ducati 232 000
dollars
for suzuki 200 000
300 000
and the last one yamaha 500 000
now similarly i'm gonna assign values
for carbon dot cost till cart five dot
cost
203 thousand dollars for
lambo i think i can copy paste these as
well
so
let's
copy paste it lot faster and easier to
do
car 2 car 3
car 4 and car 5.
we don't need this
uh as for car 2 let's take it as 252
000 and
let's make it it's 3 million
uh as per this let's keep it as
one million
four hundred thousand and lastly uh
let's see is 293. now that we have
assigned all the values for all this now
let's print it and get the value i'm
going to create a very simple program
but a very user friendly program so it's
going to be interesting for you guys so
we are going to ask the users what would
they like either bikes or cars so we
need to give them the options and our
next program will be based on the
options that the users select not the
options we give as the command so let's
do it
let's give the options
one
[Music]
bikes
and two cars
i need to take the value that user gives
for this i'm gonna write this command
so i have not used scanner yet so let's
import
scanner
and let's create a object for scanner
and yes let's get back so the data type
of choice variable is integer that's why
i'm using next int if the data type was
string then i would have used next line
so now that we have choice from the user
let's use this value
if the user chooses the first value that
means bikes so the next thing we display
is we have models and we are going to
give five models for bikes to the user
here i am giving options to the users so
that they can choose easily from number
one to five
now we can show these options to the
users so that they can choose from one
of these value so let's use one more if
statement so that we can find out
whether they have this value or not
before that i am going to ask which one
would you like to choose
to enter the choice i am going to use
one more variable lets say n so i am
going to store n
if n is equal to equal to 1 that means
harley davidson then i'm gonna show the
cost of harley davidson
this is the syntax to print the value
for the cost or any of the variable that
we use in class
what if the user says second or third or
fourth or fifth so for that we are going
to use else if statements
if n is 2 that means ducati so we have
to show the rate of ducati or the cost
of ducati to the user
now similarly i i'm going to do for n is
equal to 3 n is equal to 4 and n is
equal to 5
now i'm gonna do for n is equal to four
and lastly n is equal to five that is a
last bike yamaha
what if the users put a number that is
not between one to five so for that i am
going to use else statement and put a
message that please enter the value from
1 and 5.
so now we have code for the bikes and
the same thing whatever the user selects
that he wants to find the car so for
that we have this the choice is equal to
is equal to one so the same thing we are
going to do for choice is equal to is
equal to 2
and the same thing we are going to tell
to user that we have 5 models
same names that i gave to variables i'm
going to give this to here
second one ferrari
third book rt
fourth e course
and the last one
[Music]
posh
now we are going to ask the users their
choice that which number do they want to
choose
now we need one more value so that we
can have it as a variable which can
store the choice of the user so for this
i am going to use c
now if c is equal to equal to 1 that
means if the user wants to see the cost
of lamborghini that he puts the choice
as 1 so we're going to display this
message the cost of lamborghini
we are going to use else if loop to
enter the next values for c from 1 to 5.
if c is equal to is equal to 2 that
means the user wants to know the rate of
ferrari then we are going to show the
cost of the ferrari
same thing if the user enters 3 as the
choice
if user enters 4 as their choice
then we go for e cos
and the last one if user enters the
choice as 5
then we have to display the cost of posh
now what if the user enters none of the
values from one to five then we have to
display a message
showing that
please enter the value
between
one to five
now remember the first choice that we
wanted from user to enter either bikes
or cars so what if the user do not enter
either one or two so for that we need
one more else function to tell the user
that either enter one or two
and with this we have completed our code
so now let's run this program for this
we need to go to run and then run main
there's a shortcut for it that is shift
plus f10 so let's run the program
and yes we have successfully executed
the program let's test this program now
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have five models harley
davidson ducati suzuki pagani and yamaha
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter 1
and yeah we have our result the cost of
harley davidson is 130 000
so with this we have completed our code
and please feel free to type this code
in your own computer and try out all the
permutation and combinations that you
can with this program so with this let's
move on to classes and understand the
classes and their concept then we'll
have a new program on classes now let's
see what is a class a class is a
blueprint from which objects are created
a class describes state or behavior of
an object in this example dog is a class
the variables in this class are breed
and color the functions or methods of
the class dog are barking hungry and
sleeping we use objects of a class to
use variables and functions of the class
with this let's understand classes with
a simple java code let's create a new
project
next tick the box and let's name it as
automobiles
let the base package be student and yes
we have a class
main now let's create some classes to do
code on
i'll create a new java class as cars
and then i'll create one more class with
the name bikes
and then one more class automobiles
so i'm gonna connect cars and bikes with
automobiles so that we can use that
program in main and see what can we do
with the classes that we create in
automobiles i need some variables
i'll take private double and let's say
fuel and then same thing private double
and then year and let's take one more
private string and brand now let's have
getters and setters for this so these
are used to get the value and set the
value for the variables inside the class
there we go
we have the getters and setters for it
now let's go to class cars
so public class cars extends automobiles
so in it i'm gonna create one more class
or a constructor
and i'm gonna print a message say a new
car has been created
car has been created now the same thing
i'm gonna do with bikes let's go to
bikes and
i'm gonna use the same thing extends
automobiles this is because i can
inherit all the variables from the
automobiles class
so i created a constructor and i'm gonna
print a message a new bike has been
created
so i have created class cars bikes and
automobiles so let's go to main program
so this is where we should write our
code so i'm gonna start with the code
now it's a very simple code i'm gonna
first i'm gonna create
the variables or the objects of the
class with private
bikes bike so one is car
and one is bike both are objects for the
classes so i'm going to use these
objects
bikes bike is equal to new bike
this is so that my object can function
really well and now i'm gonna run it
it'll take some time to run
and yes there we go our program has
executed and the things that i typed a
new car has been created a new bike has
been created are done now let's try
something else using the classes
so i'm going to bikes
so i'm going to create a new method or a
new function
public void kick for bike so i'm gonna
print message
the bike has been started with kick
bike has been started
with kick now the same thing i'm gonna
do with cars now how does a car start
with the key so i'm gonna make a
function public
key and inside it i'm gonna print the
same message car has been started with
key i should write void there to give
the return value as wide so let's print
the message
car has been started
with key rotation let's write that as
well so in the main program i'm going to
use objects to use those functions and
let's see what changes they'll do to our
program
pike dot cake and car dot cake let's run
this
and there we go first we used to have
this two messages but now these two
messages are also there as well because
we invoked
those functions and methods that are
there in class cars and bikes
so if i write bike dot key
or
car dot kick
this won't work
this is because key is not a method of
bike or kick is not a method of car so
that's why i gave private static for the
functions
so if i execute it these are the error
messages that i'll get cannot find the
symbol method kick or method key
what is an abstract class
the answer is abstraction is one of the
keys to achieving an object-oriented
programming approach and designing a
software
here the programmer tries to hide the
complicated implementation of the code
which makes the software run smoothly
most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it
to do so we use an abstract class or
sometimes an interface based on the
requirements so abstract class in java
is considered as a template of methods
and variables which are used in a
program
remember abstract classes cannot be
instantiated directly now moving ahead
we will next learn the important
features of abstract classes
so the first one is template
the main reason programmers prefer to
use abstract methods is because they act
as a predefined template
for any future specific class that you
might use
next loose coupling is a procedure where
an internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world that is other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible
after that we have the code reusability
implementation of the abstract classes
provides the developers with one of the
greatest features that saves time which
is none other than the code reusability
followed by code reusability we have
abstraction as discussed earlier data
abstraction is the process of hiding
certain details and showing only
essential information to the user
abstraction can be achieved with either
abstract classes or interfaces
last but not the least
dynamic method resolution
the abstract classes enable us with
dynamic method resolution or the dynamic
method dispatch process
the dynamic method resolution is a
mechanism by which a call to an
overrated method is resolved at run time
this is how java implements runtime
polymorphism
when an overridden method is called by
reference
java determines which version of that
method to execute based on the type of
object it refers to
now these were the few important
features of abstract classes next in the
docket is the crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes
all right let us go through the rules
one by one as mentioned below
the first one is
the keyword abstract is mandatory to
declare an abstract class followed by
that the next rule says that abstract
classes cannot be instantiated directly
the third one is an abstract class must
have at least
one abstract method
next to that we have another rule which
says an abstract class includes final
methods
next an abstract class may also include
non-abstract methods
it's not mandatory that an abstract
class should only include abstract
methods
so the last rule says that an abstract
class can include constructors and
static methods
so these were some crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes in java
so far we have discussed the definition
of abstract classes its features and the
rules to use abstract classes in java
now we will learn how to achieve
abstraction in java
so basically there are two different
ways to achieve abstraction in java the
first way is by using abstract classes
and the next one is by using an
interface
now this brings us to our next topic
that is the syntax to be followed to use
an abstract class and an abstract method
to declare an abstract class we use the
keyword called abstract followed by that
we use the keyword called class
then after that we declare the name of
our class
the name of the class is up to the
user's choice for example i have named
my class as simply learn as shown here
followed by the abstract class we have
the abstract method to declare an
abstract method we use the keyword
called abstract then the written type of
the method as of now i have used void
then later we have the name of the
method that is based on the user's
choice
as you can see i have used simplylearn
as the name of the method
so this was by using abstract last
method the next one is by using an
interface method
now what exactly is an interface
so interface can be defined as a
boundary between the method and the
class implementing it in java we use
interface to achieve abstraction
in other words we can also consider
interface as a container which saves the
signatures of the methods used in a
program
now we will move ahead and understand
the syntax to use an interface to
achieve abstraction in java
to declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface followed by
that we declare the name of a class
the class name is up to the user's
choice for example i have named my class
as simply learn as shown below
as discussed earlier interface acts just
as a container that stores only the
signatures of the method
we cannot have a complete method defined
inside it
all we can do is just declare an
interface
now that we have a detailed explanation
about the abstract class and the
interface let us look into some example
programs based on abstract classes
now we have successfully booted the
eclipse ide now let's create a new
project
so to create a new project just click on
create a project
and this should give you a dialog box
wherein you have to select java project
click next
now let us give a name to our project
so simply learn will be the name of my
project here now let me click on finish
to finish this process
as you can see the project has been
successfully created and inside the
project simply learn we have the source
file and right clicking the source file
will give us a dropbox where you can
just select new and inside new you can
select a new package
now let's name the package as
abstraction and click on finish to
create the package
moving further let's right click on the
package and select new and from new
select a class to create a new class
so the name of my class will be employee
let's click on finish to create the
class
now we have our employee class ready
now let's right click on the package and
select new and inside that
let us select another class
and the name of this particular class
will be person
which will act as our abstract class
so as you can see we have declared this
particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person
so our first example which is based on
employees where we will have an abstract
class called person and
this person class will be inherited by
the employee class
and gets executed to generate employee
details
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
to execute the program just right click
on the package and go to the run option
and select the first one that is java
application
now you can see we have the employee
named pavitra
and the gender is female and the
employee has logged in successfully so
these are the details which we were
expecting to be presented on the output
console now moving ahead we shall
execute our next example which will be
based on students
so here
the class student is the abstract class
and three different student classes
namely raju pranita and punit will
inherit the student class and generate
the output that displays their
particular ranks
so you can see our abstract class that a
student
is being declared using the keyword
abstract and inside that we have an
abstract method which is get rank
and these classes that are
raju pranita and punit will inherit the
abstract class student and display their
ranks
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console
now let us move ahead and try to execute
one last example
based on abstract classes
so the third and last example is based
on interest rates provided by different
banks
here we have an abstract class named
loan and all the banks described in the
program will inherit the loan abstract
class to calculate the rate of interest
on the loans provided by them
as you can see we have the abstract
class that is loan and inside that we
have the abstract method which is
interest so we have the classes andra
bank bank of baroda idbc bank state bank
of india which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
has been displayed in the output console
so with this we have entered into our
next topic where we understand the
differences between an abstract class
and an interface
so the first difference between the both
is the keyword
while we declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface
on the other hand when we declare an
abstract class we use the keyword
abstract
followed by that the second difference
is
when you use an interface the subclasses
basically implement an interface
while on the other hand when you use
abstract classes the subclasses extend
an abstract class and inherit the
properties of the abstract class
followed by that the third difference is
multiple interfaces can be implemented
but on the other hand only one abstract
class can be extended at one particular
instance
and the final difference between the
both is
interface is capable to support multiple
inheritance
whereas on the other hand abstract
classes are not capable to support
multiple inheritances multiple
inheritance is none other than the
diamond problem which is not supported
in java
now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract class
now first we will discuss the advantages
so the advantages of using an abstract
class in java are
the abstract classes are highly
beneficial in writing shorter codes
the abstract classes avoid code
duplication
they enable code reusability which is a
major advantage
and finally the last advantage is
changes to the internal code
implementation can be done without
affecting the classes
so these were few of the major
advantages of using an abstract class
now moving ahead we shall discuss the
disadvantages of using abstract losses
few of the disadvantages of using an
abstract class and java are
abstraction is expensive as sometimes
you need to handle cases and situations
which are not necessary
followed by that the second disadvantage
is
object relational impedance mismatch in
the case of rdbms
and the last disadvantage is object
relational mapping in case of frameworks
like hibernate
so these are the few important
disadvantages of using abstract classes
in java that you need to consider before
using them into your project
what is java interface
an interface is a container that stores
the signatures of the methods to be
implemented in the code segment
it's really hard to define
interface because it's the meta of meta
it's basically a control
object
and so you see these in projects
where whoever's in charge needs to have
a very high level of control what
everybody else is doing
do you have to have an interface when
you're doing programming no
but if you're in a large project you
probably want one as director or if
you're receiving it you might get the
interface which you're supposed to use
in your programming
so when we talk about the need for
interface in java uh it's a total
abstraction and it's only the methods
we're not talking about any variables or
anything like that just the methods
you can do multiple inheritance so you
can inherit from different interfaces
and you can do loose coupling
and when we talk about loose coupling
you can think of a hundred programmers
working on a huge huge software package
and they really don't know what the
other programmers are doing they can't
meddle with it they can't mess with it
they have like a nice direct place they
can do and they have the information
they need in the interface
so we'll talk about the syntax of the
java interface the interface then you
have your interface name and then you
declare your constant fields declare
your methods default method
and really to understand this we just
need to take a look at an example in
java interface and we're going to do the
java interface defined area
just kind of a fun little code for this
i'm going to jump into eclipse
and we'll go ahead and create a new
package there we go and we'll call this
um interface
and we're going to go ahead and add in
java and it won't let you do just
straight interface because that's a
reserved word we'll go ahead and create
that and then underneath our
package interface java
we want to go ahead and actually add in
an interface
and so we go underneath here new
interface
and let's go ahead and call this one
we'll call it area
interface area
and finish
so now we have our package and we have
our area and this is just the same
package we did with our
polymorphism and inheritance so now we
have a package and we've added the
object of an interface
and note that the interface is always
public you never have a private
interface because it's a metaphile
so it's always going to be accessed by
other people and by other
classes
and as we're creating these methods
this works just like you would any other
method i could easily put
integer
and then we have
maybe integer side one
integer
side two
so you can see how you can do
like for the setup this is going to be
just like you do the rest of your class
and the rest of your methods but we're
going to keep it simple
and we're just going to do void
square
and let's go ahead and do public
void
rectangle we'll put a rectangle in there
too
so now we have a basic interface
in this case for area
one of the cool things about interface
is i can go in here to
create another let me go back into my
interface java and we'll do another new
another interface
and we'll call this um
area
curves
i don't know just making that up uh so
we have our area curves and maybe in
this one
this one happens to be uh for
a circle so we have our curved areas let
me just go back in here
and maybe we'll do
not only a circle
but an oval
there we go so now we have our circle
oval or eclipse depending on what you
want to
use on here and i can go back to my area
and just like you can in
classes
this
extends
area
curves
so now i can also
do the extends or in the case of
inheritance same as in the class
exactly the same it just makes it easier
if you have a hierarchy of stuff coming
down in your interface
now we'll go back in here to the package
oops we're going to go back here and
create a class
and let's go ahead and do that in here
under our
interface
new
class
and we'll go ahead and call it shape
area and so now we have our new class
shape area how the heck do we use our
inheritance area in here
well we just go ahead and do implements
area
and so once we do that we now have
area which happens to extend area under
curves
and let's go back in here to
our shapes area the class
and what i want you to notice in eclipse
is the shape area has an underlying red
and if i hover my mouse for it it's kind
of hard to see here a little bit
i'll give you some options there which
will say
bring in your implements you're
implementing area but you didn't do
anything with it
that is what
interfaces are all about it's about
forcing someone to show an error here
now in eclipse i have it set so i won't
throw an error if i run the program but
it's going to tag it so even if i
compile it right now let me just go
ahead and run this even though it
doesn't do anything
it still has a shape area underlined
and then it comes up here and also puts
a little exclamation point at the top
and i actually do some actual coding in
here
let me go ahead and do that so you can
see what that looks like
there we go
we'll put in our main and we'll initiate
our instance of shape area
and we'll go ahead and run this
it doesn't actually do anything it's
going to compile all our different
pieces on here
and you still see the shape area is got
the red light underneath of it when it
pops up it says
hey you have some implemented methods
make type shape area abstract or you
know different solutions on there it's
because we don't have the actual code is
saying hey you were told to use what's
in area and you're not using it
again this is all about being in control
and so we have in here when we go back
into area
oops this area
curves let's go all the way to area
we have to have square and rectangle in
there and because this extends area
curves
we also have to have circle and oval
and so when we put that in there we have
to do an override
just so our package actually does
something let's go ahead and bring in
the scanner utility this is just
capturing your keyboard that's what
that's for the java utility scanner
and then we're going to go ahead and do
our override
use the at symbol
override
there we go
and then we go ahead and take a look at
what we had an area well an area we had
square so let's go ahead and grab the
square
this of course is just being very lazy
and not having to retype it uh so we
have our public void square
and then we wanted to do something in
here um in this case we want to go ahead
and create a scanner
for the keyboard
we'll do a new scanner
system in
and that's all that is is we're going to
do we're creating an object so we can
capture keyboard input and request
information from people
uh
and since this is a square uh let's see
we're not going to get too caught up in
the code here oops
there we go
and we'll go ahead and do geometry of a
square and compile it and run it
it still lets me compile and run it and
you can see down here it actually says
hey enter the length of the side of the
square we'll put in 5
and the area of the square is 25.
so when we look at just this part
we have it accesses the square
prompts us for our input does the math
of the square
and is fully functional but i want you
to look up here it still says this still
has an error it still says hey
you're missing the stuff in here you
don't have all the pieces you're
supposed to have in here
so if we're missing the pieces in the
implements of area we need to go ahead
and put those in
now we're not going to go through and do
all the different areas and walk through
each piece and we're going to look at
this when i put in our rectangle
which is you know we have the square in
the rectangle and then we had the circle
and the oval
you can see that the air goes away so i
no longer have a shape area with an
error on it and if i run that it of
course will still compile
there we go
and if i come down here
i forgot i got to put in the put in
something for the
square
we could also instead of square
just do you know whatever it is you'll
see the circle still functions although
it's just going to do a printout as
opposed to
what we had before it takes in all the
information computes the area
this is
what implements is about it's about
taking all this stuff and pulling it in
and forcing the programmer or the people
in the team
to use the different methods
that they need for that particular class
and there's one more
thing that we want to do and i'm going
to
i'm going to take this extends out here
and then we're going to go back to the
shape area and you're going to see it's
going to give me another error on here a
slightly different error
and the reason is is that i did
overrides
but these don't exist
so they don't know what i'm overriding
or what the setup is
and let's say instead of
importing area instead of having area
inherit area curves
we could also just implement area and
area curves
and then you'll see that the error then
goes away when i run the compiler
there we go
and this should be should remind you
something we talked about in inheritance
inheritance we were discussing in
classes
how you have a diamond effect you can't
inherit from two separate classes
you can implement two separate
interfaces
that means that if you have uh
you're the head of a project you can now
say hey this class needs these different
pieces
so it's a very powerful tool and it's
one of the ways to force programmers to
put in the modules they need
and get around the diamond effect
let's take a look at interface nesting
in java
nested inter interface is a procedure
declaring a new interface either an
existing interface or inside a class
and let's go back into here a little
play area let me just close these out
real quick
and let's go ahead and add another
package in and we'll do new
package
and we're going to call this um
instead of inner interface let's call it
nested
nested
interface there we go our nested
interface package finish
and once we're underneath this package
we want to go ahead and add in an
interface
and we'll put a new interface in it
we're going to call this
it's going to be a little confusing
interface outer
and then in our interface outer
we're going to go ahead and create an
interface
enter
let me put that in this so here's our
interface outer here's our interface
center and our void
inner method
and then let's go ahead and add in a
class new
uh class
and we'll call this the nested
oops
and we'll call this the nested
if for interface
and let's go ahead and finish that so
here's our class
and in our class we're going to go ahead
and import inner interface dot interface
outer dot interface enter
whoops forgot i changed the name to
nested interface for the package
so we're going to import from our
package nested interface
interface outer
interface enter and that just means that
we're going uh from here's our interface
outer
and here's our interface enter
you can
create a stack of interfaces so that
when you send the package out instead of
sending out 50 different interfaces you
can send one interface out with all the
sub interfaces embedded in it
and you can see it highlighted there the
nested if still comes up with an error
because we haven't done our override and
we'll go ahead and put in a public here
and we'll just do
initiate our
our nested iaf class
i guess nested if there we go so let's
go ahead and initiate that we're going
to have our object
equals a new
nested if
and again if we compile it
and go ahead and run it and i'll do the
compilation here
you can see that it compiles fine it's
not going to give you any errors but
when you hover over here it says hey you
need to
add unimplemented methods and you left
some stuff out of here that you were
told you're going to include which was
this interface enter
and of course we can simply do that
there we go make it look a little nice
do our override
and once we have our override we need to
go ahead and create the
method this is telling us we have to
have that method in there we're going to
get an error
and that was our inner method that we
included and then it's whatever we
decided to do in here
let's say we wanted to go ahead and
and we want to find the first 15 prime
numbers
and our
team in the back put the other little
piece of code for that it's always fun
to throw something in interesting so
you're not just looking at a print i did
something really cool here
i can get boring after a while
so we'll go ahead and do integer we're
going to iterate equals zero number
equals 0 x equals 1 y equals 1.
and then while number is less than 15 y
equals 1 and we iteration equals 0.
so forth you can see here we're doing
what is if you divide is there any
leftover if there is no leftover
then
that means it's divisible we know we're
not that's not a prime otherwise if the
iteration equals two system out is going
to print the number
um and then we're gonna add another
number to it and just keep looping
through
so you can see right here this is just a
simple instead of code but there goes my
error my error is gone that's what's
important we have our inner method
there's no more error on here because
we've now included it that came from our
nested setup on here
and of course if we're going to put a
code in there to count the prime numbers
we should probably go ahead and do our
object method and run that
there we go and sure enough we have our
2 3 5 7 eleven there's our list of prime
numbers
so just to kind of hammer at home what
is the difference between interface
versus class
interface keyword used is interface
keyword used for class is class
interface does not include instructors
where class has its constructors in
there
interface stores only methods only the
method signature
where class has the storage of the
actual definition so just a signature
versus a full
method in there
there's no access specifiers in the
interface where of course there is
access specifiers are needed in class
no data members
includes data members in class no static
members include static members in class
so think of the interface as being just
instructions or instructions on methods
that's all they are they say hey you
have to do this as a programmer because
your head of your department said this
is what needs to be in here
or maybe you have a very complicated
code with a lot of the same pieces and
it says hey don't forget these pieces
because we're going to give you an error
if you don't
what are the advantages of interface
well using interfaces has increased the
simplicity in programming some of the
advantages are complete abstraction is
achieved with no ambiguity and that is
very key that is a whole thing
it's saying hey we need these in this
class
you have loose coupling between the data
and methods so now your team can have
what they need without having to go
through and understand what the whole
picture is they can build on small
pieces and really focus on it
it resolves a diamond problem remember
from classes you can only inherit from
one class
now i can come in and say hey these
procedures these methods all need to be
in here and i can have as many methods
as i want in there it resolves the
complexities in defining dependencies uh
so again you have this whole archive and
it's almost like telling a story this is
what we're building this is what it
looks like
disadvantages of interface
using interfaces has some disadvantages
obviously the first one i look at is if
you're working on a really small project
you've added a whole layer of complexity
to it
so when you're working on smaller
projects you almost never see interfaces
the interface in the real world project
is used either extensively or not at all
and so you will see instead of an
interface they'll just send you a list
of what you have to have in there
that's pretty common but with the
interface it forces the programmer so
when it goes back up the chain
and everything needs to be put together
and so it gets a little confusing
because some people are like oh i got to
use an interface tonight or i don't
and the use of the interface can reduce
the execution speed you're adding a
whole another layer there where it has
to look that information up and so if
you're doing
like a
huge multi-task process
and you're spreading it across multiple
processors and so now you have
hundreds of these classes that are
pulling in hundreds of these
interfaces
that's going to add a little ding to
your speed and it might not be something
you want to do there for a process like
that which is very different where if
you're writing a game
and each player and each module for
their character which has certain things
they have to do which is move left move
right move up down and then they have
their all the new games always have a
special thing they can do
that has to be embedded into that class
let's see the definition of
encapsulation encapsulation is like a
capsule the whole code and data is
bounded together into a single unit
another way to think about encapsulation
is it is a protective shield that
prevents the data from being accessed by
the code outside this shield as you can
see variables and methods are defined
inside one class like a capsule now the
question is why do we need encapsulation
the main reasons are first better
control of class attributes and methods
second class attributes can be made
read-only or write-only third it makes
java code very flexible this means the
programmer can change one part of the
code without affecting other parts apart
from these encapsulation is mainly used
to protect data and increase security of
the code as you can see to protect the
data variables must be private and they
can only be accessed through methods now
let's see java code for encapsulation to
understand the concept better
so now let's create a new project
next
next and i'm gonna name it as
and cap one
so here we have a main class we can
write the code here so before i take the
code let me create a new class
right click new java class
and i'm gonna name it as employee
so in this program we are going to use a
classic example of employee
using employee name id and salary so in
this class let me create variables
first string name
then
integer id
and then in salary
so i can easily use these variables in a
main program by creating object of the
class so let me just create the object
employee e is equal to new employee
now i can use e dot id name or salary
anything i need to but this program is
about encapsulation so this is an easy
program we can do but in order to secure
our programs when we have a large number
of program and large number of lines in
a program so we need encapsulation at
that time so that data can be secured
so for that i'm gonna name it as private
now all three variables are private so i
can't use them see we can't see them
anymore if i write id
we'll get a red color here so if we go
on it we can see id has private access
so that means we can't use it directly
because of this we need
getters and setters that are normally
methods that are used for these so right
click
generate
and here you can see getters and setters
so just select all of them
and ok
so now we can use these methods instead
of direct using the variables so we can
get in the starting then set then get
and again set so likewise it goes like
this
so now we have set here so
if i want to declare variable and if i
want to put some value inside my
variable so how can i do that
here you can see get id or get salary so
if i go for get id sorry if i go for e
dot set id and i set it as 6
so
this shows no error this means we can
use methods to access variables so let's
complete our program now first i'm gonna
set everything
and lastly e dot set salary let's get it
as 30 000
maybe in dollars or maybe in rupees
let's just set it as 30 000 for now
so how i'm gonna print it for this i'm
gonna go to a print statement and then
name
and e dot not set name but this time i'm
gonna go with get name get name is to
return the value of the name that i have
given so in this case that's simply
learn
and next will be id
and e dot get id
and lastly
salary
e dot get salary
so this is a simple program that is used
to define encapsulation we don't use
private variables that becomes a normal
program so when we use encapsulation we
are going to use private every time
whenever we declare variables so that
it's secure and no one can access the
variables directly
so now let's run the program
and there we go we have our result we
have executed the program successfully
and as you can see name simply learn id
6 and salary is 30 000
so i hope you understood the concept of
encapsulation so the main concept of
encapsulation is all the variables can
be accessed through methods so for this
we use getters and setters that are
inbuilt functions for intellij or
netbeans or eclipse so with this let's
move on to our next program to
understand it better and how we can
manipulate these variables or methods
using program so again let's create a
new project
and this time i'm gonna name it as
encapsulation 2 because it's the second
program for encapsulation
and here we have our main program
now this time i'm going to use an
example of cars so let me just create a
new class and i'm gonna name it as cars
so in this again i'm gonna create three
variables that are private
so first i'm gonna get string
name then private string
price
that means price of the car
and third one
top speed of the car
so we can create the program that we did
before as it is but i'm gonna explain
you more in depth how we can manipulate
these variables or classes so i'm gonna
create a constructor for the class
cars and inside i'm gonna give it as
arguments as string name
then string price
and string top speed
and i'm gonna give it as this dot name
is equal to name
this is so that the class can identify
that we are going to give arguments
related to that and the class can return
the values of it
so similarly i'm gonna give it as this
dot price
is equal to price
and lastly
this top speed is equal to top speed
so with this we have completed our
constructor for it now let's have
getters and setters for the same thing
for these three variables
so generate
getter and setter
select all and okay
this is a great feature that we have in
java getters and setters otherwise we'll
have to type the whole code so with this
let's move on to our main program
we'll write the code here first i'll
create object of the class cars
and inside this i'm gonna give arguments
or inside this i'm gonna give values
that i use in constructor to assign the
values without using any c dot get name
or c dot get price
so my first was name so let me just name
it as bmw
the second thing was price so i'm gonna
give it as 30 000 dollars
and the third one was top speed so top
speed i'm gonna give it as
200 kilometer per hour so we have
assigned all the values to the variables
and we have created object as well all
in the same line so this is another way
of creating objects or another way of
assigning values to the variables that
are private
so if i try to print these they can be
easily printed
so in the starting name
and c dot
so this time i'm gonna give get name so
it automatically gets the value that i
assigned to the variables through
getters and setters
after that price
price c dot price get
price and in the end
top speed
c dot get top speed
so if i print this
let's execute it
and there we go we have name bmw price
and even the top speed now if i give
spaces between them
it will look neatly
so let me execute it once more
and here you go
name bmw price 30 000
and top speed 200 kilometer per hour so
this is one of our ways how we can
declare variables or assign values to
the variables without using any getters
or setters so in this method we used
only getters to print the value that we
have for variables now how can we
manipulate the variables if we want to
change value of them
now for this again i can do set top
speed or set price let the name be as it
is
so c dot set price
so price i'm gonna set it as
fifty thousand dollars
and c dot set top speed let me increase
it to 250 kilometer per hour
so before printing that i'm so that we
can differentiate which one is new and
which one is old i'm gonna print one
more line
stats after
updation
so now if i print these values i'm just
gonna copy paste it
so now if i print it let's execute it
and here you go
first we have name price and top speed
then stats after updations that means
after we set the value the value gets
overwritten on the variables and now we
have a new price and top speed and all
the details so this is how you can
manipulate variables or values inside
the variables now let's see what is
inheritance when one class inherits some
properties and attributes of other class
it is known as inheritance let's have a
look at an example in this example
mobiles is a superclass that have
variables like cost color and ram the
classes that inherits the variables and
methods of mobiles are samsung xiaomi
and nokia these classes are known as
subclass now let's see the types of
inheritance in java first we have single
inheritance in single inheritance one
class inherits features from another
class as you can see above class b
inherits all properties of class a this
is a simple concept of inheritance next
we have multi-level inheritance a
derived class inherits from base class
and derived class also act as a base
class to other class sounds complicated
right now let's see this example class b
is derived from class a then class c is
derived from class b because of this
class c contains properties of both
class a and b this is very effective
when you go for inheritance in big
programs and lastly we have hierarchical
inheritance in this one class serves as
base class and two or more classes
serves as derived class as you can see
above class b class d and class c have a
single base class a so three classes
inherits properties of single class this
is called hierarchical inheritance now
to understand these all concepts better
let's use java code so now let's create
a new project
next
next
and i'm gonna name it as inheritance
so we have our main program here so i'll
just create a new class
new java class and for now let me just
name it as mobiles
so what are the features in mobiles to
start with
the cost of the mobile
the color of the mobile
and what can we do it as our ram of the
mobile
i am making it as string because i'm
gonna write gb as well so that's why
string
and now let's use getters and setters
for this
select all
and okay
so we have our first class mobiles here
so our first type of inheritance was
single inheritance so i'll create one
more class
and i'm gonna name it as android
and i'll make android as
extends okay i'll leave it for now
so this mobile class we are going to use
afterwards for now i'll use only android
so
let me make it as string
android
version
and for this i'm gonna go for getter and
setter
so what is single level inheritance one
class inherits from another class so
i'll create one more program or i'll
create a one more class and i'm gonna
name it as
samsung because samsung is an android
phone and as well as it comes under
mobiles so now i'm gonna extend it to
android
extends android so no need of writing
anything inside it as soon as i write
extends android i can use all the
variables right now i have only android
version as the variable
so now let's go to main program
and i'm right samsung s is equal to new
samsung
so i just created an object of it
so now if i use s dot i'll get android
version so i'll set android version as
android
pie
and now to show it
i'm gonna give it as
samsung
android
version
and here s dot
get android version
so now i have android class and a
samsung class and i extended android
class to the samsung so samsung can use
all the variables here and i can even
set the variables here so if i execute
it
and here you go you can see samsung
android version that's android pie
so without even declaring even a single
variable or method here in samsung i use
the variable of android and i did this
so this is called as single level
inheritance so next i'm gonna move it
for multi-level inheritance so what is
multi-level one class is derived from
next and this class is derived from here
so i have three classes right now so i'm
gonna put android
extends mobile
so now android can use all the variables
of mobiles i can use cost color or ram
and even samsung that extends android
can use all the variables from mobile so
if i put variables for it
s dot see i can get color cost or ram so
i'm gonna go for set color
i'm gonna give it as black
and next s dot
set cost cost i'm gonna give it as 30
000 let it be dollar or rupees
and the last one s dot
ram
i'm gonna give it as
4gb
so now if i print
i'll just delete all this
so now i can print them one by one so
let's just do that
so i'm gonna give it a samsung mobile
details
and then
cost
s dot get cost
next i'm gonna give it as color
plus s dot color
sorry s dot get color
and next last one i'm gonna give it as
ram
plus s dot
get ram
so now you can see i have not declared
any variable inside samsung but i
inherited all the variables from here
mobiles and android so all the variables
from mobiles are here and as per android
if i put
android version
s dot get
android version
so now if i execute it i'll get all the
values and as a result i'll get
everything that i gave as the value
so now let's just execute it
oh instead of cost i should put color
so as you can see i have the cost of
samsung mobile color and ram and even
android version so all these variables i
gave in mobile and android version i
gave in android class
but nothing in samsung class so this is
how multi-level inheritance works so now
let's move on to the third topic that
was hierarchical inheritance so what is
hierarchical inheritance in that three
classes or two classes have a single
base class so i'm gonna create two more
classes that derives android so now
let's create them
next i'm gonna name it as nokia
and the last one
xiaomi
so these are real time examples three
mobiles we have three different
companies and all uses android and they
all come under mobiles
so now in everything i'm gonna write
extends android
so this is the final version of
inheritance that we have and this is
very simple to understand but it might
get complicated when we use big programs
or very large programs for some project
so now i have nothing inside class nokia
or xiaomi or samsung i'm gonna use all
the variables that come from android and
mobiles as android extends mobiles so
this is the concept like i have three
classes three mobile companies that
comes under android and we can use them
to manipulate the variables and assign
values to the variables so i already
have everything from samsung
so first let's create objects for all
these classes
nokia n is equal to new nokia
and xiaomi x is equal to new
xiaomi
so now i'm going to assign variables to
their values so now let's start with
nokia
n dot
set color
let's give it as red
n dot set cost i'm gonna give it as
forty thousand
again doesn't matter because it's a
normal program so it doesn't matter
whether it's dollar or rupees so next n
dot
set ram
ram 4 gb
and lastly n dot set android version
android marshmallow
so and in the end i'm gonna give x dot
let's just copy paste it
so it will be lot easier for
me to code or for you to code
so here x start
and color i'm gonna give it as
silver
rate 50 000 ram 6gb
and android let's give it some old
so
get get
so now we have set all the values to the
variables
so now let's print them as well so again
i'm going to copy paste all those
details
instead of samsung nokia
here it gets n
n
instead of s
and now again copy paste
now xiaomi
x dot
x dot
x
and finally x so with this i have
completed the program i can show you all
the
values that i gave in the starting let's
just revise it
so in mobiles i gave all the variables
cost color and ram android i extended
from mobiles and i gave one more
variable as android version
nokia xiaomi and samsung i gave nothing
but i only extended android
so now let's execute it
so we have successfully executed our
program let's have a look at it
so here samsung mobile details in the
starting color cost
after that
nokia mobiles
and in the end xiaomi mobile and
everything that we gave as the value are
here so with this we have completed our
program i hope you understood what
inheritance is so i'll just revise it
one more time so in single level
inheritance i used only samsung android
and mobiles and samsung i derived from
android and i used only android version
in the starting next i used multi-level
inheritance in that i used mobile's
android and samsung
with the use of mobile variables i use
samsung and i printed the values of
color cost ram and android version as
samsung
in the next that is hierarchical
inheritance i use nokia xiaomi and
samsung
what is polymorphism according to
chemistry the term polymorphism can be
defined as the ability of any element or
compound to exist in multiple
crystalline forms this is called
polymorphism for example if you have the
carbon atom it can come out in different
forms in coal graphite and diamond
what is polymorphism in java
similarly in the terms of java
programming language polymorphism is
defined as the ability of any object in
clat in a class to perform a particular
task in multiple methods this is known
as polymorphism in java
we're going to open up our eclipse
editor and we're going to do some animal
sounds with cows cats and dogs just kind
of a fun almost kids-like
example of polymorphism
and you can see i already have my
inheritance in here let's go ahead and
create a new
uh package
and we'll call this polymorphism
just to keep it simple
and once we have our polymorphism in
there we're gonna go ahead and add a
class in
and if you were doing um
an abstract class we could label it as
abstract we're not going to directly
access it and we'll call it animal
sounds maybe we will we'll see how we
load the
program app but we'll call this animal
sounds
and let's create a public it's not going
to return anything but we'll call it
sound
on here and we just want to go ahead and
have it do a
system out print
and with our system out print line we'll
just have it say animals
make
different
sounds
there we go
so yeah it's really simple and
straightforward we're just gonna have it
print something out
and if we're gonna do that let's go
ahead and just um
a good thing i didn't make it abstract
let's go ahead and just test it out and
see what it looks like and we'll do
oh we'll call it animal main animal
maine
and in here let's go ahead and test out
what we just put together
uh we'll do our our static void main so
it's going to run on here
and we'll create our animal
sounds
we'll call it animal because we don't
know what kind of animal this is we'll
call it new animal
sounds
and we'll just take that animal um and i
like to
put it in capitalize but usually we'd
like to do this lowercase
there we go
and we'll just have our
animal
uh dot
sound
and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
comes out
we can see here animals make different
sounds okay that's not too exciting
so let's jump in there and let's say we
have um in this case we're going to add
in a couple of different animals uh
we'll add in a
oh let's start with a
cow yeah why not a cow
um so we'll have our cow in here we'll
go ahead and click ok
and now we have our cow class but a cow
doesn't just it makes different noises
but it actually
makes us you know a very clear noise so
we'll go ahead and give the cow a sound
and we'll have the cow
say moo moo and the cow is going to
extend
there's our um
and we'll put in our extends animal
sounds and then i want to go back here
to our animal main
and now we have a class cow so in our
animal maine we want to do
cow
cow
equals new
cow
and once we've created the new cow we
also need to go ahead and have the cow
sounds
there we go
and we run this
you can see it comes out here and it
says the cow says moo moo
so if we go back to cal we're just going
to do this real quick
and let's say
we just take this out of here the public
void sound
and then we're going to go into our
animal main and run that
recompiles animals make different sounds
because it doesn't know what sound a cow
makes
so this is really central to
polymorphism is we're taking something
going on in the um
in one set up that we've brought in and
extended from our animal sounds and
we've changed it to the cow says moo moo
and we can also add in multiple animals
in here we'll go ahead and just add in
one more animal we'll call this one
we'll do a dog why not
so here comes in our dog
and of course we want the dog to
actually say something
and we'll have the dog
go bow wow and then we'll go back to our
animal main we have to create a dog
and we'll say
cow
simply dog dog
upper case for the class lower case for
the actual object
and then of course we need the dog
to make a sound so we'll go down here
and go dog dot
sound
and when we run this as you expect the
it's going to compile it there we go
animals making different sounds the cow
says moo moo the dog says bow wow
characteristics of polymorphism the
functionality of a method behaves
differently in different situations the
behavior of a method is dependent on the
data polymorphism is mainly used to
implement inheritance as we saw we did
the extends with the animal sounds
polymorphism is mainly used to implement
inheritance it allows same name for a
member method in a class with different
types
which we'll cover briefly in a minute
polymorphism supports implicit type
conversion
types of polymorphism there are
basically two types of polymorphism that
can be occurred in java programming
language they are mentioned as follows
compile time polymorphism run time
polymorphism compile time polymorphism
gets executed during the compilation
stage here the overloading method gets
resolved in compilation stage so when
you saw me run those in eclipse and it
went through the compile time that's
looking at all the different changes we
made to those classes that's what we're
talking about here is during compile
time
in method overloading in java the
process of method overloading is
achieved when a class has two or more
methods with same name but the specific
method is selected based on the number
of parameters declared
we'll now execute a program based on the
functionality of additional operator in
a different situation and let's flip
back on over to our eclipse
so in here i'm going to go back under
the dog
and let me just highlight this
and we're going to do the same thing so
you see right here it says public void
sound so this is identical public void
sound
but instead of sending uh nothing we're
gonna send it a string we're gonna call
it angry
now at this point
you should note that what if it's a
happy dog i would have to add an if then
if the string angry said happy then we'd
print happy or something else but we're
just keeping it simple so we've entered
another sound identical to the first but
we've added string
angry to it and this one's going to
print out the dog says growl growl now
if we go back to our animal mane
and here's our dog same dog
same sound
but now we're going to add a string in
here
and we put that string in here we'll go
ahead and just call it angry it doesn't
really matter what string you put in
here because we haven't sorted out what
the string means
for now it just says growl growl it's
going to recompile it so remember this
is a polymorphism during compile time
and here we have it the dog says growl
growl the duck says bow wow and then the
angry dog says growl growl so there is
another
thing called operator overloading
operator overloading is not supported in
java
authors of java wanted to keep the
language less complicated
explaining operator overloading it
basically is a way of bundling
operations into the call statement and
user procedures it's so that it looks
like a math on a paper you have a plus
add b plus c kind of thing and it's all
wrapped up in your call to another
statement this just gets confusing it
really isn't necessary so the drawbar
developers decided not to put it in
there so runtime polymorphism in java
programming language runtime
polymorphism gets handled during the
program execution stage
here the overriding method gets resolved
in execution
so far we've talked about compile time
polymorphism as you saw in the program
we just wrote when it's compiling it
does the extend and figures out which
overload method to use on there
in runtime polymorphism method
overriding in java the method overriding
is a procedure where child class is
allowed to implement a specific class
that is already provided in the parent
class
for runtime compilation code or
polymorphism we need to go ahead and
introduce the super key word now from
inheritance you should remember that we
can look at super from before but we're
going to use it slightly different it's
kind of doing the same thing as when we
did the inheritance but we're doing like
what they call an override during run
time so the term super is predefined
keyword in java that is used to refer
the immediate parent class object or
method defined in the program
in this procedure whenever you create an
instance of subclass then automatically
an instance a parent class is also
created that will be implicitly referred
by the super reference variable
so going back into our animal sounds
let's go in here to dog
and if we add a super
dot
sound in here this is going to reference
whatever our extend is because we
extends the dog extends animal sounds
and so here's our super dot sound
and if we go ahead and both run and
compile this
and you can see here that it comes down
and says the dog says growl growl
because that's what we had it system out
print line to
and then the super animals make
different sounds and so if we go back to
our animal main
this is what it's calling right here
it's going back into sound under the
animal mains and it's printing out or
doing whatever it does here
at this point we usually ever return
something so you can look up whatever
the original class was using
so getting back to
these two setups whether you're using
the super
to use a runtime polymorphism because
that's what's happening during run time
versus compile time polymorphism during
compile time polymorphism method call is
handled by the compiler itself so the
programs maybe take a second more to
compile but it runs faster in the run
time the method call cannot be handled
by compiler in the execution stage so if
you have any errors it's not going to
show up either during the compile time
we have compile time polymorphism is
less flexible as it needs handle all
method calls in compile time so you
really in runtime polymorphism your it
exhibits higher flexibility as a method
call gets handled at runtime coming in
the execution period for compile time
polymorphism is less
that's what i was just talking about it
compiles it so the compiling takes maybe
a little bit more but if you're
executing the same program over and over
and over again once it's distributed
it's going to run faster
then of course with the runtime
polymorphism the execution period for
runtime polymorphism takes longer it's
just a little bit more usually in most
programs you don't notice this but if
you're executing the same script a
thousand times suddenly that .01 second
is a lot more it suddenly is adding up a
second each time it goes through the
thousand iterations uh then with the
compile time polymorphism integrating
the right method call with the right
method is done in compile time and of
course in runtime integrating the right
method call with the right method is
done in run time again that's another
delay because it has to figure out what
it's doing it's not already pre-mapped
out and finally compile time
polymorphism occurs during method
overloading and operator overloading
where runtime polymorphism occurs during
the method overriding
advantages of polymorphism
programmers code can be reused via
polymorphism
number one goal of a programmer is to
reuse the code as much as possible so
you're not reinventing the will over and
over again
advantages of polymorphism supports
single variable name for multiple data
types reduces coupling between different
functionalities
and some of the disadvantages of
polymorphism that can come up is that
polymorphism ends up raising performance
issues in real time
you can see whereas you're loading all
these different things you might end up
creating loops you didn't know you're
doing polymorphism reduces readability
of the code
sometime your actual code everything you
look at in java is polymorphism all
based on a primary object so you could
have a very complicated setup and then
actually very easy to read when you
actually put your final variable in
there
but when you're going through lines and
lines of code it can be really hard to
figure out what's going on as you loop
through all these different inherited
modules or classes programmers find
polymorphism difficult to implement just
depends the more you use it the easier
it is what exactly is a java collection
a java collection can be generally
defined as a collective unit of objects
in the form of a group
for example a group of numbers of
integer data type etc moving forward we
enter into our next topic where we face
the java collections framework this will
help us understand java collections in a
little more detailed way a java
collection framework represents a
unified architecture for storing and
manipulating a group of objects its
architecture includes the following
an interface a class and the java
collections api
to understand these in a much better way
we shall now go through the java
collections hierarchy the utility
package java.util contains all the
classes and interfaces that are required
by a collection framework the collection
framework contains an interface named as
an iterable interface which provides the
iterator to iterate through all the
collections
this interface can be extended by the
main collection interface which acts as
a root for the collection framework
all the collections extend this
collection interface thereby extending
the properties of the iterator and the
methods of this interface the following
figure illustrates the hierarchy of
collection framework out of the
complexities we have the interface and
the classes as the major part of the
collections
now let us understand each one of them
at one step at a time as you can see on
the screen we have the iterable class
which is implemented by the collection
class and this particular collection
class is further implemented by list
queue and set and moving ahead we have
the following classes which have
implemented the list queue and set
classes in the list we have array list
linked list vector stack and on the
other hand on the queue we have priority
queue dq and array dq and finally on the
set we have the hash set
lint hash set sorted set reset etc now
moving further we will enter our first
java collection which is none other than
the interface so the first one is an
interface an interface can have methods
and variables but the methods declared
in an interface are by default abstract
that is only the method signature is
available not the body
interfaces specify what a class must do
and not how it must do
it is a blueprint of a class now a java
collection is a foundation to the java
collections framework note that all the
collection interfaces are generic for
example public interface collection is
the syntax for the generics and when we
declare the collection we should use it
to specify the type of object which it
can contain
it helps in reducing runtime errors by
type checking the objects at compile
time to keep the number of core
collections interface manageable the
java platform doesn't provide separate
interfaces for each variant of each
collection type if an unsupported
operation is invoked a collection
implementation throws an unsupported
operation exception
now under the collection interface we
have many interfaces that we should use
for data manipulation
a few of the major ones are set
interface list interface dq interface q
interface map interface sorted set
interface
sorted map interface
no worry those are a lot of interfaces
but we will discuss each one of them in
a detailed way along with a practical
example for a better understanding
so the first one in the docket is the
set interface a set is a collection that
cannot contain any duplicate elements
this interface model is the mathematical
set abstraction and is used to represent
sets such as a deck of cards
the java platform contains three general
purpose set implementations
the hash set tree set and
lint hash set the set interface does not
allow random access to an element in the
collection you can use an iterator for
each loop to traverse elements of a set
now for a better understanding let us go
through a practical example i have
prepared a code document for all the
programs that i am going to explain to
just save time you can always have
access to it all you need to do is just
ask for it in the comment section below
so you can see on my screen we have an
example for set interface
in this particular example we are going
to store the elements 21 23 43 53 22 and
65 so let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so you can see the elements stored in
the set interface are 65 21 53 22 and 23
43
so the sorted set is here which is the
21 22 23 43 53 and 65
and the first element being 21 and the
last element being 65
so this is how the set interface
practically works now let's move ahead
into our next type of interface which is
none other than the list interface so
what exactly is a list interface the
list interface is an ordered collection
that can contain duplicate elements you
can access any element from its index
the list is more likely an
array with dynamic length the list is
one of the most used collection types
and array list and linked list are the
implementation classes of the list
interface the list interface provides
useful methods to add an element at a
specific index to remove and replace
elements based on the index and to get a
sub list using the index
for a better understanding let's check
out an example
so this particular program is based on
list interface so we are going to add in
three names which are david john and
stacy into our list and also we have a
fourth edition
which is stacy again
just to check if the statement is true
it says
list interface also allows duplicate
elements unlike the set interface
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the names
david john and stacy are added into the
list
now let's come back to our program and
remove this comment and try to run again
and check if the fourth element which is
the duplicate of the third stacy
will be added into the list or not so as
you can see the program got successfully
executed and the fourth element which is
stacy the duplication of the first one
got successfully inserted into the list
so this is how the list interface works
now let's move ahead into our next type
of interface
which is the queue interface so what
exactly is a queue interface queue is a
collection used to hold multiple
elements prior to processing
besides basic collection operations a
queue provides additional insertion
extraction and inspection operations
cues typically but did not necessarily
order elements in the fifo or first in
first out manner
among the exceptions are priority cues
which order elements according to a
supplied comparator
or the elements in natural ordering
whatever the ordering used the head of
the queue is the element that would be
removed by a call to remove our poll in
a first and first out queue all new
elements are inserted at the tail of the
cube
now for a better understanding let's go
through a practical example
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for queue interface
so in this particular queue we are going
to store the names of fruits apple mango
grapes and banana and apple being the
head of the queue and banana being the
tail of the queue
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so we are also going
to count the size of the queue which is
four basically in the first after that
we are going to remove the element
grapes from the queue
so the command is q dot remove the
element name so after that the grapes
element has been removed from our queue
we have the latest size of the queue as
3.
now after that we are also going to
check if the element apple is included
in the queue or not
so for that statement
yes the element apple is included in the
queue and the result is true
so this is how the cues work and let's
move further and in the next phase we
have the dq interface so what exactly is
a dq interface
so a linear collection that supports
element insertion and removal at both
the ends is called as a dq interface
the name dq is short for double ended q
and is usually pronounced as dec most dq
implementations place no fixed limits on
the number of elements they may contain
but this interface supports capacity
restricted dqs as well as those with no
fixed size limit this interface defines
methods to access the elements at both
the ends of the dq
methods are provided to insert remove
and xml in the element for a better
understanding let's check out an example
so you can see on my screen we have a
program for dq interface so here we are
going to add in some elements into our
dq and then also try to remove the first
element and print the updated dq
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so as you can see
the program got successfully executed
and the elements which we try to push
into the dq are 52 10 and 21 52 is being
the first element and the 21 is being
the last element so we try to remove the
first element which is the 52 so after
that the updated dequeue is having two
elements which are 10 and 21
so this is how the queues work now let's
move ahead and learn our next type of
interface which is the map interface
so what exactly is a map interface a
java map is an object that maps keys
along with its values a map cannot
contain duplicate keys each key
can map to at most one value
the java platform contains three general
purpose map implementations which are
the hash map tree map and linked hash
map
the basic operations of a map are
contains key contains value size and is
empty for a better understanding let us
check out an example so this particular
example on my screen is an example
for
map interface here we are going to add
three elements and map them as one as
cricket two as hockey and three as
archery
now let us execute this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are
mapped with their keys and the element
cricket is mapped with the key one and
similarly hockey with k2 and rcd with k3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move further into our next
type of interface which is the sorted
set interface so what exactly is a
sorted set interface
so a sorted set is a set that maintains
its elements in ascending order
several additional operations are
provided to take advantage of the
ordering
sorted sets are usually used for
naturally ordered sets such as
word list and membership roles
for a better understanding let's check
out an example based on sorted set
interface
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for sorted set interface
so here we are going to add in bob sean
and jennifer into our set and we are
going to print the same let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and we have our
elements printed in the sorted set and
you can see the
names are been arranged in the form of
ascending order according to the
alphabets which have started in the
first position so this is exactly how
the sort set interface works
so the last one in the interfaces is the
sorted map interface a map that
maintains its mapping in an ascending
key order
this is the map analog of sorted set the
certain maps are used for naturally
ordered collections of key value pairs
such as dictionaries and telephone
directories
now for a better understanding let's
check out an example based on map
interface or sorted map interface so you
can see the program on my screen is an
example for sorted map interface
so here we're going to add in the
elements john molly aaron and daisy into
the map interface now along with the
names we also have their aggregates
which is 76.5 for john 87.3 for molly
and 78.2 for aaron and for
daisy we have 73.4
now finally we are going to fetch the
data of molly which is the aggregate of
molly now let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and knowledge
aggregate is 87.3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move ahead into our next topic
which is the java collection classes so
now that we have finished the java
collection interfaces let us have a
quick understanding of java interface
methods so the first method is the add
method the add method is used to add an
object to the collection and next is the
ease nt method
this method returns the true if the
collection contains no elements followed
by that we have the clear method and
this method is used to remove all the
elements from the collection followed by
that we have the remove method this
method is used to remove the given
object from the collection if there are
duplicate values then this method
removes the first occurrence of the
object next to the remove method we have
the size method so the size method is
used to return the number of elements in
the collection so after the size method
we have the stream method the stream
method is used to return a sequential
stream
with this collection as its source so
the next method we have is the two array
method
so the two array method is used to
return an array containing all the
elements in this collection
followed by that we have the hashcode
method this method is used to return the
hashcode value for this collection
next the equals method
the equals method is used to compare the
specified object with the remaining
elements in the collection
followed by that we have the iterator
method so the iterator method is used as
an iterator over the elements of the
particular collection and finally
we have the contains method
so the contains method returns true if a
specified element is existing in the
collection and false if it is not
present so with this we finish the
collection interface and collection
interface methods now we will move ahead
into our next topic which is none other
than the java collection classes so what
exactly is a class a class is a user
defined blueprint or prototype from
which objects are created it represents
a set of properties or methods that are
common to all the objects of one type
now we'll start up with the first one
which is the hash set class so the java
hash set is the basic implementation of
the set interface that is backed up by
the hash map it makes no guarantee for
the iteration order
of the set and permits null elements as
well
so this class offers constant time
performance for basic operations such as
add remove contains and size assuming
the hash function
disperses the elements properly among
the buckets we can set the initial
capacity and load factor for this
collection
the load factor is a measure of how full
the hashmap is allowed to get before its
capacity is automatically increased
for a better understanding let's go
through an example
so on my screen you can see a program
which is an example for hash set classes
so inside this we are going to store
some names which are the names of the
manufacturers of bikes along with null
values
so we have added in two null values to
just check if it allows two null values
at once
so basically it only should allow one
null value so let's check out how does
it perform
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and the null value
is stored only once that too in the
first location
so this is how the hash set classes work
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class which is the tree set
class
so a tree set class is a navigable set
implementation based on a tree map the
elements are ordered using their natural
ordering or by a comparator provided at
set creation time depending on which
constructor is being used this
implementation provides guaranteed log
stein cost for the basic operations such
as add remove and contains
note that the ordering maintained by a
set whether or not an explicit
comparator is provided must be
consistent with equals if it is to
correctly implement the set interface
now to understand in a much better way
let us go through an example now we are
going to add in some numbers into the
tree set using the add method now let's
execute this code and see the output
so you can see the numbers are added
into the tree set and the numbers are
ordered in ascending order
which is 0 18 88 748
983 8476
now let's move further into our next
type of class
which is
the arraylist class
so add a list in java is a resizable
array that is an implementation of list
interface that allows null elements so
in this class we have three types of
arrays which are one-dimensional arrays
two-dimensional arrays and
three-dimensional arrays now let's check
out the one-dimensional array
so
a one-dimensional array looks similar to
this where we have the array index
and the element present in the array so
here our indexes are a0 1 2 3 and 4 and
the elements which are shown here to
understand one dimensional arrays in a
much better way let's go through a
sample program so you can see the
program written on my screen is an
example for one dimensional array and we
are going to store the elements 10 20
and 30 into my array a
so you can see the program has been
successfully executed and the elements
have been added into my one-dimensional
area
moving further we will discuss the
two-dimensional arrays the
two-dimensional arrays are completely
similar to one-dimensional array but the
only difference is the index numbers
earlier we had index number but now we
have index numbers
now using these index numbers we can
represent the elements in a matrix form
so to understand this in a much better
way let's go through a sample code
so you can see this particular program
in my screen is an example for
two-dimensional arrays so here we are
going to add in elements one two three
and four in the matrix form and we are
going to use two for loops to print that
now let's execute this program and see
the output
so you can see we have the elements 1 2
3 and 4 and the elements are printed in
the matrix form
at the array index location 0 0 we have
1 0 1 we have 2 and 1 0 we have 3 and 1
1 we have 4 so this is how the two
dimensional arrays work and finally
let's deal with the third type of array
which is the multi-dimensional or
three-dimensional array
so you can see the three-dimensional
array is completely similar or a little
bit similar to the two-dimensional array
but the only difference is we have a
third vector here
so next up we have the linked list
linked list also come under java
collection classes
there are three types of linked lists
which are single linked list doubly
linked list and circular linked list now
let's check out each one of those
so the first one is the single linked
list so you can see in a singly linked
list each memory segment is divided into
two parts so the first half of the
memory location is given for the element
and the second half of the memory
location is dedicated for the address so
this particular address is used to point
to the next element or the next memory
allocation which stores the second
element similarly the third so this is
how the singly linked list works so the
last memory allocation is called as tail
and the last address will not store
nothing but null which indicates the end
of the singly linked list
now to understand singly linked list in
a much better way let's try to execute a
sample program
so you can see the program on my screen
is an example for singly linked list now
we are going to add in the elements one
two three and four in the form of a
singly linked list now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are one two three and four now let's
move further and try to learn the next
type of linked list which is the doubly
linked list
so the doubly linked list is completely
similar to that of the singly linked
list but the only difference is we have
two address locations so the first
address location of the head stores null
and the last address location of the
tail stores null which
indicate the start and end of the doubly
linked list respectively so here in the
second memory location you have two
addresses so the first address points to
the previous element and the next
address points to the next element so to
understand doubly linked list in a much
better way let's try to execute a sample
program
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for doubly linked
list and we have the node which has the
data and previous address next address
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output and the elements that
we are going to store in this particular
doubly linked list are one two three
four and five
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the notes are
one two three and four and five so this
is how the w link lists work and now
let's check out the third type of linked
list which is the circular linked list
so there are similarities between the
previous linked list and the circular
linked list
so the circular linked list makes it
circular based on the last address
location
so this particular address location
points to the first element back again
so this is how it becomes a circular
linked list so to understand this in a
much better way let's check out an
example for it
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for circular linked list
now let's try to execute this and see
the output
so you can see we have successfully
included one two three four five six and
seven and eight into our circular linked
list and they are printed on the screen
so this is how the circular linked list
work so moving further we will try to
understand the next type of classes in
java collections which is the hashmap
class so hash table is based on the
implementation of map interface
this implementation provides all the
optional
map operations and permits null values
and the null key hashmap class is
roughly equivalent to hash table except
that it is unsynchronized and permits
null this class makes no guarantee for
the order of the map now for a better
understanding let's go through a sample
program
so this particular
program on my screen is an example for
hashmap class so here we are trying to
load the data which is the name of the
manufacturer and their bike so let's
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and we have the
manufacturer and they are made bikes now
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class in java collection
which is the tree map class so the tree
map is based on navigable map
implementation the map is sorted
according to the natural ordering of its
case or by a comparator provided at map
creation time depending on the
constructor used
now let's check out an example for
better understanding
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for tree map class
so we have the roll numbers and the
names of students here now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so the program got successfully executed
and the result has been printed on the
output console so we have the roll
numbers of the students and their names
amber
james wallet and reynolds along with
their respective ids
so now with this we complete the java
collections classes now we move into our
next topic which is the collection api
algorithms so the first one is sorting
sorting does the job of ascending and
descending numbers based on the
algorithm written by the user for a
simple example we shall consider the
bubble sort algorithm for this one so
you can see on my screen we have an
example for bubble sort algorithm so we
have the elements 289 39 48 6 28 1 2 and
33 which are ordered in a an orderly
manner let's try to execute this program
and order them
so you can see array before bubble sort
is 289 38 48 similarly 33 and after the
bubble sort we have the sorted array
which is 1 2 6 28 33 39 48 and 289 so
this is how the bubble sort works now
let's move further and understand the
next type of api
which is the shuffling algorithm so the
shuffling algorithms are designed to
destroy the current arrangements they
are employed on creating randomness in
the list so for a better understanding
let's check out an example so you can
see the program written on my screen is
an example for shuffle algorithm so we
have an array which has the elements
completely sorted in ascending order
which is 10 to 100.
now when we run the shuffle algorithm
these elements will be completely
shuffled according to a random order now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output so you can see the
elements which were in an ascending
order are now completely in disorder so
this is how the shuffling algorithm
works now let's move further and
understand the next type of algorithm
which is the searching algorithm
searching algorithm is employed to
search an element in the list or array
based on the type of searching mechanism
used now for example let's use the
binary search
now you can see a program on my screen
which is an example for binary search so
we have the elements 1 2 3 4 and 5 in
our array now what we are going to do is
search for the element or the key
element 2 in our array using the binary
search algorithm
now let's execute this program and see
the output now you can see the program
got successfully executed and the output
says the element which you are looking
for is found at the index location one
so this is how the binary search
algorithm works now let's move further
and understand the next type of
algorithm which is the composition
algorithm so the definition says the
frequency and disjoint algorithms test
some aspect of composition of one or
more collections so the frequency counts
the number of times the specified
element occurs in the specified
collection
so the disjoint determines whether two
collections are disjoint that is whether
they contain no element in common or not
now to understand it in a much better
way let's go through an example so you
can see on my screen there is an example
for composition
now let's run this program and see the
output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and
the elements are completely disjoint now
moving further we will enter into our
next topic which is based on the
benefits of
java collections so there are various
benefits of java collections out of
those the major benefits are software or
code reusability so the java collections
enable code reusability to save time
followed by that the ease of designing
apis so the next two ease of designing
apis we have the simplicity in learning
and using apis and finally increased
speed in programming so these were the
major benefits of java collections what
is an exception
so an exception is defined as an event
that arises due to an unexpected input
or logical failure in the program
this may not be considered merely as an
error but it surely does impact the
normal functioning of the program
segment
now these types of exceptions are
resolved by the most efficient mechanism
called exception handling
exception handling is not any rocket
science but a simple mechanism that
drives the compiler to the next
statement by making the compiler
understand that the input obtained or
the null malfunction that arise
is just an unexpected or an unnecessary
event which can be ignored by sending
the user with a relevant message about
the exception arrows
for a better understanding let us go
through a small example
so as you can see on our screen we have
typed in a program so according to this
program we are going to access a file
called data.txt from the c drive so this
particular data.txt is not really
existing in the c drive so when we run
this program we will face an exception
that says file is not found so let's try
to run this program and see
so as expected
so when we run this program we get that
this particular file what you're looking
for which is data.txt is not found
or in other words it is not present in
the specified location so this is how
the exceptions work in java
now followed by this we will move ahead
into our next topic where we will
understand the meaning of an error
so what exactly is an error
so here
we are trying to learn about the error
just to eliminate the ambiguity between
an exception and an error also further
we will discuss the major differences
between them but now let us go through
the term error first unlike an exception
an error poses a serious potential
threat to the program or sometimes it is
even capable enough to collapse an
entire software
so basically an error is occurred due to
syntax error or some logical error while
coding
so we have some understanding of an
exception and an error now let us move
further and learn the differences
between the both
error versus exception
so some of the major differences between
an error and an exception are
an error is classified under unchecked
type whereas on the other hand an
exception is classified under both
checked and unchecked
the next difference is if a program
encounters an error then it turns out to
be completely irrecoverable until the
error is resolved whereas in the case of
an exception
if the program encounters an exception
then the program is easily recoverable
followed by that the third difference is
an error belongs to the package called
java.lang
java.lang.error
on the other hand an exception belongs
to the class java.lang.exception
the fourth difference says that an error
can be encountered only during the
program's run time whereas on the other
hand an exception can be expected both
during the run time as well as the
compile time
finally we will mention an example for
both an error and an exception
we can consider the input and output
error as an example for error and on the
other hand we can consider divide by
zero exception as an example for
exception
so with the differences discussed we
will now move ahead and have a look at
the exception hierarchy in java
the hierarchy of errors and exceptions
is really
simple there is one root class called
the throwable
now the throwable class is basically
inherited from object which comes from
the superior route called java.lang
now the throwable class is inherited by
two child classes which are none other
than the error and an exception
further an error is inherited by
different types of errors for example
jvm or java virtual machine error memory
error
and also in some cases some of the
errors are caused by the incompatibility
of the ide or the framework which are
you are using
next up is the exception now the
exception is inherited by few more
exceptions which are mentioned as below
the exceptions can be input output
exception sql exception class not found
exception runtime exception and many
more
further the runtime exception is
inherited by some more
which are the automatic exception
number format exception etc
now that we have a good understanding of
the exception hierarchy let us move
ahead and check the differences between
checked and unchecked exceptions
so the first one which is the checked
exceptions
these are really simple exceptions and
can be defined as follows
an exception that pops up during the
compile time is called as the checked
exception
it is not serious and is completely
ignorable
followed by the checked exceptions we
have the unchecked exceptions
on the other hand the unchecked
exceptions are defined as an exception
that pops up during the run time is
called as the unchecked exception
it is considered as serious and is
caused by logical errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular example is based on
checked exceptions
so basically we have a text document
called data.txt
in the location documents username users
c drive
so this particular data file has five
lines so we are going to access the
starting three lines of this particular
file and basically when we try to run
this program we will face some of the
major exceptions which are unhandled
exception type input output
and again the same exception
and here
file not sound exceptional so these
exceptions are errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular code segment here is
trying to read a document from c drive
which is data.txt
so this particular data.txt has five
lines of text so what we are going to do
here is try to type in a for loop and
try to read the first three lines of
this particular document so basically
when we run this program
we will face some of the exceptions
called file not found exception input
output exception and another input
output exception
so we can resolve this particular
program with small modifications to the
program and then if we run this program
then we can find our lines
so the lines in the data dot txt file
were hello welcome to simply learn we
are an e-learning company our
certification is recognized by major
mncs end role and upskill
so this particular example was for
checked exceptions
now
we will also go through an example for
unchecked exceptions to learn it in a
much better way
so this particular example is based on
unchecked exceptions this particular
program is really simple we have an
integer type array and inside that we
have 10 elements which are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 and 10.
so what we're going to do is we're going
to access the 11th element of the array
which is not really present so this
should throw an exception
so array index out of bound exception is
one of the example for unchecked
exceptions
so with this we will move ahead into our
next topic
now we know what exactly are checked and
unchecked exceptions moving further we
will slowly dive into the process of
exception handling in the process of
exception handling we have five major
keywords
so we will learn each one of them as
follows
so the first one is try keyword
the try keyword is used to specify the
exception block
in a program when you specifically type
the exception that you might expect to
face in your program then you describe
it using the keyword try
followed by that the solution for that
exception will be defined in the catch
block so the catch block is used to
specify the solution
finally the finally is a keyword which
has the executable code which is
completely mandatory for a program to
execute
followed by finally we have a throw
keyword the throw keyword basically
throws the exception when it is found
during the run time
followed by that we have the throws the
throws keyword is used to declare the
exception so basically this is where you
declare the kind of exception you are
going to expect in your program
sometimes you might
try to type in your user defined
exception or sometimes you might type in
the exception that is
default in its way
or in other words it might be system
defined
now that we have a good understanding of
the implementation of the exception
handling in java
let us move further and solve some of
the most frequently faced exceptions in
java
so with this we enter into our seventh
topic which is common exceptions faced
in java
so the first one is the array index out
of bound
so if you try to store a value in an
array or try to access an element in an
array which has an address exceeding the
array's maximum location value then this
particular exception is thrown
so to understand this particular
exception let us go through a practical
example
so as you can see on our screen we have
an array of integer data type so we are
going to store the values 10 20 30 40
and 50 in five different locations of
the array which is 0 1 2 3 and 4.
now we are going to provide the address
of the required element so during that
process we are going to specify
one location which is more than the
maximum location of the array so here
the maximum location of the array is 4
and if we try to provide the location 5
then this program should throw us an
exception
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so as you can see we have our array here
now
the program is requesting us to provide
the address of the element required so
what if we provide file
so now it should throw an exception
so this exception is the array index out
of bound exception
now let us try to run this program again
and specify the proper address
so for this time let's provide 4 and see
if we get the output so as you can see
at the address location we have the
element 50 as we have defined here
now our program is running perfectly all
right
now let's move ahead into the next type
of exception
which is none other than our
null pointer exception
if you try to perform an operation on a
null value this particular exception is
thrown
so might be a little ambiguous to
understand this particular exception in
a perfect way let us go through a
practical example
so here on your screen you can see that
we have a program and inside the program
we have a string called sdr which stores
a text called simplylink
followed by that we have another string
type which stores a null value which is
abc as you can see abc is equals to null
now here we are going to access the
value of abc so here the string abc has
a null value and we are trying to access
it so this particular code segment
should throw an exception called null
pointer exception
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see it has thrown an
exception called the null pointer
exception so whenever in java if you try
to access the null values then the null
pointer exception is thrown
followed by this we have the next type
of the common exception
which is the number format
if you try to store a value with wrong
formatting then this particular
exception is thrown
now to understand this in a much better
way let us try to execute a sample
program
so here on the screen we have a sample
program
where we are trying to cast a string
into integer so this kind of operation
should throw an exception
so as you can see the program has been
successfully compiled and we have our
exception here which says number format
exception
followed by this we have another most
commonly faced exception which is the
arithmetic expression
if you try to divide a number by 0 this
particular exception is wrong now let us
go through a practical example
now you can see we have a sample program
on our screen where we have two
particular numbers and one is equals to
0 and n2 is equals to 100
so here what we are trying to do is we
are going to divide the number hundred
percent which is practically not
possible so when we try to execute this
particular program then we should be
getting an exception that says you
cannot divide a number by zero
so there you have your personalized
message which says the divider cannot be
zero try a different number
so this is how the automatic exceptions
work
so with this we have come to our last
topic
which is the best practices to be
followed while working with exceptions
in java
so the first one is use exceptions
conservatively
so exceptions have proven that they can
be costly if used recklessly or
unnecessarily
so it's better to use boolean values to
indicate successful implementation of
smaller operations for example if you
specify a particular operation and it
successfully gets executed then you can
just notify the user by specifying a
boolean value which can be 1 or in the
case of failure we can just specify the
number zero
next after that we have the customized
exceptions
it is a very good practice of
customizing your exceptions in the
design time rather than planning them on
the go
so in other words we can consider this
as if you're planning to design a
software then in that particular stage
itself you must also evaluate the kind
of exceptions you might face on the
process of designing
so tomorrow if you completely design a
software and suddenly an exception is
popped in your head then designing or
including that particular exception in
your finished software might be
difficult
so it's better you start planning your
exceptions
followed by that we have exception login
keep track of the exceptions and this
process comes handy as the user
understands why exactly a particular
exception has popped up
followed by that we have early through
and early fail an exception should be
thrown as early as possible and should
be resolved in the same pace
and then we have the closing resources
since exceptions halt the complete
program we must make sure that the
system resources are shut so as to save
the resources
what is jdbc
jdbc is a tool or an application
programming interface that establishes a
connection between standard database and
java application that intends to use
that database
need for
jdbc establishing database connectivity
to execute mysql or sql queries and ddl
dml commands
view and modify data records
and one of the most important things to
look at when we're talking about a jdbc
and probably uh the most confusing part
where the devil's in the details
is data types in a jdbc
so we start looking at the data types
and you're setting up your data you have
your sql which is your var character and
your java equivalent
java.language.string
and you have your bit in sql in java
it's boolean in sql it's numeric
java.math.bigdecimal
integer int
real float float float
so there's no real difference in java
between a real number and a float number
your double is double your binary is a
byte
data java sql date so your date and java
dot sql date
and there's also your sql timestamp
java.sql timestamp
array java.sql array reference
javasql.reference.structure.java.sql
structure
character
java.language.string biginteger long in
java
variable binary it's a byte
a clob
and that's character large object and
then equivalent is java.sql.clob
and then you have your blob in sql
which is a collection of binary data
stored as a single entity and the
equivalent in java is going to be your
javasql.blob
now if you're doing a lot of programming
i would suggest having a cheat sheet
there and then once you're up and
running you'll start to remember most of
these just because out of use
with the jdbc architecture
we're looking at the application then it
goes into the jdbc api so you have your
application your writing your java
database connector api
then that has a manager underneath of it
and then you have your java database
connection drivers and the drivers are
the ones that are transferring that
whether it's an sql server mysql server
the oracle database
or different sources that use a jdbc
connection
jdbc environment setup
so when we talk about the environment
setup we have java and your
environmental setup underneath of that
in setting up a java environment you
have to download the latest jdk set java
to home and set your java path so if
you're just using eclipse for the first
time or whatever ide you're using to
program you want to make sure you have
that all set up and you have the current
jdk in there the java development
package
and then with mysql
setting up mysql environment download
the latest mysql workbench extract the
file run the setup file and that'll get
you set up with your own mysql on your
computer and mysql registers with your
operating system so it's kind of like a
global variable when you start accessing
it and it's designed that way because
normally when you're using an sql or
mysql database it's installed on a
server
so it makes sense that you want it
registered with the operating system so
it's accessed globally
steps to connect your jdbc
step one import your packages this
procedure is followed to make sure that
the relevant packages are readily
available for the api
step two load and register your driver
the imported driver is needed to be
loaded and registered for establishing a
connection between application and
database and if remember in this case
we're doing the mysql so we make sure
our mysql driver is installed
and step 3 connecting database after the
first two steps the next stage is to
connect the database this can be done by
a git connection
step four writing a query
so now we're actually starting it into
your scripting here we write in the sql
command or query that we need to execute
if you're not familiar with sql it's
good to have an sql cheat sheet set up
once you start understanding how it's
put together you'll find that it goes
really quick and it's pretty fast to
learn but it is its own query language
and you do need to learn
a number of the main settings in poll
language so you know what you're doing
step 5 executing query now the query
from the api is executed using execute
query
and we'll actually load that up just as
a string variable when we look at that
you'll see how that fits together
step six processing result after step
five the system basically does two
things it processes an output and
retrieves the values from your query
and then step 7 closing statement the
result set and statement needs to be
closed
explicitly
and you'll find there's two closing
statements there is your result set
which is still pulling from the database
and then step eight
which is we need to actually close
closing connection so the last stage is
to disconnect ourselves or the api from
the database so we no longer have that
open connection using resources
so we're going to jump into our java
database connection example
and we're going to do that with what we
call the university database
let's start with a basic overview of
mysql and you can go to dev.mysql.com
and you'll see here we can look up more
information they have the download of
the newest version
this is
a full sql database package
and some of these you can actually go in
there and if you're doing a database
management they can spread across up to
usually don't want to go more than five
servers but
it is designed to go up to five servers
kind of set up with terabytes of data in
there
for a developer on the programming side
we usually want to install
something like mysql
locally so on my setup it has no network
connections
it doesn't auto start on the boot up of
the computer
and i have it locked down that way if i
use some kind of simple password or
something like that for one of my demos
it doesn't go anywhere no one can access
it
now another option to mysql is also the
sqlite
and you can go to the sqlite.org read
more about it and download it
it has a couple limitations that you're
not going to see in your regular your
full scale mysql or oracle or sql
but most of it will transfer over and so
for a small project you can actually use
it as a backend for storing your data
you can also integrate it or upgrade it
into my sql because most of the sql
commands are the same
and when you go into uh the mysql which
is a significant download versus sql
lite
you can certainly go down to downloads
and then there's also
the connectors so
devmysql.com download slash connector
slash j
and i bring this up because it depends
on how you set up eclipse
for your interface and your ide and it
depends on what you need and how exactly
on your setup as far as the connectors
we'll look at that a little bit more
closer
in the mysql it isn't oracle-based so
you'll have to set up an account if you
don't have one you have to log in it's
all free as long as you're not doing
like the enterprise with all the support
and help on it you don't have to pay for
it it's an open source
now once you've installed
mysql and if you do sqlite you're not
going to have these interfaces it'll all
be done from java code
but once you've installed mysql it's
going to add in a terminal window and
then also
the
workbench which is just a nice gui uh
interface for my sql server
and we're not going to do anything with
the workbench you can play with it
certainly
because a lot of times you don't have
the workbench installed on your computer
especially if the mysql
is set up on a different server and
you're remote accessing it especially
like if you're in the classroom or
something like that they probably have
sent you your login information so you
can get into the shell quick note though
is if you do your own mysql just note
that i kept this as a local host you can
actually see it down here root local
host
no outward connections and that's just
to protect my computer once you start
opening those you have to be aware of
your passwords and since i'm doing demos
i want to keep my passwords really
simple so that's not the focus of the
programming
i had to log out and relog back in
so once you've gone in there you should
have this a lot of times your interface
might be web-based if it's a remote
mysql connection you're working with and
i'll prompt you for your username and
password
in this case mine is on my computer it
automatically has me login as admin so i
have full admin rights
and then we always like to start by at
least i do is show
databases
and these are the current databases on
here
they have some different information on
them that is part of the basic setup and
some examples like sakila and world are
both example databases that
automatically load with mysql
for this example we're going to create a
database
and it's going to be university we'll do
capital there university
don't forget our semicolon
and um
time you can see how long it took 0.69
seconds and of course if we go show
databases
you'll see now that there is a
university in there
and we want to go ahead and use
university
that means that whatever we do any
commands that we have in here for tables
or whatever are now going to be going
into the university database
so now our database has changed
and let's go ahead and zoom in
let's see here we go set okay
a little bit more so we get a nice big
print so you can see what i'm doing a
little bit better
there we go
all right so we're going to go ahead and
create our table
and this has all been prepared so i
don't have to go through and and redo it
all the time
you'll see here we're going to do
create a table engineering student
and then we have
student id is an integer not null
department variable character 25 long
first name
last name pass out year
university rank primary key
in creating this uh note a couple things
first we created a table engineering
students and we've gone ahead and
created the fields as part of the crate
set up here
and the things i want you to note is
that we have our integer so our student
id is an integer our department is a
variable character and is 25 long and
the reason i say that that is really
important is when we flip back on over
here if you remember from our
there we go
if you remember from our data types
here's our variable character and in
java language that's a string
a string
doesn't say hey it's only 25 long and so
you've got to be a little careful when
you're pushing and pulling this data
especially when you're writing the data
from java into the sql that you check
for that length of that string
and then the integer is of course an
integer and of course your other data
types you can see how they follow suit
but with variable character be very
aware of that that that is a designated
25 characters long
and we're going to go ahead and insert
some data in here
here we go we'll go ahead and
insert into
engineering students values
and this is going to be the student id
and it's also the primary key so keep in
mind that that is a
unique value in there and then we have
cse computer science engineering koran
ackeria 2018 1272. so there's our
pass out year 2018
and ranked
i guess number 1272
i'm not sure where the um oh it's a
university ranking there we go
and then we have some prepared data
which i just went ahead and pasted in so
we have a whole bunch of individuals in
our database now
and we'll i mean it's the same line over
and over again insert into engineering
students values and then you have your
list of values
and we can see that by doing a simple
select
uh
we'll do what's the star so it's going
to select everything one of our hot
characters
if you're not familiar with um sql get a
setup on there and look it over
and you can also
download a cheat sheet from somewhere
with all the different commands in there
i myself do a lot of
consulting and so i'm always jumping
around from one platform to another
if you're doing that kind of work it's
more important to understand the
limitations and the advantages of
different systems and then you have your
cheat sheets for putting together stuff
really quickly when you need it
and you can see here the data we just
put in there there's our student ids
department first name last name
passout year and university rank
and we'll go ahead and do one query in
here real quick we're gonna we already
did one query we're gonna do two queries
uh we did select star from engineering
and then we're gonna go ahead and select
student id department first name last
name so you can actually choose what you
select instead of doing the asterisks
where student id equals 10202
and when we go ahead and execute that in
here
oops
there we go
you'll see that it returns the one
individual with that student id here
so let's take this back into our eclipse
because we're still doing the setup so
you have your mysql server set up or you
did sql lite with a little bit different
setup going on there
and let's flip on over and see what's
going on with eclipse
so in eclipse we're going to go in new
we'll start a new
project and we'll call this jdbc
it's our jdbc project whoops
select a wizard
i forgot where i was going on there it's
a java wizard we're looking for this
project java project
there we go and we're going to call this
there now we're in the right spot uh jd
bc package that way everything will be
bundled in there in the same package and
finish it
create all right so you can see right
here we have our new jdbc package we're
working with
now at this point there's a lot going on
as far as your options
if you set this up for doing database
management which i did not and i'm going
to show you the two different ways you
can go under
windows and under preferences
and in this list you'll see
database management and then you can
just go in there and set it up this way
and it'll pull in that information for
your sql connections
now if you did not and you downloaded
the mysql
it does have an option to download the
java connex which would put it into
wherever you installed that at which is
default under your c drive program files
now on mine
i didn't i downloaded the connection
separately
and there's two different ways we can go
under project and under the build
project
give that a moment to come up
oops i mean properties there we go the
project properties and the java build
path
this same window can be accessed by
right-clicking on your
package we're working on and then we can
go down to properties and you'll see the
same window opens up
and we're going to go under java build
path
and we're going under library so these
are libraries we want to include in our
setup
and then i click on our module path and
at this point you'll see add external
jars here
now again if you haven't already preset
up any clips you can just add jars and
it will be in the jar library so there's
different possibilities there but i did
a download so i'm going to go add
external jars
and i happen to keep mine on my d volume
under my sql
and you'll see my sql connector java and
this is
mysql 8.0
and i just go in here
oops there we go i just go ahead and
open this up and you'll see right here
it has my connector java once i set that
in it's now added those packages and
there's hundreds of actual subfiles in
there and it's all set to go and i can
apply and close this window and now i'm
ready to go ahead and start writing my
script and start building a program in
here
and let's go ahead and
go under source new i'm going to put in
a new class in here and we'll just go
call it jdbc
same as the package i'm going to finish
that and we're set up with a new class
in here
and once we've got this set the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and import
all of our java setup in here so we have
the java connection and now we want to
go ahead and import it
and when we look at this
we can see we have our
connection and remember two of these
have to be closed explicitly and that's
your connection
and when you create the statement
you have your driver manager
so when it goes in there that's a piece
that connects to actually does a
connection to the
database the drivers that convert
everything in the code in there so you
have your connection to the database you
have the code that converts it
you have your result so you're going to
get a result off of your query
then you have your exception so if you
have an error throws or something like
that that's where that's going and of
course the actual statement that you're
going to send to the sql server
and of course we want our java to be
able to actually run so we'll put our
main in there public static void main
and it's going to throw the sql
exception uh so you'll see right here
that's what we're working with and
there's our javasql sql exception on
there
so the first thing we're going to need
on our setup let's put that in here it's
going to be our connection information
uh we need to know the username i'm just
going to call it string you name equals
in this case i created a user
richard underscore simplylearn
and then i created a password my
password remember this is a local host
so you probably don't want to have a
simple password like that but mike this
whole database is locked down on just
this computer there's no outside network
access or anything like that to get in
here
and then of course this is a separate
user so it's not even my admin or root
user
and then we go ahead and put a query
right here in this case we'll start with
our most basic query if you remember we
already did that on our at the very
beginning select star from engineering
students and we're going to use that
query in our code to start off with
and then another really common thing
when you're setting this up
is that we also want to test it and see
hey did we import our package correctly
is it set up correctly
so remember we came in and we
imported our my sql connector jar file
in the code we would just want to make
sure it's it's working correctly and
that's what this is it says try class
for name and then it has our
com.mysql.cj.jdbcdriver
saying hey do we have the driver for
this that's all that's doing
and if not then it's going to print an
error so we can find out why it doesn't
have that driver
uh and then next we want to actually
start getting into our actual code and
in here
we're going to do a try because whenever
you do any kind of major connection you
want to make sure
that
you're looking for your errors you're
not going to miss on anything and we're
going to do a catch
and so we're looking for any kind of sql
exception error
and for this demo we'll just do um you
know print it out so i'm hopes wrong
spot
goes into the catch section there we go
uh so we'll print it out over down here
as far as the error on there and it's an
xql exception so still looking for the
code which we haven't put in here yet
and this is really where the the magic
really starts to happen because we have
our
connection
and there we go
and you'll see that the connection is
that's all this is right here here's our
connection up here
and
we pop it down here we have a connection
we'll just call it con
do one end so keep it uniform
there we go
and this is going to go to the driver uh
so in other words right here we're going
to need a
the driver manager and that's where we
imported here and it says get connection
because that's part of the driver
manager
and we have um our url
let's see and we of course forgot to put
the url in up above so let's go ahead
and go back there and put that in
and the url comes out as a jdbc mysql
that is registered with my computer so
my computer has when it's running the
mysql
this is the local host
in this case we call it university
that's where this comes from
and that's all part of your mysql setup
if you're working with the remote
database you want to get this
information from the remote whoever set
the database up
so that you have this particular line of
where to call
and so we go back down here we have our
connection it's all set up on here the
next thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead
and
create our statement
and this initializes it so we have a
statement called statement
but this statement is going to be based
on our
driver manager which is then connected
to the connection so these are all
connected to each other and this
generates the format it needs
uh for when we actually send our inquiry
remember here's our query right here so
we're going to send select star from
engineering students for right now
we haven't put that part in we're just
creating the class or initiating the
instance so that we can do that
and then once we've initiated the
instance here let's go down here
we need to go ahead and generate a
result and so we have our result set
again that comes up here from what we
brought in
we're storing the data coming in or
storing the pipeline to bring it
in we're just going to call that result
and then we have this is generated from
our statement here's our statement so
this is all like linked together here's
our execute query which is part of the
statement and here's the actual query
which is coming that we put together the
select star from engineering students
and then finally we want to actually do
something with our information
so we'll do is we'll just loop through
it while
and here's our result
set that we just generated so wall
result
dot
next
and this just generates a boolean so it
says hey there's still another result
coming in so we need to go ahead and get
that next result
then we'll go ahead and create a
and we'll take that string university
data and then
we're going to loop through the
different results
there we go integer and then
here we go university
data
and we want to tag on the end of it
result.getstring i
so what's going on here there we just
did a bunch of things uh we are going
through each row
result.next each row of data that comes
off of the database until this returns
no there's no next
result coming in there and then we come
in there we look at the result the one
we're looking at is the current one so
it goes through i forget how many we put
in there about 20 it was you know row
twenty zero row one row two row three
row four
and then on each of these rows
we have a string it's an array of
strings
and we're going to get that string and
it returns i so this is get string of
column i
uh so we have row and column
and really important it is programming
to really understand rows and columns
because that's so central to most of the
data processing going on
and then finally we want to go ahead and
see our results so let's print them out
we'll put in our nice uh print statement
uh system out print line university data
so this is going to print each row as it
goes through it and then i'll reset the
row again to an empty string and then
i'll add each of the columns to that row
for my result and then we'll print the
next row out
and now that we have a complete code
let's go ahead and go up here hit the
run button
it's going to compile it runs it out and
we can see down here
let me just get my double mouse we can
get a better view
here's our different
your id comes up
with their i forget what the actual
setup was but the cse the name the date
the ranking
all that prints out one row at a time
and that's what we're doing here of
course if you're processing the data
differently you might be loading this
into a
user interface this might be generating
other information you may be doing
statistics with it
but you can see how it's set up in here
as far as pulling the data into the java
format and then running it from there
just so we can get a quick glimpse of
where this goes let's go back up here
and we're going to flip back and forth
between a couple different screens so
let me do that
uh and here if you remember we did
select star from engineering students
and there's the same thing up here that
we got down here this is our my sequel
server interface and this is the
interface we built in java
and from here we also did this
particular selection select student id
department first name last name pass out
year university rank from engineering
students where student id is
and we got the single row on here
and this is kind of interesting because
i switched something in the code here
where this could cause a problem it
won't on this one
let me go ahead and paste this in here
and we'll run and compile this one
and you see it comes out with the single
user
so the danger of this particular code
is that i went ahead and hard coded in a
loop for i equals one to six
and so this one we pulled it just
happened to be that we did selected six
different columns in here so you gotta
be a little careful when you're coding
in here what are you pulling and where
is it going uh you can see if i take out
oh let's do
we'll just remove the student id
and we're going to run that without the
student id
we compile it there we go and it gives
us a bunch of errors because it doesn't
see the we're short a column down here
so when it gets down to this code down
here
under the while statement
and it goes hey where's number six well
there's no number six and so we get a
lot of errors on that
you can see where our queries uh let me
just go back up here and paste another
query in
there we go
and we'll run this one and we're looking
at is uh we're going to go ahead and do
the same columns
and
we'll just leave this as a star to make
it easy so we're going to select all
columns
from engineering students where the pass
out year is 2018.
just do a copy of that one
and we'll run that
it recompiles
and you can see here's all the 2018
on here if you look at the dates so
they're all 2018
and that's the same as our
query
directly into the sql server if i do the
same thing on here
you'll see they're exactly the same
and just because we're having fun let's
flip this back over here and we'll do
one more sql server
and let's do in this one
let's just take this whole thing out
here
and in this one we're going to pull in
all the departments but i want the
minimal university ranking as the
highest from engineering students that
way we can get an order of the rankings
on here
and we'll go ahead and run this
and there we go there's our minimal one
uh so this one hit the lowest ranking on
there or closest to number one
and we can do that in here and get the
same result uh there's karen karen is
awesome
ranking number 96
and you saw there's other people that
are ranked way below koran so that's
this guy must be super smart
so that concludes our jdbc example
university database where we took a
quick look at mysql server
or you can do sqlite and some basic
queries you can put in there and how
that works
we will discuss all the most frequently
asked questions in the interviews based
on the pattern programs and java first
of all
we will discuss the right angle triangle
pattern
so basically the right angle triangle
star pattern looks something like this
as it is shown on my screen
so to resolve this problem statement and
print the pattern we must assume that
this particular star arrangement is made
in the form of a matrix where the first
row has single star and the second row
has two stars third row has three stars
and so on now to execute this particular
code we might need two for loops so the
first for loop will be for printing the
rows and the second one will be for
printing the columns now let us execute
a practical program and see how does it
work don't worry about the codes that we
will be executing here because i have
formatted a draft about all the codes
that i will be executing today and that
particular file will be attached in the
description box below
so i think my screen is visible to all
on my screen you can see the particular
pattern which is a right angle triangle
star pattern so as discussed before we
will have the first outer for loop which
will be for printing the rows so inside
the outer for loop we have the second
for loop which we will be using for
printing the columns
you can see i have defined the row value
as 5 which means we will be printing the
star pattern for five rows
and we have used a counter variable
which is i which is assigned the value
of one and the comparator operator is
used here which is i should be less than
or equal to the number of rows declared
and followed by that we have a
pre-increment operator and once the
condition is true the control will be
entered into the second for loop where
we have the next counter variable which
is j so we have assigned j is equals to
1 and the comparator operator which is j
should be less than or equal to i which
is the value here which is in the outer
for loop and followed by that we have
the pre-increment operator
once the condition is true the control
will enter into the inside for loop and
will print a star
so here just let us assume that the
value of i is 1 and the statement is
true so the control will enter into the
second for loop and it will see the
conditional operator here so
j is less than or equal to i so value of
1 is less than or equal to 1 and the
star will be printed
after that we have the pre-increment
operator so here the j value will be
incremented to 2.
now if we compare the values 2 is
not less than or not equal to 1. so
the condition fails here so it will not
print a star again it will come out of
the inner for loop and it will see the
next statement which says it should
print in the next line whereas in the
inside for loop you can see we just used
print not print in the new line
so it will come to the new line and go
back to the for loop again and the
increment of i will be taking place and
the same runs again
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so you can see that the program got
successfully executed and the right
angle triangle star pattern is printed
successfully
now let us go into the next type of
program
so the next type of program is the
inverted right angle triangle star
pattern so similarly according to the
previous example we also consider this
one in the form of a matrix
so you can see that in the first row we
have 5 stars in the second row we have 4
stars similarly so on
now let us try to check out the code and
learn how does it work and how to print
the star pattern on a screen
we are back in the practical mode again
so the kind of pattern that we wanted to
print as this one which is a little bit
similar to the previous one but only
thing that is inverted so the code is
pretty much the same but the only
changes that we need to do are related
to the comparator operator
in the previous example we chose that i
should be less than or equal to 1 and in
the next stage we used pre-increment
operator in here we are using a
different one
which is pre-decrement and inside the
for loop we have the j comparator
operator
in the same way so here we have declared
the row value as 5 and inside the for
loop we will equate the counter variable
equals to rows which is five and
followed by that the comparator operator
compares if the value of phi is greater
than or equal to one and followed by
that we will use the pre-decrement
operator once the condition is true the
control will enter into the inside for
loop and here the counter variable j is
assigned to the value 1 and the
condition is
j should be
less than or equal to i
and followed by that we have the
pre-increment operator which is plus
plus j so once the condition is true it
will print the value of a star and
followed by that it will again
continue the loop so here the follow
will work in the following way and i is
equals to 5 is greater than or equal to
1 which is true and pre-decrement so the
condition is true so the control will
enter into the inside for loop where it
will again compare with value of j j is
equals to 1 and j is less than or equal
to 5 and followed by that we have the
post increment so the control will enter
inside the for loop and print a star and
followed by that in the next instance
the value of j will be incremented to 2
so 2 is less than or equal to i followed
by that
pre-increment and in the next iteration
it will print a star again so this will
continue until the condition is true
once the condition fails the control
will exit the follow and print in the
next line you can see that we have print
in the new line here which is unlike the
print function which is inside the for
loop so this will continue until the
statements are true now let us try to
execute this program and see if the
desired pattern will be printing or not
there you can see that the program got
successfully executed and the pattern
which we desired for is printed on the
screen
now let us move ahead into the next type
of pattern
so the next type of pattern is the arrow
shaped pattern and this almost looks
familiar to the previous two programs
the only difference is we have combined
them together to form an arrow pattern
now let us try to combine the previous
two programs and print this
so now you can see on my screen we have
our desired pattern which looks like an
arrow so as discussed before we are
trying to combine the two programs that
we executed before so the first half of
the program
is designed for the first half of the
pattern which is completely similar to
our first program so the second half of
the pattern is from our second program
but the only difference here is we have
considered
the value of rows is row minus 1 because
we don't want
another extra row to be printing here in
this way so you can see if we used i
value is equals to rows then the pattern
would be something like this we will not
have a pointed edge so to get a pointed
edge we will use row minus 1 to get this
pattern what we desired for
now let us try to execute this program
and print the output
now let us enter the number of rows we
want let's enter
so there you go let me expand my output
screen
yeah there you go we have the pattern
which we desired for
and don't forget that we need to use row
minus 1 in the next stage which is the
second half of the program
so this is how the arrow pattern is
printed now let us move further and see
the next type of pattern in our list so
in the next pattern we have the right
angle triangle which is completely
similar to the first one but
the hypotenuse is on the other side
as you can see this is the difference
between the first program and this
program so in the first program we had
the hypotenuse in this direction and now
we have the hypotenuse in the opposite
direction
now similarly to the first program we
shall consider this one as well in the
form of a matrix
so you can see if we consider this
pattern in the form of a matrix we have
four spaces
followed by a star similarly in the
second row we have three spaces followed
by two stars in the third one we have
two spaces and three stars and so on so
the main point that we need to consider
here is first we need to print the
spaces followed by that we need to print
the stars to get this pattern
now let us execute a practical program
and see the output
so back in the practical mode you can
see on my screen the desired pattern
what we are looking for is this
so here
the only difference is
we have to print this pieces first so
for printing the spaces we will be using
this folder with the condition j is
equals to 2 into n minus i and j should
be greater than or equals to 0 and
j
decrement which is a post decrement
operator so what is the value of n n is
nothing but the value of rows so the
value of n is declared in the main
function and n is equals to 5 after that
we will be calling the print stars
function which is over here and the
value of n will be carried over here and
then the counter variables i and j will
take care of the for loops now let us
try to execute this program and see the
output
so you can see that the program is
successfully executed and the desired
pattern is printed successfully so this
for loop will be run until the condition
is true once this follow fails we will
enter into the next for loop which is
particularly designed to print the stars
now after this let us move ahead into
our next type of pattern
so the next type of pattern is an
inverted right angle triangle pattern
which is opposite to the second type of
program that we dealt with
now similarly let us consider this in
the same way as we considered all the
other programs that is in the form of a
matrix so here we have five stars in the
first row four stars in the next one and
one space followed by that we have two
spaces followed by that we have the
three stars and three spaces two stars
and so on
now let us see a practical program and
try to print this particular pattern
so we are back in the practical mode so
you can see that the desired star
pattern is this and it is completely
similar to our previous pattern
so the only difference is we tried to
print spaces first in the earlier
pattern and here we are trying to print
the stars first so that's the only
difference
and we have the same for loops so the
first for loop is for rows and it will
print spaces and the second for loop is
for stars which will print the stars as
you can see we have the row values and
the column values here as the comparator
operator
and we have the comparator operator
which finds if j is greater than i
in the first case
the loop will fail because the value of
j and i are completely similar because
we have declared i is equals to rows in
the first outer for loop and same j is
equals to rows in the second inner for
loop so obviously the condition has to
fail and it will not print any space
here it will directly enter into the
next for loop and will print the star
pattern and followed by that we will
enter into the next line so this
follow-up will print the number of stars
in the first row according to the row
number for example if we give 5 as the
row number then it will print 5 stars in
the first row and it will exit the for
loop and it will enter into the next
line and the same pattern will be
continued now let us try to execute this
program and see the output
now let us give 5 as the number of rows
needed
so there you go you can see the star
pattern here
so this is how this particular star
pattern will be generated
now let us move further and check out
the next type of pattern program in our
list so the next type of pattern program
in our list is
arrow
so this arrow is completely similar to
the previous one the only difference is
it is in the inverted way which is it
has pointed towards
the left side now let us check out the
practical program and learn how to
execute this
back on to eclipse ide
so
you can find some similarities between
the previous two programs and this
particular program in the previous two
programs we tried to print the first
half of the pattern and followed by that
we have printed the second half of the
pattern now we are going to just combine
both the programs and print this
particular arrow pattern
so here the first half of this
particular program is concerned with the
top portion of this pattern which is the
right angle triangle followed by that
the second half of the program where we
have the conditions
placed so this particular segment of the
code takes care about the second half of
the program which is the inverted right
angle triangle
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so let us specify the number of rows as
five completely similar to the previous
two programs
now let's press enter now there you go
let me expand my
console
so there you go you can see the arrow
pattern
so this is how you print an arrow
pattern pointing towards the left side
we have also discussed an arrow pattern
where the arrow will be pointing towards
the right side as the program number
three
again don't worry about the quotes
all the programs that i'm going to
execute in this session are drafted in
the form of a text document and that is
linked in the description box below you
can take that source file and practice
the programs for yourself no worry
now let's move ahead and check out the
next type of program
so the next type of pattern that we have
in our list is the pyramid we also call
this
an acute angled triangle
star pattern
now let us understand the logic for this
now you can see without the matrix
format this looks completely similar to
our first program but only the
differences we have a space which is
obvious but there is a small difference
let us check out what the difference is
if we look this program in the form of a
matrix you can see there are variations
in spaces in the first row we have two
spaces one star followed by that again
two spaces
in the next row we have alternate space
and star space and star and similarly in
the third row we have a star space star
and space so this is how the matrix
continues according to the number of
rows provided
so let us understand how the logic
exactly works for this program
okay
so you can see
the pattern that we desired is in the
form of an acute angle triangle or
pyramid now we have two counter
variables which is i is equals to 0 in
the outer follow and j is equals to n
minus 1 which is inside the for loop so
the value of n is equals to 5 which is
the total number of rows that we needed
in a particular pattern
now you can see in the outer for loop we
have the condition which is i should be
less than n so i should be less than the
number of rows which is equals to five
followed by that we have the post
increment operator i plus plus so the
condition will be true because 0 is less
than 5 and it will enter into the inside
for loop where we have j
which is equals to 5 minus 0
followed by that we have the condition
so 5 is greater than 1
so the resultant of this particular
statement is 5 so 5 which is now the
value of j is greater than 1
followed by that we have the post
decrement operator which will decrease
the value of j in every iteration so
once the statement is true it will try
to print a space
so it will print the spaces until the
condition is true
so once the first for loop fails the
control will enter into the next
following for loop where we have j is
equals to 0 and j should be less than or
equal to the value of i which is
currently equals to 0
and followed by the conditional
statement we have the post increment
operator which is j plus plus so this
particular for loop is used for printing
two things
which is the first one star followed by
that we have a space so once this follow
gets executed the control will exit it
and will print in the new line so this
is how the program works now let us try
to execute this program and see the odd
there you go the program got
successfully executed and the required
spaces and the stars have been printed
here so as you can see we have spaces
followed by that we have a star
similarly
space
spaces on to the left
a star and the second star
so followed by the previous program we
have the next program which is also
considered to be like a pyramid but the
only difference is it is in an inverted
format now let us check out the logic
behind this program and try to execute a
practical program so logic wise it's
completely similar to the previous one
we have star followed by that we have a
space and again a star space and a star
next row we have alternate space and
star and finally we have two spaces star
and two spaces so the number of spaces
and stars is based upon the number of
rows we provide
now let us try to execute a program and
see the output don't worry this is
completely similar to the previous one
but the only difference is it is printed
in the inverted fashion so there will be
minor changes to the code let's try to
look on those changes
so here we are back in eclipse so the
desired pattern is here which is an
inverted pyramid and the preview program
was a regular pyramid
so here is the logic and we have the
following for loops so the first for
loop is dedicated for printing the
number of spaces we require so inside
the exterior for loop we have the
counter variable i is equals to 0 and i
should be less than or equals to the
number of rows minus 1 and followed by
that we have the post increment operator
i plus plus
so let us assume that we have provided
the number of rows to be 5 and according
to the logic i is equals to 0 and
followed by that 0 is less than or
equals to 5 minus 1 which is 4 and
followed by that we have the post
increment operator which will increment
the value of i to 1 once after the for
loop first iteration is finished so once
the exterior follow condition is true
the control will enter into the second
for loop which is the internal follow
and we have the second counter variable
which is j is equals to 0 followed by
that the comparator operator which says
j should be either less than or equal to
the value of i followed by that we have
the post increment operator on j so this
particular code segment or the first
part of the program takes care about the
number of spaces we require in our
pattern followed by that we have the
second
which will take care of the number of
stars we print and the number of spaces
we require after the star pattern
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
now let us provide the number of rows we
need let's provide the value as 5.
now there you go according to the logic
provided in the program the star
patterns are successfully generated
followed by the spaces
now moving ahead we have the next type
of pattern
which is the combination of first and
second pyramids
now let us understand the logic and
print this pattern
now you can see the desired pattern is
the combination of the first pyramid and
the second pyramid so the first half of
the program is derived from the first
pyramid pattern and the second
part of the program is derived from the
second pyramid pattern now we have
combined them together and now we are
trying to print the rhombus pattern
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
let us provide the number of
rows as five
and there you go
so here you can see the desired star
pattern has been successfully executed
so according to the input we have the
first five rows and followed by that we
have the inverted star pattern where we
avoided the first row and printed the
following four rows
so that we have a proper rubik's pattern
now moving ahead we shall see the next
type of pattern in our list
so followed by the previous pattern we
have the next type of pattern which
looks completely similar to the previous
one
but the only difference is we have
printed the second type of pyramid first
and then the first type of pyramid which
makes it look like an hourglass
now let us understand the logic and
print this pattern
so here is the desired pattern what we
are looking for and this was the
previous pattern what we printed
now followed by the first segment we
have the second segment which is
dedicated to print the second half of
the pattern which happens to be the
first type of pyramid which is a regular
pyramid but the only difference is
inside the first follow we are using the
rows minus one command because we don't
want
an extra star so if we add in an extra
star this pattern will look a little
abnormal so let us try so this is what
it looks like if we had an extra star
there so let us remove it
so this is how our pattern should look
like so that's the reason why we are
using row -1 here now let us try to
execute this program and see the output
now let us enter the number of rows we
want let us input 5
enter so there you go you can see the
program got successfully executed and
the desired star pattern has been
printed on the console
now let us move further and have a look
on the next type of pattern in our list
so followed by the hourglass pattern we
have the next pattern where we need to
print a diagonal star pattern
now if we look at the logic it's just a
single line which is placed in the form
of a diagonal
now let us check the logic behind it
so you can see we have printed stars in
the form of a diagonal
of a matrix now we have the first four
spaces followed by that we have a star
and similarly three spaces provided by a
star then a space and so on now to print
this pattern what's the logic let's go
back to eclipse and try to print this
program
so this is our desired pattern now let
us go into our program
now inside the program we have two
counter variables which are 1 i 2 is j
so the first for loop is i is equals to
1 i is less than or is equals to 5 which
is the row number then i post increment
so when the logic is true which is one
is less than or equal to the row number
five the control will enter into the
second for loop so once the control
enters into the outer for loop we have
the second for loop where we have our
second counter variable which is j j is
equals to 0 and j is less than 5 minus i
which is 5 minus 1 which is the current
value of i which is 4 so
0 is the value of j currently so 0 is
less than 4 followed by that we have the
post increment on j counter variable so
once the condition is true the control
will enter into the second inner for
loop and will print space
so this loop will run until the
condition is true once the condition
fails it will come out of the inner for
loop and will print a star in the new
line
followed by that it will continue to
start the outer for loop again so this
is how the flow goes ahead now let's run
the program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the desired
pattern is printed now let's move ahead
and understand the next type of pattern
in our program
so the next type of pattern is a little
bit similar to the previous one
so in the previous pattern we had one
diagonal right now we have two diagonals
which have formed the shape of x so we
can consider this as a next pattern now
let's check out the logic and
next after that let's execute the
program so according to the logic when
we consider this particular pattern in a
form of a matrix we have the stars
printed in the first row followed by
that we have three spaces and then again
a star so this is continued in the same
way with alternate spaces and in the
third row we have a single intersection
point with one star so this is how the
pattern should look like once the
program gets executed now let us check
out the program and see the output
so you can see on my output console this
was our previous pattern now what we are
going to do is make a similar pattern in
the opposite direction and make sure
they intersect each other
now you can see our program has two
segments the first segment and the
second segment
they both look a little similar because
the first segment will print the upper
part of the pattern that is the first v
and then the second segment will print
the lower part of the pattern which is
the inverted v
now let us check out the condition
we have the first outer loop which has
the first counter variable which is i is
equals to n n is nothing but the number
of rows that we want in our pattern
then i
should be greater than or equal to 1
followed by that we have the post
decrement operator where we will
decrease the value of i
then if the condition is true then the
control will enter into the next
statement where we have the inner for
loop with second counter variable that
is j is equals to i then the condition
is j should be less than the value of
rows provided then post increment of j
and if the condition statement is true
then it will enter into the inner for
loop and it will print a space similarly
for printing the star we have the next
segment
inside the next segment the condition is
a little trickier because we don't want
to print any stars in the space between
the x pattern we provide this condition
where j is equals to 1 and j should be
less than or equal to 2 times the value
of i which is the auto for loop minus 1
if this condition is true the control
will enter inside the for loop where we
have if else condition if j is equals to
is equals to 1 or j is equals to is
equals to 2 into i minus 1 then we
should print a star else we should print
a space
so this will print the upper part of the
pattern and similarly we have another
segment which will print the lower part
of the pattern which is the inverted v
pattern now let's execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the program got executed
now let us provide the value of n
let us provide phi and there you go you
can see that the program printed the
desired pattern so this is the first
half of the pattern which is the proper
v then this is the second half of the
program which is the inverted v so this
is what the flow of the program is
now let us move further and check out
the next pattern in our list
so the next pattern in our list is the
inverted v pattern
now let us check out the logic behind it
if you see this in the form of a matrix
then you can recognize this
we had already discussed similar program
which was the third one where we had
printed the pyramid shape but the only
difference is we have missed out the
star in between
which makes it look like a inverted v
now let us go back to eclipse and
execute a program based on this to print
this pattern
as you can see we have our desired
pattern on my screen which is an
inverted v so if we check out the logic
we have
outside loop and inside loop
so we have two for loops so the first
outer for loop has
out is equals to one out should be less
than or equals to the number of row size
then
post increment of outside variable
if the condition is true we enter into
the inner for loop where we have inner
loop is equals to one inner loop should
be less than or equals to the row size
into two then we have increment operator
which is a post increment so if this
particular condition is true then we
enter into another statement where we
have the if else statement so if in
value is equal to is equals to control x
or in is equals to print control y
then we should print star else we should
print a space now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
now let us provide the row size which is
5 so as you can see we have got our
desired pattern
now let us move ahead and execute the
next type of pattern which is the v
pattern now let us understand the logic
behind it
it is completely similar to the previous
program but the difference is
the pattern is in inverted position to
the previous one which is in the proper
v format so now let us try to check out
the code and execute the program and
print the
pattern
so on my screen you can see the desired
pattern what we are looking for which is
v now the previous program was to print
an inverted v so the complete program is
same but only there is a minor change in
the logic where we have replaced i as
greater than or equal to 0.
and there is some change in the second
segment as well now let us try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the desired
pattern is printed here the value of n
or row size is equals to 5 which we have
declared here in the main part now let
us get back and check out the next
pattern to be executed in our list
so the next pattern is the combination
of both an inverted v and a normal v
which will result in the form of a
rhombus
now as you can see this is our previous
program now we have two segments in our
code where we have the first segment to
print the starting or the top position
which is an inverted v format and the
second segment of the code is designed
to print the second half of the pattern
which is the normal v pattern so we will
combine these two and print the rhombus
shape
now let me provide the number of rows
which is five so there you go you can
see the desired pattern now let us move
ahead and check out our next pattern
so the next pattern is completely
similar to one of the previous ones
which is a pyramid pattern but the
difference is this pyramid is hollow or
in other words this looks like an acute
angled triangle
now let us understand the logic behind
it so if you look at this matrix then
you can find that we are going to print
the stars in the form of a side of the
triangle which is we will print the
stars in this shape of a triangle and
nothing inside the matrix
now let us understand the program and
print this pattern so as you can see the
desired pattern has been located here
which is a triangular pattern now inside
this we have three particular for loops
so the first follow-up is the outer
follow and the rest two for loops are
the internal for loops so the first
internal for loop is dedicated to print
spaces where we don't require stars
and the second internal for loop is
dedicated to print stars where we
require them also we have an f else
condition which decides where to print a
star and where not to
now
if we look at the condition i should be
less than or equal to the number of rows
provided and if the condition is true
then we enter into the internal follow
and in the internal follow if j is less
than the number of rows given then in
that particular location we need to
print a space once the condition in the
first for loop is failed the control
will enter into the next for loop where
we have the next counter variable that
is k is equals to 1 and k should be less
than or equals to 2 into i minus 1 where
the value of i is 1 at the current stage
and followed by that we have the post
increment of the value of k if k is
equal to equal to 1 or i is equal to
equal to the number of rows or k is
equal to equal to 2 star i minus 1
then we should print a star so this will
give the location in the matrix where we
should print star to make it as a
triangle pattern
if location is anything else than the
condition provided then we should be
printing space there
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
let us provide the number of rows as 5
so there you go we have printed the
desired pattern
so the next pattern after the triangle
pattern is the box pattern so this
particular program will be completely
similar to the previous program the only
difference is we need to find the
locations where we need to print stars
so that the resultant pattern looks like
a box so for that we will make some
changes in our program and those changes
will be related to the rows and columns
now let us understand the logic so as
discussed before we need to look at this
pattern in the form of a matrix and
check out the number of rows and columns
so where the number of row and column
are equal
we need to print a star so let us now
check out the program and execute the
program to print this particular pattern
so as you can see on my screen we have
the same program that we used to print
the triangle but now here we have rows
and columns so n is nothing but the row
and m is nothing but the column so if
the value of the external for loop that
is i is equals to equals to 1 and i is
equals to equals to the number of rows
provided similarly j is equal to equal
to 1 which is the internal for loop
counter variable value and if j is equal
to equals to m that is the column value
then we should print a star in that
particular location and wherever the
location does not match we should
provide a space now let us try to
execute this program and see the output
so there you go we have our desired
pattern which is the box pattern
now let us move ahead and check out the
next type of pattern in our list
so you can see the next pattern is
completely similar to our first pattern
the first pattern was a right angled
triangle now we have the same right
angle a triangle but the only difference
is we have used numbers here now we will
use the numbers from our for loops and
we will print the same values in our
pattern so that it looks like a right
angle triangle
now let us understand the logic so we
will see this pattern in the form of a
matrix now we will print the numbers
where we require them where we don't
require the numbers we will print spaces
now let us check out the program and
execute it to print the following
pattern
now you can see we have got back to our
same program
but the only difference is here we are
using the values of the inner for loop
which is j
instead of a star previously we used
star symbol here
and we are now replacing it with the
inner follow up value let us try to
execute this program and see the output
now let us enter the number of rows as 5
and there you go we have the values of
the internal for loop making the pattern
look like a right angle triangle pattern
now let us move further and check out on
our next type of pattern in the list
so here is another right angle triangle
in our list but the difference is we are
using the numbers in a continuous manner
which is one two three four five six to
fifteen
this type of triangle is also called as
floyd's triangle
now let us understand the logic
so similar to the previous one we will
consider this in the form of a matrix
and we will print the numbers only way
we require them that is to form a right
angle triangle where we don't need the
numbers we will try to print a space
there now let us check out the program
and execute it and print this pattern
now you can see we have got back to
eclipse and don't get scared about the
pattern it's completely similar to the
previous one only thing is we will be
using one extra counter variable which
is k so we have provided the value of k
is equals to 1 and where we are supposed
to print stars we will add the post
increment operator to the counter
variable k so whenever the for loop gets
executed we will be printing the values
of k which is 1 2 3 4 5 and so on now
let us try to execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the values of k one two
three four five six seven until fifteen
so this is how the floyd's triangle work
now let's get back and check out the
next pattern in our list so the next
pattern in our list is similar to the
previous one which is pyramid so this
type of pyramid is also called as
pascal's triangle now let us check out
the logic the logic is completely
similar to the pyramid's logic but
instead of star we are going to use
numbers so this type of triangle is
called as pascal's triangle and the
logic is also a little bit different
from the regular pyramid let us
understand the logic through the code
so now you can see the program on my
screen
so the logic and the for loops used are
completely similar to that of the
pyramid but only the difference is we
are going to print the value of number
so the number is firstly initialized as
1 followed by that we have a formula for
that which is number is equals to number
into i minus j divided by j plus 1 which
are the values of the counter variables
of
outer for loop and in a for loop
respectively
now let's try to execute this program
and see the pattern
so you can see the program could
successfully executed and the floyd's
triangle has been successfully
constructed here
now let us move ahead and check out the
next pattern in our list so the next
pattern in our list is a box which is
made up of binary numbers now let us
understand the logic for it first
so if we look at this in the form of a
matrix we have binary numbers 1 and 0
which forms the pattern of a box
now let us check out the program and
execute the program to print this
particular pattern
so you can see on my screen we have the
program to print that particular box
type of pattern using the binary numbers
so we have the external for loop for
rows and the counter variable i is
equals to 1 and i should be less than or
equal to the number of rows provided
once the condition is true we enter into
the external for loop where we have the
number
and where we have the condition i
modulus 2 is equals to is equals to 0
and the number is equals to 0
and inside that we have our logic to
print the binary numbers
now let us try to execute this program
and see the order
now let me
place the number of rows as 5 and there
you go we have our
box pattern using binary numbers
now let us get back and check the next
pattern in our list
so the next pattern is the ruby pattern
this is completely similar to our
program where we printed the ruby
pattern using the stars now we will use
the numbers and print that particular
pattern now the logic for this is
completely same that of the ruby pattern
we used but the only difference is
instead of a star we'll be placing the
value of the counter variables
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and instead of
stars we have printed the ruby pattern
using the numbers
now moving ahead we have our next
pattern
so here the next pattern is completely
similar to the first one which is the
right angled triangle pattern but here
instead of numbers or stars we will be
using alphabets so for alphabets we will
be using the ascii values in the program
let us check out that program soon now
first let's understand the logic the
logic is also completely similar to the
right angle triangle which we followed
for stars and numbers
now let's check out the program
so as you can see the desired pattern is
the right angle triangle made out of
alphabets so the logic is completely
true but the only difference is we are
going to print characters using ascii
values and alphabet function
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so the desired pattern is the right
angle triangle printed using the
alphabets now the logic is completely
similar to the right angle triangle
pattern but the only difference is we
are going to use the ascii values so we
have declared an integer type variable
alphabet with the ascii value 65 which
should start the alphabets from
capital a because the ascii value of
capital a is 65.
now let us run the program and see the
output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
right angle triangle printed using the
capital alphabet now let's get back and
check out our next pattern
so our next pattern is a pyramid again
so instead of numbers and stars we are
going to use the alphabetical values
now let's check out the logic
even here you can see the logic is
similar to the pyramid logic
now let's check out the code and execute
the code and see the pattern now you can
even see the logic is also similar to
the pyramid logic but here the only
difference is we are going to use the
ascii value that is 65 which is
equivalent to capital a now in the print
statement instead of a star we are going
to print the alphabets and this
particular follow-up is for spaces now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the pyramid pattern has
been successfully printed
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the byte code
in the runtime
jit or just in time compiler compiles
code to machine level directly for
higher speeds of code execution
so basically just-in-time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader now let's discuss
the answer for this particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute any java
program so the java class loader is the
integrated part of java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders
so the third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java so the answer for this
particular question is
java provides multiple types of memory
allocations but the five major types of
memory allocations which are most
frequently used are class memory heap
memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is
yes
because java does not follow any
specific rule for the order of
specifiers you place in your program so
when you execute the program with such
pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare a local variable or a global
variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if you just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question
so what would be the output of the
following code segment is the sixth
question so this might happen sometimes
so basically what happens is your
interviewer will throw a question at you
which has a code segment so all you need
to do is decode that code in your mind
and provide the output so this would be
the code that we will be dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has 100 plus hundred plus
a string which is simply learn and in
the second printf statement we have a
string that is e-learning company plus
hundred plus hundred so what will be the
output of these two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and e-learning company
100 100 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so jvm
here understands 100 as an integer value
and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here so followed by the
addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers 100 plus hundred so
followed by that we have another plus
symbol here so followed by the plus
symbol we have a string value so here
the jvm considers the plus symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learn similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value
so it considered the plus symbol as a
concatenating operator similarly it
happened with the second plus symbol as
well so that's the reason we had
elearning one zero zero one zero zero as
the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association
so the answer for this question is an
association can be defined as a
relationship that has no ownership over
the other so to understand this
definition we can consider a simple
example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c
and similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and bank c are
associated with the person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x but the banks do
not possess any kind of ownership over
the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface but normally in
interface we provide some signatures so
these signatures belong to particular
methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning
i guess the word object learning is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented so this question might be a
little confusing but it's true java is
not completely object oriented but
what's the reason
yes i'll explain you why java is not
completely object oriented
so the answer for this question is java
is not considered as 100 object-oriented
programming language because of the data
types it uses
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are end flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100
object-oriented programming language so
the next question is
define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is
in java when you declare primitive data
types that is the end flow double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types just as we discussed
before
java is not 100 object oriented
programming language just because of the
primitive data types it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones which
convert them into objects or reference
types for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes
so followed by that we have our next
question that says define package in
java so if you use some of the popular
ides that is the integrated development
enterprises such as intellij or eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file so basically you create a project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
java program so here the question is
define package in java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and jar files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember
c programming language we had pointers
there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no
because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implicitly so java's major
motto was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
implement pointers in java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared now followed by the
16th question we have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool
so for example you wanted to create a
new string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string port if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there
then the jvm will create a new string
that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program
so for example just consider that you
are going to write a program for
division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
0 or any other sort of input so if this
kind of input is provided to your
program then your program might crash so
you can avoid this kind of crash by
using exception handling so basically
you can use try and catch blocks so you
can embed your code inside the try block
and say to your program that if any kind
of wrong input such as special symbol or
zero is provided by the evaluator then
send a message saying wrong input or
divide by zero exception so this kind of
approach will provide an output but this
kind of approach will avoid your program
from crashing so this is how exceptions
are handled in real time so followed by
this we have our next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable will
remain constant throughout the execution
of program so sometimes if you include a
normal variable and provide an operation
on that particular variable then the
value of that particular variable will
change after the execution of program
but when you declare the same variable
using final keyword then no number of
operations or any kind of manipulations
applied onto that variable will not
change the value of that particular
variable so that's a specialty or final
keyword in java
so followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method don't forget to specify the
static keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions followed by the
beginners segment we have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is so
jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets
oracle has the following variants for
java development kit so the first one is
the jdk standard edition which is
normally used by beginners and
intermediate developers next after the
jdk standard edition we have the java
development kit for enterprise
so this particular enterprise edition is
used by professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition
now followed by 21st question we will
dive into the next question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public
then that particular data member or
method can be accessible by any class or
object throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only and
finally we have the protected access
specifier so the protected access
specifier is a bit more secure than the
private access specifier so the access
for this particular protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method could be a little more difficult
to access unless you are going to
implement everything which is present in
that particular package
so basically if you are trying to access
the protected data member or protected
data manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically so finally after the major
three axis specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
java virtual machine so in case if you
declare a variable or a data
manipulating method without using any
specific access specifiers that are
public private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is
can a constructor written a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows
yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but
automatically it returns the instance of
a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
the term this keyword is used to refer
to the current class properties like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain
super keyword in java so the answer for
this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism so now let's have a
correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures using one method name
is called as method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name add so here
you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference
you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method then which method to be
overloaded that's the confusion right so
should i overload or should i execute
the first add method or the second
method so this completely depends on the
number of parameters you pass if you are
passing two parameters then the first
method will be executed if you are
passing three parameters then the second
method will be executed so this is how
the method overloading happens in java
so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before the values of the
variables or data manipulating methods
will not be changed when we have used
the keyword static in front of it so the
question is can we overload a static
method now let's discuss the answer for
this
the answer is no java does not support
overloading of static method
the process worked through an error
reading static method cannot be
referenced
so followed by this we have our next
question
so the next question is define
late binding the answer for this
question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the methods code
segment
late binding happens when the method's
code segment is unknown till the method
is called during the run time
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the runtime the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in
linkedlist than an array
so basically lint list and array are the
java collections or in other words it's
also considered as data structure so to
answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is um
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations so consider that your
memory location starts from 100 and your
array has 10 locations so it's a
complete reserved block of from 100 101
102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list
you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then what you do is just to
manipulate the addresses so the address
of the consecutive node will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the
delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make a minor update
to the point of value so that the node
can point to the next successor in the
list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly born state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
perform the operation of right shifting
so when you provide a binary number or
binary value then the bits will be
shifted towards the right and the second
symbol or the second operator which is
having three greater than symbols is
used to shift out the zero filled bits
so this is the functionality of these
two operators now followed by that let's
have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages the first
stage is the initialization stage next
is the start stage third is the stop
stage fourth is destroy and finally we
have paint
now the next question is
why are generics used in java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation generic methods and classes
help programmers to specify a single
method declaration a set of related
methods or with a single class
declaration a set of related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain
externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
right external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization
serialization is a process of sending
your java code or java project from one
computer system to a different computer
system so basically if you wanted to
execute some kind of java program from a
different location then you serialize
this particular code to a different
location where you actually want to
execute and this particular process of
transferring your code is called as
serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
daemon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java
the set daemon method is used to create
the demon thread in java programming
language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in java
so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class when creating the
objects at load time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called
so the answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the finalize
method just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is
can the keywords this and super
we used together so the answer for this
question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use so with this
let's continue with the next question in
the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain jd bc so the answer is jdbc is
an abbreviation for java database
connector jdbc is an abstract layer used
to establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of
jsp the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine
after the jsp page is compiled into a
servlet directives are used to set page
level instructions
insert data from external files and
specify custom tag libraries directives
are defined between the following
symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive so
include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page
the page directive is used to define
specific attributes in the jsp page like
error page and buffer the taglib
directory is used to declare a custom
tag library which is used in the jsp
page
followed by that we have the next
question
what are observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe
observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to
read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative desk
course of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any java application
so the next question is explain jca in
java so the answer for this question is
jca is basically an abbreviation for
java cryptography architecture
so jca provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security so the next
question is
explain jpa in java so the answer for
this question is
jpa stands as an abbreviation for java
persistence api
the jpa is enabling us to create the
persistence layer for desktop and web
applications
jpa deals with the following
java persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form based authentication
in this particular type of
authentication the login form is made by
the programmer by using html
followed by that we have the third type
of authentication
that is digest authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly we have the client certificate
authentication the client certificate
authentication requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate itself
this requires ssl protocol hello guys
this is vikesh and let's get started
with today's topic which is about
working through a particular project
using all the concepts which we have
learned so far
so in this session we are going to focus
on a particular project
and the project we are going to focus is
is about an atm application
so you might have interacted with
different atm stores in your cities
where you go in you insert your card you
enter your pin and then you can view the
balance you can withdraw some amount you
can also deposit some amount from the
atm
so we will try to look at it from that
perspective and and we will see what
kind of different java and oops concepts
we can use to build such atm application
this is not a super versatile
application but this is just to give you
the idea of how to use those oops
concepts to build a simple or a complex
java application so let's start from the
options menu class because that will
give us the understanding of what kind
of functionality i'm using
and here you will use that
i am using different concepts which i
have taught you so far in this
particular series
so for example we are using the iu
exception we are using the hashmap class
we are also using a scanner class which
is used to take input from the command
line
so this option menu class is extending
the account class and i will come to the
account class in a while but let's see
what this option menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of
format of money you have
then we have a hash map which is storing
the couple of
records of account number to pin mapping
so we create a map and inside the get
login method
we add couple of entries to the map
here the first entry the first integer
is pointing to the customer number
and the second integer is pointing to
the pin of the account of this
particular customer number
so
if we call the get login method this
method will insert the data
after that it will ask the customer to
enter the customer number which has to
be one of these two
if you provide any other value then
there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input
so whatever a customer number the
customer inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number
again i will come back to that
and once you have provided a valid
customer number then this method is
going to ask you to enter a pin number
and remember i told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping
so whatever customer number you select
from here
you will be providing the corresponding
pin number and again if you provide an
invalid pin number you will get an error
so that will all happen inside this try
block and
if you enter any invalid characters in
the pin number or the atm
customer number then you will get an
exception which i am writing inside the
catch block
this is all what we have seen so far
after the successful enter of the
customer number and the pin number i
fetch those values from these two
methods again i will talk about what
these methods are doing
and again i'm doing some basic
validation checks but things get
interesting in this method
so what we covered so far was the get
login method let me close this method
here
so we covered the get login method the
second method which is defined in this
particular class is the account type
so here that we will ask the once the
customer has provided the customer
number and the pin number we will ask
the customer to provide the account type
this application supports two different
account types which are checking account
or a savings account so whatever so the
customer has to choose one of them again
we will be taking the input from the
command line using the scanner class
and then i'm using a switch case if the
customer entered one then i will execute
some code for the checking account which
is defined here in the case 1
and if the customer entered 2 then the
case 2 will be executed
and if the if it enters 3 then i will
exit the application by just printing a
sys out
so here i am using the switch case
construct to provide different options
to the customer
there is also a default case specified
here which says invalid choice
so this is what is happening in the get
account type method
the next method is if the customer has
used the option one
then we call the getchecking method
so let's go to the getchecking method
which is the next method which is
defined in this particular class so if
the customer has selected a checking
account then we provide the following
functionality to the customer
which is the customer can view the
balance
customer can withdraw the funds
customer can deposit the funds to the
checking account or they can just exit
the application
and again i'm using a switch case here
based on the customer types 1 2 3 or 4
the corresponding case block will be
executed for example if the customer
wants to view the balance
then this block will get executed and i
call the get account type method
if the customer selects the
to as the withdraw fund then get
checkings with withdraw input method
gets called
and then get account type gets called
similarly if the customer enters three
then we deposit the fund and for that
also i have defined a method i will go
to the definition of these methods as we
go along but right now we are just
building the framework
so the get checking deposit input method
will be called whenever the customer
selects the option three
and for option four we just exit the
application
so this is what is happening in the get
checking method
now if from the account selection if the
customer selected second option which
was savings account then we were calling
get saving method
so this is where the get saving method
is defined
and again it is following the exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method
where we present the following options
like viewing balance withdrawing the
funds and depositing the funds in the
savings account
and i have some methods defined here for
example get saving withdraw input
get saving deposit input
so we define the switch case here based
on the customer's choices here
and that is what is happening in the get
saving method so let me close this
method as well and that's all what is
defined inside the option menu class
so we ask the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
get login method
then based on
that we provide
the customer the options to choose the
account type whether they can choose the
savings account or the checking account
and based on that whatever account type
they use
we call the get checking or get saving
method and inside this method we provide
the customer the other options to either
withdraw the money deposit the money or
view the balance
that is what is happening inside this
option menu class
now let's go to the account class and
all the methods which we saw here will
be provided a definition in the account
class
you also see this option menu is
extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now
so this is the account class where i
have defined some private member
variables like customer number so now
you will be familiar with the customer
number pin number which i just described
and also with the checking balance and
the savings balance
you can also divide this account class
into two child classes where you have a
savings account class and a checking
account class
but for simplicity i've kept it to one
class
i'm initializing a scanner input which
will be used at multiple places and then
i have the setters and getters for these
four
member variables so you see set customer
number get customer number
if you remember this set customer number
was called in the option menu class if i
go back to the get login
once we ask the customer to enter the
customer number
we call the set customer number
which gets called here
similarly
we call the set pin number
which gets called
here similarly once we have said that we
then we were fetching the values using
the get customer number and the get pin
number
and that has that is also defined here
in terms of the getters
get pin number and get customer number
similarly we also have the getters for
the checking balance and the saving
balance
member variables
we do not have the setters for them
because they are not technically setters
but we have to calculate the balance
it's not a simple setter where you can
just return the value
so now let's look at some of the
business functions of the account class
how do you deposit how do you view the
balance how do you withdraw the balance
etc
so you see these two methods
which are specifically when the customer
is trying to withdraw the money from
their account
and these methods are basically called
internally by other methods so we will
come to that let's just understand that
we have two methods for calculating the
withdrawable amount or executing the
withdrawal transaction
for the checking account account and the
savings account
similarly i have two more methods here
which are calculating the depositing for
the checking account and calculating the
depositing for the savings account
and then we get the the bigger methods
which are using these calculation
methods so i define four calculation
methods so far
calc checking withdraw calc saving
withdraw
calc checking deposit and calc saving
deposit basically withdrawing and
deposit for both of the classes
and then we have these business
functions called get checking withdraw
input
and get saving withdraw input
get checking deposit input and get
saving deposit input
so these getter methods are something
which were being called from the option
menu class if you remember
if you go back to the option menu class
and if you chose the checking account
you get these options and let's say you
chose option 2 which was withdraw funds
or option 3 which was deposit funds
then the corresponding methods which
were being called were get checking
withdraw input
and get checking deposit input
and this is the exact same method gets
checking withdraw input
and
get checking deposit input
so if you see what is happening inside
this particular method is couple of
sysouts
then we
take the scanner input amount and we
convert that amount to the double
after that we check
if the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw is smaller than the checking
balance or not and i'm running this
condition to check that if the amount is
smaller than the checking balance
then we call the calc checking withdraw
method
which was defined right here
remember i told you that these four calc
methods will be used and this is how
they are used so here i'm actually
subtracting the value so whatever amount
the customer wants to withdraw
subtract that from the main balance and
then return the new main balance
that's what you do right if you have
thousand rupees and if you want to
withdraw 500 you subtract 500 from
thousand and then you send back the
remaining balance
so that is what is happening when we
call this method and then we print the
new checking account balance
that is what is happening in the get
checking withdraw input method
similarly if you chose option 3 which
was
depositing funds to the checking account
then get checking deposit input gets
called
and it is defined right here get
checking deposit input and here instead
of subtraction
we are doing the addition
so here i'm again doing a condition
check that the current balance plus the
new amount which has been supplied by
the customer from the command line
the total sum of it should be greater
than zero
what if the customer entered an amount
minus 5000 i should not allow that
so that's
the reason i'm putting this condition in
place and if
the current balance plus the new amount
which is supposed to be deposited to the
account the sum of it is greater than
zero then call the calc checking deposit
method
and this is where the calc checking
deposit method is present and where i'm
just doing present balance plus the new
amount and returning the new balance
that's all which is being done here
and you will see exactly similar logic
running for the
savings account as well
if you look at the get saving withdraw
input which is used to withdraw money
from the savings account so i take the
input from the command line and i run a
condition check that the amount which
the customer wants to withdraw should be
less than the current saving accounts
balance
if yes then call calc saving withdraw
method
which is defined here whereby subtract
the amount from the current balance and
i return the new balance
and similarly you will see the exact
same functionality in the get saving
deposit where we add the money instead
of subtracting the money
and this is all what is defined in the
account class
so we talked about the option menu class
we talked about the account class and
now we have the atm class which is the
entry point which basically initializes
the option menu class and calls the get
login method
remember get login was the first method
which asked you to provide the customer
number and then get login called the
method to choose the account type and
the account type methods then called the
method to choose the option to withdraw
deposit or exit
so now we have built a fair
understanding of what is happening in
this application so let's run this
application
so i just ran this application and let
me bring the console here
it's first asking for a customer number
so i will go to the option menu class
and i will
pick up one of the customer number which
i have hard coded here
so i will provide that customer number
and hit enter
then it asks me for the pin number
so remember you have to provide the
correct pin number corresponding to the
customer number
so i'm taking this pin number just
copying it and pasting it here
then
this whole code got executed
and then it called the get account type
and the get account type method provided
you with these options which you see
here on the screen so based on what you
select the case block will get executed
and let's say i want to go for a
checking account so i press 1
and i hit enter
once you select the checking account the
case 1 gets selected and it calls the
get checking method
and the get checking method again
provides you with another menu view
withdraw or deposit or exit
so let's say i want to deposit funds so
i press 3
and hit enter
it says the current balance is 0
and enter the amount you want to deposit
let's say i want to deposit 500
and i hit enter
you get the message saying the new
checking account balance is 500 and you
have successfully deposited the money
and that is what i did for the checking
account
now let's try to withdraw something from
the ticking account so you again get
back the same option because inside the
get checking method
we call the once we have successfully
done the business operation we again
call the
account type method to display the menu
again to the user
so let's say again select the checking
account class
and this time i want to withdraw the
funds
remember i've added 500 there
so let's say i want to withdraw so i
choose the option 2 as the choice
current balance is 500 and it's asking
me the amount you want to withdraw from
the checking account
so i enter let's say 100 and i hit enter
when i do that the new checking account
balance becomes 400 so the 100 got
subtracted from the 500 and the new
balance is shown to your screen
you can do exactly the same thing for
for the savings account as well
and let's also run a negative condition
so i again select the checking account
and i want to withdraw the funds i
choose the option two
current balance is 400 and i i would
like to withdraw a thousand
what happens
if you do that we get a message saying
balance cannot be negative and this is
coming from the calc checking method
which which is defined here so what is
happening that i wanted to withdraw the
funds from the checking account
and here get checking withdraw
input.called
here
this condition was checked
so the checking balance was
400
and the amount i wanted to withdraw was
thousand so 400 minus thousand is not
greater than equal to zero so it jumped
into the else block and it said balance
cannot be negative
so this is how you can also build some
error conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have lot
of bugs
we can also exit the application so if
you just type three
and hit enter
you will exit from the application and
will again call the login method where
it will again ask you to enter the
customer number
so this is how you can run this
application and this is this was a
simple use case for you to show how you
can use the different object-oriented
concepts like classes objects methods
setters getters switch case etc to build
the application with the correct
business logic
and this is all i want to cover in this
particular session
and in the next session we are going to
have a look at another interesting core
java project just to build our
understanding more better about the core
java concept choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scaleup by simplylearn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's get started with walking through a
core java project using all the
different oops concept we have learned
so far
so in this example we are going to have
a look at a calculator application and
this calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open
domain class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user
so we initialize the scanner class and
we start taking the inputs and whatever
the user inputs in terms of the
expression let's say the user entered 4
plus 5 or whatever
that whole expression gets sent back
into this
input line
as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression
the next thing we do is divide the input
expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say
let's say the user entered this
expression so this has either numbers
or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the numbers and operators into two
different string arrays
and here i'm providing the split
expression that split at every time you
encounter one of these symbols so this
when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4
5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i have created this string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i'm going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this linked list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this linked list as a
queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now and then i am
using the poll method
if you remember the poll method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the whole
method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable
and after that i run a loop on the
numbers q
and i'm going to run this
particular loop till this particular
queue
is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers q
till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do the exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations
like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it
so in this case plus will be picked up
and will be stored in this variable
called opr
and then i am going to run a switch case
on this opr basically as i told you in
this particular calculator application
we are supporting four operations which
are addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors for
multiplication i have a class called
multiply and for division i have a class
called
divide let's have a look at what these
classes are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results which
is accepting a variable argument array
if you remember i told you that you can
also use a
array this is called a arg expression
this means that this numbers will be an
array of arbitrary length it can be a
one element array it can be a two
element array it can be a four element
array or whatever you supply but it is
still going to be a fixed length array
but the length is going to be dependent
upon how much argument you supply to
this particular method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it just has one method declared
which is called get result which is
accepting an array of numbers so
if the add class is implementing the
operator interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and the exact same kind of logic or
similar logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class
it is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one
so it's doing pretty much the same thing
in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning
the object type to this interface
reference so i'm using the concept of
dynamic binding which we talked about
when we talked about interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can assign an object to an
interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue
remember we already did one pole here
so
as per this example 4 was here in this
res
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue
so we pick up 5 here
and then we call
operate dot get result now this get
result will be called based on the
expression which was encountered first
in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus so
the expression was plus so the operator
type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum four and five
this rest is holding four right now
based on what i described here numbers
dot poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically
basically 5 here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number q is now empty no
it is still not empty because we still
have 3 n2
left there
so
again it does the operations dot pole
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll
and this time the numbers.poll is going
to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9
4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate.getresult
the multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3
which will become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls
the queue of the operations
where the expression divide is present
there which is the only element left in
this particular operations queue and
since we have the opr value as divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers dot poll
now the last number which is available
in this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate.getresult
this times is the operate object refer
object operate reference type was of
divide class type so when we call
operate.getresult
the divide operation or the getresult
method of the divide class
basically this method will get invoked
and it will divide the current value of
result which was
4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27
so it is going to divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers.poll it is going to execute 27
by 2 and whatever value it gets it is
going to store a value back into the
rest variable and then it is again going
to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers queue is
not empty but now the numbers queue is
empty because 2 was the last element so
it is going to come out of the loop and
it is going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now let's try to see this in action and
we'll try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star
3
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step we
pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator
and whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then we
fetch the next value in the numbers q
and then we call the get result based on
the expression
and whatever result we get from the get
result we store it back into the rest
variable so we keep updating the rest
variable at every step that's the reason
the result of 4 plus 5 gets stored in
the rest and next time you are calling
the get result for a multiply operation
here the rest value is 9 now and it says
9 into 3. again in the next time the
rest value will be updated to 27 because
we are storing the result back into the
result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc
also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etcetera
which is not here but this is just to
show you the basic idea of how you can
build simple to complex cli applications
using the core java concepts
so why kotlin
kotlin is one of the fastest growing and
widely used programming language
in may 2017 google announced it as an
official language for developing android
applications
after this announcement the jobs for
kotlin increased in large numbers
since then the job openings for kotlin
gets doubled every three months as per
dice
it is very easy and friendly language
also it is quite easy to maintain and
debug this language
which is why it is a good language to
start with
kotlin has a bright future as it is
being widely used for android
development companies like google
netflix pinterest are some of the
companies using kotlin
so being a kotlin developer will boost
up your career growth
now coming to what is kotlin
kotlin is an open source statically
typed language designed by jetbrains
it has both the features of object
oriented programming and functional
programming kotlin is interoperable with
java that means both the languages can
share and use the information
and just like java compiler the kotlin
compiler also generates the byte code
which can run on jvm
also we can say kotlin is kind of java
with some added features
even the java libraries can also be used
in kotlin project
although java is a really cool language
the developers of kotlin focused
more on simplifying the code and
increasing the transparency
now let's learn some history of the
scotland language
the development of the kotlin language
was announced in the year 2011.
in 2012 the first web demo of kotlin was
released along with the new logo and
became an open source
then in 2014
kotlin lang.org was released along with
some features to increase the
interoperability with java
in the year 2015 some new features were
added like the companion objects
multiple constructor etc
after a quite long development process
kotlin 1.0 version was released in
february 2016.
it was developed by jetbrains in russia
the developers of jetbrains were fed up
with the repetitive code so they wanted
a much modern language
but the problem was most of their code
was already written in java and
switching to some other language would
create a bigger headache for them
so the team decided to create a language
which is compatible with java and with
all the features they wanted
so then they created the kotlin language
in the year 2017 google announced the
first class support for kotlin on
android
later kotlin 1.2 was released with
features like sharing code between jvm
and javascript
after that
various versions were released like
kotlin 1.3 in 2018
kotlin 1.4 in 2020
kotlin 1.5 in 2021 etc
now
moving on to features of kotlin language
the first feature is
kotlin language can be used on multiple
platforms which reduces the time that is
spent on writing and maintaining the
code on different platforms
kotlin doesn't depend on virtual machine
on the target platform
next is kotlin has some modern features
like null safety which is a feature to
reduce the problems associated with the
null references
then the lambda function which is an
anonymous function
and the smart casts which are used to
track conditions inside the expression
next is
in kotlin language there are many
extensions
which allows us to add the functionality
without inheriting from the class or any
decorative pattern
this feature makes the code easy to
maintain and read
now coming to another feature of kotlin
which is
in kotlin functions can be passed as
parameters to the function
that means function act as a variable
and just like the variable it can also
be passed it is also known as higher
order function its functionality is to
do two things
first to take the functions as
parameters and second to return a
function
next feature is kotlin is compatible
with java
it is fully interoperable with java and
you can convert the java file to the
kotlin file with just a script
also it works on jvm and java libraries
work fine on kotlin
next is
in kotlin there is a data class
a data class is that class which doesn't
perform any operation
and only contains state
the advantage of this class is that it
provides self-generated code and avoids
the implementation of methods within the
class
now
coming to uses of kotlin
kotlin is used in web development it is
compatible with java and also
much easier to work with
also kotlin works fine with spring and
some other frameworks
which makes it an easy replacement of
java
when it comes to web development
next is
kotlin is used in data science as well
because of its features like null safety
statically typed maintainable code and
also being a language which runs on jvm
makes kotlin a good choice for working
with the data
next is it is used for android
development
after google has announced kotlin as the
first class language the user's interest
in kotlin language elevated to a great
extent which resulted in creating a
large community of android developers
going for kotlin
this language allows the developers to
write more expressive and concise code
and its interoperability with java is
one of the main attraction to choose
this language
with google statement not only the
android developers but also the app
development companies are opting the
kotlin language
similar to these uses there are many
more uses to the cotton language
but now let's move on to its
applications
so we'll start with google
google widely uses the kotlin language
not only they have declared it as the
first class programming
but they also use it in their production
code
google also implemented kotlin in more
than 60 applications
such as google home
google maps google drive google pay
google sheets etc
similarly airbnb which is an american
company that operates online marketplace
for lodging and home stays to vacation
rentals also uses kotlin language for
their android frameworks
mvrx
for a seamless experience
other companies like zometo which is
india's largest food delivery company
also uses kotlin for the android app
which has helped them to reduce the
lines of code and made the code a lot
more concise
next is netflix
netflix is world's leading streaming
service also use the kotlin language to
rebuild their ui player for the android
app of netflix
next is uber
the american mobility company uber that
provides services like food delivery
ride-hailing package delivery couriers
etc uses kotlin language because of its
popularity for android development and
its interoperability with java
so these were some popular companies
that uses the kotlin language
similar to these companies there are
many more companies like pinterest
tinder slack etc that uses this language
now let's have a look at what we have
learnt so far
in this video we spoke about why kotlin
language what exactly kotlin is then
history of kotlin language and some of
the features and uses of kotlin language
and at last we have covered the
companies that uses cotton language
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know
more kotlin is a general purpose
statically typed programming language
developed and released by jetbrains in
2016.
in 2011 jetbrains revealed the kotlin
project which is a new language for jvm
and later in february 2016 its first
version kotlin 1.0 was released
this language is concise and more
expressive than java
it is fully interoperable with java and
it is also said that kotlin language is
made by extracting all the good parts of
different programming languages like
scala javascript java c-sharp etc
google also announced kotlin as the
first class language for android
development
so it is now an official language for
the development of android and is being
opted by many organizations across the
globe
now let's move on to our next topic
which is variables in kotlin
there are two types of variables in
kotlin
which are
where and well
first where
the var variables are mutable
which means their value can be
reassigned
then there is val
the val variables are immutable which
means their value cannot be reassigned
or changed or modified
as you can see in the example where is
the type of the variable name and the
value raj is assigned to it
after that the value is reassigned as
said
so after printing it will display set
because where is mutable type and its
value can be reassigned
on the other hand
val is the variable whose value cannot
be reassigned
which means it is immutable
as we can see in the example on printing
the value of the name variable
it is showing an error because we tried
to change or reassign the value from raj
to sid
and because it is a val type variable
the value is not going to change
kotlin
is smart enough to understand which is
string and which is an integer
so it is not necessary to specify the
type
like in this example
name is the string and roll number is
the integer
but we haven't specified their type
and still there is no error however it
is possible to specify the type if you
want
now coming to next topic which is string
templates
a string can be defined as a collection
of characters enclosed in double quotes
the string templates allows us to
include the expressions variable
references inside the string
the references in a string start with
the dollar sign
to print the string
we need to add the dollar sign before
the string name
we can easily add the variables in the
string instead of concatenating them
for example here name 1 and name 2 are
two strings and we can include them
together
within the same sentence while printing
like both
dollar sign name one and dollar sign
name to our best friends
it will display the value of string
within the sentence
we can also print the expression like we
did while printing the second sentence
dot to upper case
dot upper case is an expression and in
kotlin expressions start with the dollar
sign
and are enclosed in the curly brackets
as you can see
so as we have understood about the
string templates
let's move on to if else and when
statements
if is used with a condition
if that condition is true
then the block of code executes and if
the condition is not true or false then
the else block executes
now in quarterly language the if-else
statements can also be used as
expressions that means they can return a
value
while using if-else as an expression it
is mandatory to use the else branch
here in the example we can see if a is
greater than b is the expression and the
value of that expression is assigned to
the variable named great
now which so ever is greater among them
that will be assigned to it and is then
printed
now coming to when statements
when statements in kotlin is similar to
switch statement in java
when statement is used to select one
code block from the multiple code blocks
based on a conditional expression the
code block which satisfy the condition
is executed
for example as you can see the value 4
is assigned to the variable tab
now whichever value matches with the
value of tab
that particular code block will execute
in this case there are no code blocks
but single line branches
the branch value that matches with the
value of tap
that particular branch will execute
like wrap will execute
which is then stored in the order
variable
which is then printed
now
let's move on to areas in kotlin
arrays are generally used to store
multiple values in contiguous memory
location in a single variable
in kotlin language to create an array
you have to use the address of function
and then
write the elements inside the bracket
for example here name is the array name
and sid robbie max john
are the elements of the array
in order to print the elements of the
array you can use loops
for example here we are using for loop
in this for loop n is the variable
names is the array name
and one by one it will print every
element of the array
now
as we have understood about arrays
now let's understand about loops
loops are used to iterate through the
different parts of program
for example arrays
ranges several times
it is a set of instructions which keeps
on repeating until a certain condition
is met
it is generally used while working with
arrays
in kotlin language the for loop is bit
different to that in java
in this for loop we use a variable in
operator and the array name to display
the elements of the array
for example as you can see in the
example there is an
array with elements 4 2 5 12 7 and using
the for loop we are displaying the
elements of the array inside the for
loop
here n is the variable
n is the operator and numbers is the
array name
loops are also used to iterate through
the ranges
which we will discuss later
now
let's understand why loop and do while
loop
both these loops are similar to the
loops in java
the function of the while loop
is it checks the condition and executes
through the block of code as long as the
specified condition is true
and the do while loop executes the do
block once before checking if the
condition is true
which means the loop will execute at
least once even if the condition is not
true
so as we have understood about loops in
kotlin so now let's move on to our next
topic which is null safety
so null safety is a feature in kotlin
language that solves the problem of null
pointer exception
if you have worked on other languages
including java then you must have an
idea of null pointer exception
in cotton language you can easily create
null type variable to create a null type
variable or string which can hold a null
value we can simply define them by
putting the question mark at the end
as you can see in the example
name is the variable name and string is
the type and after string there is a
question mark which means that this
variable is of null type
by default all the variables are not
null in kotlin
but you can create one by putting a
question mark with them
now moving on to the next topic which is
ranges
now ranges can be defined as an interval
from start to
end expressions are created with double
dot operator and an in operator here in
the example 0 is the starting point and
7 is the ending point in between them
there is operator double dot operator
which means that the loop will iterate
from 0 to 7.
similarly we can also print the range
with gaps like in the example
i in 0 to 10
step 2
means that it will print from 0 to 10
the gap of 2 digits like 0 2
4 6 8 10
range can also be used in decrement
manner for example i in 7 down to 2
means the loop will iterate from 7 to 2
in a decreasing order
now
let's move on to the next topic which is
kotlin functions
functions are also known as methods
they are the block of code which runs
whenever it is invoked
in kotlin language functions are defined
with the fun keyword
after that the name of the function and
paranthesis
are written
if the parentheses are empty it means
function doesn't accept any arguments
in function with parameters the
parameters are specified inside the
parenthesis
the type of parameter is specified after
the name of the parameter
we can see in the example fun is the
name of the function
num1 num2 are the parameters name
int is the type of the parameters
then after that the colon there is
another int data type
which is the return type that means it
is the data type of the value which is
returned
so these were some important topics of
cotton language
now let's go to the code editor
and do some practical implementations
so this is our intellij idea here we
will do some examples of cotton language
so let's go ahead
first of all we'll create the kotlin
file
so let's name it as example one
so first we'll do an example of string
template
in which we'll have a look
that how to create those strings and how
can we use some expressions with them
so let's start
so fun is the keyword for function
now main function
now inside this main function
we'll write
well
this is immutable as we know
code is the name of the variable
now let's say
code is
cipher
in kotlin language you don't need to put
the semicolon in the end as it is not
necessary you can do it but it is not
necessary to do that
all right now
after that let's say we want to print
this
we'll write
the code is
dollar sign
code so this is how we can print
this string
and let's see that if it works or not
first of all we'll have to save it
so we'll do save all
and now we'll go to run
now here we will
run run and select example one
all right
as you can see the code is cipher
it is getting printed
now let's say we want to use some
expression with it
right
the code is
let's say we want to write the code in
capital letters
right the code is
dollar sign and then the curly brackets
and inside the curly brackets we'll
write code
dot
upper case
yes
uppercase
now with
brackets
now after that
you want to put the semicolon it is your
choice otherwise it is not required
so now let's save it again
evolve and now
let's try to run it
as you can see the code is ciphered the
first one the code is in capital letters
cipher
so this is how we can do it and we can
also merge
the strings we don't need to concatenate
them
so we can do like this the code is this
and
it now let's try to run it again
so here what we are doing is we are
merging the uppercase and lowercase
here we can see the code is cipher and
cipher
so this is how we can
concatenate both the strings easily so
this is one of the example of string
template
now let's do another example of
if else statements as expressions
let's go ahead
right
now we'll create
main class fund main
and inside this main function
first of all we'll create two variables
that is marks one
of well type
and let's assign it value 87
then another variable marks2
and we'll assign it as
let's say 82.
here we are using if else as expressions
so what we'll do is
we'll make a variable result and we'll
store the value of if or else in that
particular result and then we'll display
that particular variable and let's say
that variable is
result
here we will use if else as expressions
so
val result equals
if
marks one
is greater than
marks two
then
in the bracket
right
marks one
equals this is for the printing purpose
dollar sign
marks one
is the greater
among both
let's write
is greater
then
marks two
variable marks
two
all right
now similarly we'll do four else as well
write else
now similarly we'll write
max2
equals
marks2 variable
is the
is greater
than
marks one
all right
so after that we'll print the variable
result because the result is getting
stored in this variable result
so whichever is greater will get stored
over here and then we will print this
variable
println
and we'll write
result all right
now it's done and i think we have
to run this one
save it and let's try to run
example 2
hope it works
as you can see
marks 187 is greater than marks 282
as
marks 1 is 87 and max 2 is 82
so marks one is greater so that is why
if block is getting printed
now
let's do an example of when statement
let's create a new file
go to new
this
kotlin file
now let's name it example
three
all right so this is example three
now let's start with the one example
function main
inside this will create a variable named
coupon so let's say the variable is
where
coupon and let's assign it a value
5
all right now
the when statement works as switch
statements
it is used to select one code block or
one code branch out of many code blocks
or code branches based on the
conditional expression
which so ever code branch matches with
the condition
that particular code branch will execute
all right so
let's start with it
we'll use when keyword
and let's say
open is the
name of the variable and the value of
coupon is 5 as we can see as we have
already declared that
now
inside when
the first branch would be so this is how
you can create a first branch
and if there are multiple lines then you
have to use the brackets
all right so here we will print
here is your
coffee
all right so first message is this
the second message would be like
forgot to d
yeah
so the second message let's say here is
your t we will write
so here is
your t
so in the third branch
we'll write
here is your green d
the fourth branch you will write here is
your juice
and in the fifth line or the fifth
branch
we will write here is your water
so
this is how we can create this we can
also create a default value
for that we have to use the else
statement
write else
right invalid
input
all right so this is how we are doing it
and so the value of coupon is five
and
which so our values among these like one
two three four five five obviously will
match it
that particular
statement or line will be printed
so let's save this one
and let's try to run it
so there's an error as you can see so
for that
we have to use the arrow operator
instead of these brackets
so let's do that
so now if any value other than these
five values is there in this variable
then this
default message will be printed that is
invalid input
so now let's save it
again
and now
run it
as you can see here is your water as the
value was 5.
let's say the value is six
it must show the invalid and input as
there is there are only five values
so now let's try to run this and let's
check
if it is working fine or not
as you can see invalid input
as we have entered six over here
which is not in this
one two three four five so that is why
it is printing invalid input
now let's do an example of array
let's create a new file
portal in file
now let's name it example
4
all right
now the main function
right now inside this function first of
all we will create an array
so how we will do that
well
let's say the name of the function is
arr1
equals
array
off
as we have discussed already array of
now the number of elements
like 2
4
6
8
12.
these are the elements of array1 now
similarly we will create an array2
write
array
array off
oh the elements
1
3
5 7
9 11.
all right now
now here we will use
a set function
so if we want to set a particular
element at a particular position then
we'll use set and if we want to display
a particular element of the array then
we'll use get so first of all we'll
understand set so
array1 dot
set
so first here we will write the position
let's say one is the position and at one
position we want to set 5 as an element
so this is the syntax for it
and let's say for array 2
array 2 dot set
now here we want to set at zeroth
position
and we want to set
two element
so first is the position and second is
the element
that we want to set at that position
all right now
[Music]
now we'll see the get
function
so
get is used to display the particular
element of an array
so let's say array1 dot get
let's say i want to print the fifth
element
that is 14th in array1 case
so i'll do this
similarly for
two
and in array two case i want to print
this
fourth element
that is nine
now
after that we'll use println
so that the result come out vertically
all right now if we want to print each
and every element of an array so this is
how
we can do it
for
element in
arr1 here element is the variable
array array1 is the name of the array
and one by one it will print
all the elements so here we will write
element
yeah it's done
let's save it now
and now let's run it
as we can see
fourteen and nine so as we know here we
have set
five at one position at first position
so zero one so in at place of 4 there is
5 now
and here at 0th position that is at 1
position there is 2
so first of all here we have
printed this get 5
so at array one position at fifth
position zero one two three four five
there is fourteen so that is why it is
preventing fourteen
in array two at fourth position there is
nine so here it is printing nine
after that
here we are printing all the elements of
the array so as we can see at the first
position we have set
5 instead of 4
here we are doing that so that is why
here we can see 2 5 not 4 then 6 8 12
14.
similarly as you can see at 0th position
in array 2 that is here we have set 2
so we can see
instead of 1 there is 2 3 5 7 9 and then
11.
so this is how we can
add some elements at a particular
position and print those elements and
print the array as well
so now let's do another example
right so we'll write function main
now inside this we will create an array
well arr1
now in kotlin
you can create an array having the
integer elements and character elements
or string elements as well in a same
array
so i'll show you that
array of
so first we'll write down the integer
elements let's say 2 4 6
and then
your string elements
let's say
8
and then 10.
so this is our array
within the same area there are integer
elements and string elements
all right
now using for loop
we will try to print this
element in
array1 dot
here dot indices means if we want to the
print the index of each of these
elements let's say if we just want to
print the elements so we'll not use this
we'll simply
print ln
and then we'll do is
array one
this is just for printing purpose
element
then
all right
so now let's save it
let's run it
as you can see
2 4 6 8 10 it is printing without any
error so we can easily do that
in kotlin
and these are the
indexes for the index if you want to
print the index of these elements we'll
do is
dot
indices
now let's save it again
and run it
as you can see array of one with zero
index zero one two three four
the index is correct but the elements
are not
so i think this yeah we forgot to write
array off
in the bracket
now
let's save it again
now let's again try to run this
a01
yeah
again let's try to run this
all right as you can see
array with index numbers will print 2 4
6
8 10.
so
not only the integer elements are
getting printed but also the string
elements are also getting printed along
with the index number
because of this dot indices we are also
able
to print the index of array elements
so these were some examples of kotlin
language you can try some more examples
on it the more you'll practice the more
you'll get to know about this language
conditionals in kotlin
conditional expression refers to a
situation that may happen or exist if a
specific condition is met
for example there's a statement like
we can sit on the front benches if we
reached before the given time now here
the conditional statement is
if we reached before the given time
and the main clause is we can sit on the
front benches
so here sitting on the front bench which
is a main clause is dependent on
if they reach before the time
so now
there are some conditionals in kotlin
like if else and else if
so let's have a look at that first is if
statement
if is used when a block of code must be
executed based on the condition to be
true
second is else statement
else is used when a block of code must
be executed if the same condition is
false
third is else if statement
else if is used to specify a new
condition if the previous condition is
false
we will understand them in detail
now moving on to different types of if
else expressions
first is if expression second is if else
expression third is
if else if letter expression and fourth
is nested if expression
now
let's understand the if expression first
if expression is a conditional statement
which checks if a particular condition
is satisfied
the condition is specified inside the if
brackets and it checks if it met the
condition or not
if they met the condition then the block
will execute otherwise not
as we can see there's a statement then
there is if condition
if the condition is satisfied that is if
it is true
then only the if code will execute
otherwise
if
it is false then control will exit
now moving on to if else expression
the if else expression has two blocks of
statements the if block executes if the
condition is true and if the condition
is false then the else block executes
the if else is similar to if expression
the only difference is
it has one extra block known as else
block
a simple example of if else is a
conversation between a father and a son
the father says
if you scored more than 85 percent then
i will buy you a car
but if you scored between 75 to 85
percent then i will buy you a bike
here i will buy you a car is the code
written inside the if block
and i will buy you a bike
is a code written inside the else block
so when
the son
scores 85 percent then his father
buy him a car
but if he scores between 75-25 percent
range then he will get the bike
now
moving on to if else if ladder
expression
kotlin if else if condition is used when
there are multiple conditions to be
checked
in this expression first the if
expression is checked if it's true
then it executes the if block otherwise
it moves to the other else if conditions
if none of the condition turns out to be
true then it executes the last final
else expression
to understand it let's have a look at
this example
according to this example if a student
scores marks between 80 and 105
then the cutoff is not cleared but he or
she can sit for the second examination
if the marks code is between 105 and 130
then the cutoff is cleared
if the marks scored between 130 and 180
then the cutoff is cleared and also
there will be no feed
and else cut off not cleared
so by this example we understood
that there are multiple conditions
and each condition has a specific
criteria
if the marks of the student is fit in
that criteria then that specific block
gets executed
now
moving on to the nested if expression
in kotlin nested if expression there are
if statements inside another if
statement
first the if statement is checked
if it is true then the nested if
condition is checked
if the conditions turns out to be false
then it will move to the else expression
in this example it checks for true in
condition 1
then checks for true in condition 2
if condition 2 evaluates to true
statement 1 that is even number is
executed
otherwise statement 2 that is odd number
is executed
similarly if condition 1 evaluates to
false
then else block executes and the
statements
negative number is printed
so as we have understood all of these
expressions
so now let's do its practical
implementation
so this is our code editor
that is intellij idea so here we will be
doing some examples of kotlin if else so
let's start with the first example of if
else expression
so we'll write
function main
and inside this function we'll create
a
marks let's say the marks of the test
so we have named it test marks
now
let's say
he scored 78 he or she scored 78 now
we'll use if condition
and we'll write the condition
that if text marks
is let's say less than 75
then we will print you didn't qualify
the test
so we'll write
dn
qualified the test
so basically to qualify a test you have
to score more than 75
so in else block
will write
print ln
will write you qualified the test
basically
if you have scored less than 75 marks
you are not qualified but if you have
scored more than 75
then you have qualified the test
here we have used the basic if else
expression
here the test marks is the variable
that we have set let's say 78
and if we have changed it like
less than 75 let's say 70 then it will
get printed you didn't qualify the test
but as we have
set the value of test marks as 78
so it means
you qualified the test will print
it's a simple example let's try to run
this
so as you can see you qualified the test
is printed
so as we know that the marks is 78 so it
is printing you qualify the test
and if you have let's say
marks is 17 now again let's try to print
it
now it will print
you didn't qualify the test
as you can see it is printing you didn't
qualify the test
now
let's have a look at an example of
nested if
so now create a new file
here we have to change the name of this
file
all right
so in this example again we'll write
function main
inside this function we'll create a
variable
let's say the name of the variable is
num
and we'll assign it 50
now we'll set a condition if the value
of num
is let's say less than 100
then we'll print
number is less than 100 first of all
we'll print that
now if num
is equal to 50
so this is the if condition inside the
first if condition this is the first if
condition this is the if condition
inside this if condition so it's a
nested if
now here we'll print
that
number equal to 50.
now inside this if condition again we'll
write an if condition saying that if
number is let's say greater than
40
then we'll print number is greater than
40.
basically we are printing
the condition
all right so this is the
code
now
first if condition then there is nested
if condition then there is another
nested if condition first condition says
if the number is less than 100 then it
will print number is less than 100 if it
is equal to 50 then it will print number
equal to 50 if it is greater than 40
then it will print the number is greater
than 40.
so now let's try to run this program
so as we can see number is less than 100
first it is printing after that number
equal to 50
then the number is greater than 40.
so as we know the number is 50 that is
why all the three
statements are printed
now let's say if we change this number
like let's say the number is 45
if the number is 45 then number is less
than 100 is printed
and this sentence that is the number is
greater than 100 is printed and not
number equal to 50 because to print this
number equal to 50 sentence the number
must be equal to 50.
now let's try to run this again
so as you can see number is less than
100 is only getting printed because as
we can see here
to
get inside this if condition the number
must be 50
as the number is not 50 but 45 so it is
not getting inside this if condition
so that is why this condition is also
not getting checked so that is why only
number is less than 100 is getting
printed
so this is an example of nested if
expression now let's do an example of
if else if letter expression
let's name it if else three
all right so now
here we will do an example of if else if
ladder expression where we will
give grades to the student based on
their marks
so let's start
function main
inside this we'll create a variable
let's say val score
and assign it a value
so this value is the marks of the score
or you can say
score is 76
now
we'll create a variable
whose type is
string
now
after that
we'll have to assign this grade
so basically we are assigning the value
of f lc flat expression to this variable
grade
so this is how we do it if
score variable
is greater than equal to 90
that is if the score is greater than 90
then we'll simply print your grade is a
plus
so yeah
we will do it
it is a plus
now
if a student scores more than 90 then
his grade is a plus
now
he will write
else if
so inside the elsif there is a condition
we can write the condition inside the
else if as we know
4 is greater than equal to let's say
80
then we'll print
your grade is a plus
your grade is a not a plus
now after that
another else if
if the score is greater than equal to
70.
then the grade
is we'll write your grade
is
b plus
let's see if the score is greater than
60 similarly
write your grade is
e
you can do same for all of these we can
just copy paste it
this one is 60 then let's make here 50
and the grade would be
c
e plus
now here would be let's say 40.
we'll do it 40 and the gate would be
c
now after that 35
let's make it 35
your grade is
sorry d
now
in else block will simply write
that is your grade is f that is if you
scored below 35
your grade is f that is your fail
so you must score more than 35 to pass
the exam
all right now after that we can print
this great variable
and let's try to run this
so as you can see your grade is b plus
it's getting printed and i think
by mistake
there is n in between
here it is
that is why it is printing in here so
our score was 76 so that is why it is
again taking printed your grade is b
plus
so this expression is used when there is
a need of multiple conditions
like in this case we have
we had the need of multiple expressions
like
one condition score must be greater than
90 then only the score will be a plus
then score must be greater than 70 score
must be greater than 60 similarly for
every statement that is to be printed
there must be a specific condition and
in this type of case we use if else if
letter expression
so these were few examples of if-else
expressions
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
are used to repeatedly execute a series
of statements until a certain condition
is met
typically a process is carried out such
as retrieving and altering data
and then a condition is verified such as
whether a counter has reached a
specified value
if it hasn't the next instruction in the
sequence is a command to go back to the
first instruction in the sequence and
repeat it
so until a specified or given condition
is true or the loop is broken with the
break statement
a series of statements are going to
execute
there are various types of loops in
kotlin like for loops for each loop for
loop with ranges
while loop and do while loop
so let's go ahead and understand these
loops
now we'll start with for loop in kotlin
a for loop is a conditional iterative
statement that checks for a specific
condition
and then
constantly executes a block of code as
long as those criterias are met
the for loop differs from other looping
statements in that it provides an
explicit loop counter that allows the
loop's body to know the exact sequence
of each iteration
the for loop is used in kotlin to
traverse over ranges arrays and maps
as we can see in the diagram first there
is an initial statement then there is a
condition and if that condition
evaluates to be true then the statement
inside the loop body are executed and
updated the updation can be incremental
or decremental then again the condition
is checked if it's true then the same
process will get repeated and if the
condition is not satisfied then the
control jumps out of the loop
this complete process will keep on
repeating until the condition evaluates
to be false
now
let's understand for loop with the help
of an example
so this is our code editor intellij idea
here we will be doing an example of for
loop
in which we will print the odd and even
elements from an array
so here we will use a for loop and if
else condition
so let's start
first of all we'll
make the main function
function mean
inside this function
let's declare an array
val num
num is the name of the array and the
array of function
inside this
we'll mention the elements of the array
let's say 7
21
then let's say 23
these are the elements of the array
now after this we will simply
print a message let's say
like the odd and even numbers in the
list are as follows and then we will
apply the logic
right
the
odd
numbers
are as follows
right
now we'll use for loop
now inside this
for loop item will be the name of the
variable that will store the
variables or
elements of the num array one by one so
num is the name of the array and in
between there will be inoperator
so one by one each element of the array
will be stored in item and now
we'll use
if condition
now we have to print even an odd numbers
the logic is simple we'll write if item
percent sign
divided by two
if the
remainder is equals to 0
then it means it is an even number so
any even number on when it is divided by
2 it will give 0 as a remainder
so
if it will give 0 as the remainder then
we will print
even number
then here we'll write item
that particular element will be printed
all right now in else block
we'll do
println
and here we will write
odd number
here again we'll write
plus
item
so all right
i think our code is done
and
we can
run it
let's try to run this one
so as we can see even numbers and odd
numbers are getting printed
so 16 is an even number 2 is an even
number
all numbers 11 17
28 even number or number 39 and even
number 10.
so i think all the elements are getting
covered
here we go 721 odd number
so yeah so this is how you can use for
loop and here we also have used if and
else statements
now let's understand
for each loop
for each method in kotlin allows you to
access elements in a collection or list
and perform actions on them
we can achieve the same thing using the
for loop but several for loops would
quickly make your code unreadable
as we can see in this example there is a
list name my list
and like in arrays we use array of
function similarly in list we use list
of function
the elements of the list are in winter
is and coming so there are three
elements first is winter then is then
coming
so to print each element of the list we
will use for each loop
as we can see here we have used my list
dot for each
that is the for each loop and then we
will print the iterator to print all the
elements of the array
now let's do an example on for each loop
to understand it better
so again we are back in our code editor
here we will be doing an example of
for each loop
so this example would be a simple
example function main
and inside this function
we will create a list
let's say
where
a list let's name it a list
okay so
after that
we'll use list of function
and
also let's mention the
data type
all right so now inside this
list we will mention the elements let's
say 110 and
265 and let's say 315.
so these are random elements
all right now we will have to create a
variable sum and initialize it with zero
now using this list b
sorry a list
that is the name of the list will use a
for each loop to iterate through each
element of of the list we'll use for
each
e must be capital
after that
right for each
and now we will use
this
sum variable
to do a simple
sum of each element of the list
sum plus
here i t so i t will be storing each
element one by one it will some with the
help of sum it will add each element to
one another
so initially sum is 0 when 110 is added
then 265 is added to 110 then 3152 added
to both of them
so all right now all we need to do is to
print this we'll write print talents sum
so here we go now i think we can
try to run this one
although it is showing an error but
let's try to run this
as i thought
i think we have to write the correct way
only
this is
the right syntax of
for each loop and
yeah so now let's try to run it
so as you can see 690 is getting printed
so we have to use for each bracket with
for each
only and we can't we can't enter put
space
with it so yeah so this is the syntax of
it
now let's move on to the next loop which
is for loop with ranges
range is a set of values that fall
within a specified lower and upper limit
and the values can be numbers characters
or objects
ranges might be incremental or
decremental
but the difference between two values is
always one
as we can see in the example inside the
for loop num in one two eight
here dot dot is the operator it means
all the numbers from one to eight range
will be printed
also we can use a step function to print
the elements with a gap
and we also have to mention the gap like
step 2.
there are more library functions that
build ranges that aren't covered by the
double dot operator
for example down 2 creates a range that
counts down
while range 2 creates a range that
advances to
a certain value now as we have
understood ranges now let's understand
while loop
while loops are used to repeatedly cycle
a block of code as long as the specified
condition returns true
the condition is verified first and if
it is true the blocks code is run
every time it enters the block the
condition is checked and as a result the
code will keep running until the
condition is met
once the loop starts the condition is
checked if that condition is satisfied
then the set of instructions are
executed and if the conditions are not
satisfied then the control jumps out of
the loop
this complete process will keep on
repeating and executing unless the
condition evaluates to be false
now let's understand while loop with the
help of an example
now here we will be doing an example of
while loop
so here we will use an array
and we will create elements of the array
like positive and negative
then using the while loop we will print
the positive numbers and the negative
numbers separately
so let's start
first of all we'll create the main
function
and inside this main function we'll
create an array let's say arr is the
name of the array
and here we are using the array off
function
inside this function we'll
write down the elements like 50 to any
random elements
minus 77 we have to write some
negative elements as well
minus 67 let's say and
minus 20
all right after that we'll
create a variable let's say i and assign
it to 0
initialize it with 0. so here we are
initializing it
now
within the while loop
we will write
i less than
ar dot size that the array size so it
means
this loop will keep on iterating
till the size of the array is greater
than zero
and when it becomes zero the loop will
break
or the control jumps out of the loop all
right
so
as we know i is 0 so that is why i less
than array.size we have used now in if
condition will write arrow i
greater than 0
that is positive number
if the element
here if the element is positive that is
greater than 0
then we'll print
positive number
right now here are
i
so that is how we will print it
now here we'll write else block
and inside the else block
again we will print
negative number
arr of i
okay so after that we have to
increment i plus plus
basically we have to we have to make the
loop to keep on iterating so that is why
we have used i plus plus for the
updation like to move to the next
element
in for loop we don't do the updation
part
like ourselves but in while loop we have
to do that
now let's try to run this
so here we go
50 to 10 positive numbers
minus 77 negative 82 is positive then
there are negative numbers
so here we have used the while loop
and it is
easy pretty much easy now
let's move to the next loop which is a
do while loop
the do while loop
the while loop and do while loop are
quite the same kind of loops
the only difference is that the function
is run at least once before the
condition is evaluated in the do while
loop
the while loop on the other hand checks
the condition before executing the
function
so as we can see in the diagram
the do while loop starts and the set of
instructions are executed
after that the while of condition is
checked
if it is true then again the set of
instructions or statement will execute
so basically in do while loop
the set of instruction will execute once
before checking the condition and after
that it will check for the condition to
be true
so we can say the set of instructions
will execute once even if the condition
is not met
let's understand do while loop with the
help of an example here we will do an
example of fibonacci series so fibonacci
series is the series in which the
sum of the
previous two elements is equal to the
third element
so let's start first of all we'll write
function main
now inside this we will create a
variable let's i this is a counter
variable so we'll start with 1
and now another variable let's say n
let's assign it 10
after that
we'll create a sum variable and sign it
0
then where
let's say f1
and make it 0
and where
f2 and we'll make it
1
all right
so we know in fibonacci sequence first
two elements are 0 and 1
all right so that is why we have
assigned f2 as 1
and we'll print
it now we have to do this example with
the help of do while loop so first of
all we'll write do
and inside this do
we'll write i plus plus that is we are
incrementing the counter
then
we'll print
f1 because
in
fibonacci series the first number is
always 0
write f1 we have assigned f1 as 0 so it
will get printed
now we'll write sum
equals
f1 plus f2 this is the logic
and after this we'll write f1 equals to
f2 that is we are assigning the value of
f2 to f1
and
f2 equals
sum
so here what we are doing is
for each iteration we are assigning
second number to the first number
and assigning the sum of the last two
numbers to the second number
so
fibonacci sequence works that way
0 1 1 that is the sum of the previous
two elements is the
third element like 0 plus 1 equals to 1
then 1 plus 1 equals to 2 then 2 plus 1
equals to 3 so that is how it goes on
now
after do block we'll use
while loop inside the while loop
will put a condition
that if i is less than equal to n
as we know the value of i is 1 on
increment it become 2 and the value of n
is 10
so the loop so this block will keep on
hydrating till
i becomes equal to 10
and as we know that i is now 2 after
this block executes which is less than
10 so again this block will execute
so it keeps on iterating till n become
till i becomes equal to 10
so it will print up to 10
that is 0 to 10 digits of fibonacci
series now let's try to run this one
as you can see
these are the fibonacci series 0 1 1 2 3
5 8 13 21 34 there are total 10
digits so as you can see 0 plus 1 equals
to 1
1 plus 2 equals to 3
then there is 3 plus 5 equals to 8
then there is
8 plus 13 equals to 21 13 plus 21 equals
to
34
so
this is our fibonacci series and we have
done it with the help of two while loop
so these were some examples of loops in
kotlin you can try some more examples on
it it will help you understand this
topic better
kotlin functions
functions in kotlin is very much similar
to functions in java
there are some minor differences in
between them
so let's have a look at them
a kotlin function can be defined as a
block of code which is used to hold the
data
this block of code has a name and is
defined with fun keyword
for example as you can see fun is the
keyword here and info here is the name
of the function
a cortland function divides the program
into small modules
these functions can easily be invoked by
making a call
and to make a call we use the name of
the function with parenthesis
as we can see in the example the
function info is getting invoked from
the main function
that is from the main function we are
making a call to the info function by
using the name of the function with
parentheses
now
let's understand function parameters
vectors can be defined as the
information that are passed to the
function
so basically functions can accept the
data or information passed to them
these informations and data are passed
in the form of parameters
after receiving the data or information
function can easily use this data to
calculate or display as per the function
definition
the parameters are specified after the
name of the function
and is mentioned inside parentheses
separated by commas
and we can easily pass as much
parameters as we want
for example as you can see
function calc
is accepting three parameters a b and c
of integer type
these three arguments or values are
passed from the main function where the
function call is made
so a b and c three arguments are passed
to the calc function and the function is
providing the average of these three
values
also the values that are passed to the
functions are called arguments and the
parameters are the values that are
defined in the function definition
so now let's understand the next topic
which is function returning values
just like printing the values functions
can also return values
to return a value or values a return
keyword is used
also
while returning a value the return type
of the function is also specified as you
can see in the example
int is the return type of the function
and return keyword is used to return
values to the main function where they
are getting printed
so now moving on to the functions with
no return types
bottling function with no return type
in kotlin language if the function is
not turning anything then we don't need
to specify any return type
but if we want to mention the return
type then we can add unit as the return
type
so basically unit type in kotlin is like
void type in java
that means it is used with function that
doesn't return anything
next is
higher order functions
the higher order function in kotlin is a
function that can accept the functions
as a parameter and can also return a
function
we have heard that function accept
variables but we haven't heard about
function accepting other functions
in higher order function we can easily
do that
so as we can see in the example of
higher order function
the name of the function is high order
and is accepting two integer values that
is num1 and num2 and a function whose
name is fname
now
this function fname is accepting two
integer values and its return type is
int
inside the function body we are calling
fname function and printing it
let's understand it with the help of an
example
so this is our kotlin playground
here we will do an example of higher
order function we will do a basic
example of higher order function so
let's start first of all we'll create
the main function function main
and inside this main function
let's name the higher order function as
high order
you can name it as per your choice i
have named it high order and now let's
pass the variables let's say 50
80 and
let's say 40.
now
we have to pass the function to this
higher order function
so
we can do that with the help of these
two column operators and then
the name of the function
let's say the name of the function is my
function
so here we are passing three variables
and a function to the higher order
function
now
we'll create the higher order function
we'll write one keyword
then
high
order
and now inside the paranthesis we'll
write num1
in the parameters that is 5080 40 we
have to
write the parameters
similarly num3
now after that
here we will
here we are accepting a function as well
so we'll write the name
let's say name of the function is func
name
and
here
int and
the type of
the values that this function will be
accepting
here also we have to mention the types
of the function that this function will
be accepting and the return type of the
function as well
so int is the return type of this
function
we'll have to mention that as well
and
by mistake we have done this we have to
use arrow operator for that
and yeah
now
we'll write the print basically will
call the function
in which
we will define the
definition of this function
so let's say the yeah the function name
was funct
name and these three are the parameters
num1
num2
and num3 we are passing these
arguments
now
let's create this
function definition
so we'll create fun
keyword
my function
function is accepting num1
of integer type
num2 of integer type
and
num3 of integer type
now after that
the return type of the function is int
all right
now let's say we want to do the average
of these three numbers
so what we'll do is we'll write return
num1
plus num2 plus num 3
divided by 3
all right so
all we need to do is just enclose it
within the brackets
yeah
now let's try to run this
as you can see
50 plus 40 90
90 and 80 is equals to 170
170 on
divided by when it is divided by 3 it
will give you 56.3
something and as we have used intj value
so it is showing 56 only
so
what we are doing here is first of all
we are calling the high order function
so basically this is a higher order
function and we have named it high order
and we are passing three integer values
and one function
so these three integer values are
passing over here and these are the
parameters and this is how we accept
function as a parameter
this is the syntax of it
after that we are here calling the
definition of this function
so this is the definition we are calling
this function and this is the definition
of this function the value is calculated
over here and then is returned here and
then here it is getting printed
so the answer or the output of this
program is
56
as you can see so this is a higher order
function
now
let's understand lambda function
lambda function
lambda is an abbreviated form of
function writing
the lambda function is written without a
name and is enclosed in curly brackets
the lambda function has the basic syntax
arguments or variables are mentioned on
the left hand side of the air operator
and the body of the function is present
on the right hand side of their operator
in the example
avg is the lambda variable
n1 n2 and n3 on the left side of the
arrow operator are the parameters and on
the right side is the function body that
is the average of three parameters
so as we have understood the lambda
functions and the higher order function
as well now let's understand how to use
higher order function with lambda
function
so lambda function allows us to
eliminate the code and write the code
more compactly
as we can see in this example we have
used the lambda function instead of the
normal function which has decreased the
lines of code
now
let's understand this with the help of
an example
so this is our example of higher order
function that we have done previously
now we will do this example or edit this
example
with lambda function
so now we'll understand how to use
higher order function and lambda
function together
and it will make our code shorter and
more compact
so as we can see this was the here we
have used two column operators with the
name of the function
now all we need to do
is to create a lambda function over here
and for that as we know that there is no
name for a lambda function the lambda
function is enclosed in two brackets
now let's say num1
and this is the parameters or the
variables
that is on the left hand side of the
arrow operator
then num2
3
after that
here we can see here we have used the
arrow operator now we have moved to the
right hand side of that operator which
is the function body
now we'll use the parentheses
num1
plus num2
plus num3 so basically this is the
function body or the function definition
we can say
so now here we have
we are doing the average of these c
numbers as we have done previously
in the higher order function
now here we don't have to use this
function
we can just eliminate this one
now as we can see our function is almost
done and let's try to run this program
as you can see the output is 56 so here
we have used the lambda function
so this part which is the left hand side
part
of the arrow operator this is the
variables or the values
and this part
on the right hand side is the function
body
so the lambda function is enclosed in
the
in two brackets as we can see here we
have positive three variables and this
is the lambda function
also we have eliminated the my function
function because in that particular
function we are just defining or doing
the
calculation
and that we have already done in this
part so we no longer need that function
so
as you can see this is
here we are using higher order function
with lambda function
so first is what is kotlin
multi-platform
the kotlin multi-platform is a feature
released in 2017 with kotlin 1.2 version
this feature allows us to write the same
code on multiple platforms directly
it focuses on cross-platform app
development
it is based on the idea of write one's
run anywhere approach
but it takes the concept of write once
run anywhere to a much higher level
in which we can write the code once and
target multiple platforms
the kotlin multi-platform
allows you to include other platforms
like linux windows and the web
while its subset that is kotlin
multi-platform mobile
allows the developer to write business
logic code for ios and android from a
single code base
now as we have understood what is caught
in multi-platform now let's understand
how kotlin multi-platform works
so let's take android and ios
the shared business logic code for
android gets converted to java bytecode
that can be executed in jvm
and android has the virtual machine
so it can easily run it
but in case of ios there is no virtual
machine
so the code is converted to the native
code that can be executed on ios
now in kotlin compiler there is a front
end which converts the code into
intermediate representation known as ir
and the back end converts that
intermediate representation to machine
executable code
so in case of android it converts it
into java byte code and for ios it
converts it into ios native machine code
so as we have understood how kotlin
multi-platform works now let's
understand
common kotlin code
to make common core clean code run
kotlin provides platform specific
compilers
to convert
the code according to different
platforms it provides different
compilers
these platform-specific versions include
kotlin slash jvm
kotlin slash javascript
and kotlin slash native
these versions contain
the platform-specific tools and
libraries and also the extension
to kotlin language
each platform specific version include
various platforms for example
jvm includes java 8
java 6 and android
then the javascript includes browser and
node
the native includes ios mac windows
linux etc
multi-platform libraries helps in
developing shared parts of the project
at one area by providing apis for common
cordline code and later
share it with all of the target
platforms
the versions of platform-specific
libraries provide the libraries that can
be used to increase the
platform-specific capabilities of the
platforms that are targeted
now
let's understand the benefits of kotlin
multi-programming
so let's start with the first one which
is
quick and clean code
in cortland multi-platform
we don't have to recreate and rewrite
the code for different platforms
we can simply share the common code
between platforms which saves a huge
amount of time
features like interoperability makes
things very easy and quick as well
also there is no lagging behind the
native platforms and because of that the
developers don't have to wait until the
new features are added for the support
next is
fast development
so as we have already discussed that
code sharing saves a lot of time
and helps in making the development
process much faster and easier
its features including null safety ide
support and interoperability with java
makes it less complex and fast
next is
one language for close platform and
native apps
most cross-platform app development
tools
don't allows you to use the capabilities
of native to ios and android devices
in kotlin we don't need to introduce any
new programming language to the code
base
it is easy to make our android app
work on ios devices without changing
much in code
the major advantage of using kotlin
multi-platform is that we can write the
code once and use it on both mobile
platforms that are android and ios
next is support and community
kotlin is pretty famous in many
companies and organizations
also after google statement of kotlin as
an official language for android
many companies are opting this language
and a huge amount of users
started working on this language
which means there is a huge community
support for the kotlin language
the developers who are already familiar
with java can easily switch to kotlin as
it is fully interoperable with it and
easy to learn so the java community also
adds up to the kotlins community
now let's have a look at some
applications that are built using kotlin
multi-platform
this includes netflix autodesk vmware
trello
philips
ice rock
so let's start with netflix
netflix the popular ott platform
has rebuilt the current user interface
player in the netflix android
application using kotlin
next is autodesk
autodesk is a multinational software
corporation
kotlin works well with ios and android
without any java native interface
which is a major reason for the company
to opt kotlin multi-platform
next is vmware
vmware is an american cloud computing
and virtualization technology company
the vmware development team
wanted a cross-platform strategy for
mobile applications
then the cotton multi platform was
selected
and now it is the default go to
framework of choice for vmware
next is trello
trello is a project management
application
the android application of trello is
built using kotlin
fellow uses scotland because of its
interoperability with
java
next is philips
philips is a popular multinational
corporation and we all have heard about
this company
in philips kotlin multi-platform proved
to be a faster at implementing the new
features and also to get more
interaction in the team between android
and ios developers
the last one is ice rock
xlock is an outsourced company that
provides mobile and backend solutions
for various industries and market
segments
it uses kotlin multi-platform mobile to
create applications for its clients
apart from these there are some more
applications and companies that have
opted the kotlin multi-platform
what are threads
to understand core routines in detail
first we will have to understand the
threads
so let's understand it a little
so the programs are just a set of
instructions
when a program runs a process is created
which contains memory process id etc
in that process there are threads
that are used to execute information
every process has at least one thread or
more than one thread
threads help with the high performance
applications and they work in a
sequential order one after the other
whenever a thread gets stuck while
running an instruction then the other
thread executes the rest of the
instructions
so these were threads
now as we have understood about threads
so let's learn about core routines
coroutines stands for cooperating
functions
the word co stands for cooperation and
routine stands for functions
the core routines can not only do all
the things that a thread can
but is also very efficient
coroutines are lightweight threads that
help to write simplified asynchronous
code that keeps the application
responsive while maintaining heavy tasks
like network calls
core routines are executed inside the
thread
and are also suspendable
here the word suspendable means we can
execute some instructions and then stop
the core routine in between the
execution and continue when we wish to
and they can also switch between the
threads which gives core routines and
edge over threads
so as we have understood about co
routines so now let's learn about some
features of core routine
so these are the features of kotlin co
routines
first one is
core routines are lightweight
due to the support for the suspension
we can run many core routines on a
single thread
which doesn't block the thread where the
core routine is running
core routine has a collection of threads
that can be used when required
when the task is done the thread is kept
back to the collection and reused when
need
so this was the first feature
now moving on to the second feature
which is less memory leaks
there are very less memory leaks in
kotlin
because of the structured concurrency
the kotlin core routines follow the
structured concurrency
this structured concurrency means the
new quarantine can only be launched in a
particular coroutine scope which sets
the lifetime of the core routine
during the implementation a large number
of core routines are launched and the
structured concurrency take care of
those
so that they are not lost or leaked
this was the second feature
next is built-in cancellation support
cancellation in coroutine is interactive
in order to be cancellable a core
routine must be cooperative
but
if it is not cooperative then it will
wait for the core routine to finish
there are two ways to make a core
routine cancellable
one
through using suspending functions
through cortland dot co routines like
delay function yield function etc
these were cancellable
and second using coroutine scope dot is
active boolean flag
there can be many reasons to cancel a co
co-routine and also a co-routine cannot
be cancelled if it is working in
computation
now moving on to the last feature that
is jetpack integration
there are many libraries of jetpack that
provide support for core routines for
example android ktx is a set of cortland
extensions that provide android platform
and other apis etc
the jetpack is basically a collection of
android development components that
helps in building android apps and
making complex things
simple and easy
these were some features of co-routine
now let's understand an example of co
routine
but before that we have to understand
some terms of co routines which are
launch delay and run blocking
first is launch
now launch is a co-routine builder
launches a new co-routine concurrently
that is without blocking the current
thread
it is automatically cancelled when the
resulting job is cancelled
and it doesn't return any result
now next is delay
delay is a suspending function
which is used to suspend a function for
a particular time and resumes it after
that time
it doesn't really block the underlying
thread but allows the other core
routines to run and use the underlying
thread
also it is a cancelable function
then there is run blocking
run blocking is a coroutine builder
again
it basically runs a new core routine and
blocks the current thread until its
completion
or in other words the thread that runs
in it gets blocked for the given
duration until all the code blocks
inside the brackets of run block
complete their execution
now
as you can see in this example
here the run blocking refer to the
thread that runs it
that is the main thread
it is the scope of the core routine
launch
here launch will launch a new core
routine concurrently
then there is delay
delay will suspend the core routine for
a selected time
here that selected time is 2 seconds
by default the time is in milliseconds
now here the word sam will be printed
after
my name is
because of the time delay for 2 seconds
on printing it
it will display my name is sam
let's take this example on kotlin
playground
here it is here we have written that
example here we can see there is a delay
of
2000 l that is 2 000 millisecond which
is equal to 2 seconds
so that is why my name is printed
earlier then sam is getting printed
let's run it and let's check the output
as you can see my name is sam is getting
printed because we have delayed this sam
for a like for like two seconds
and now we'll use delay here
okay
let's say three seconds
3000 milliseconds
which is equal to 3 seconds
so as you can see there's a delay of 2
seconds here is the delay of 3 seconds
now what will happen is
sam will print first after that my name
is printed
as you can see sam my name is
so
i want to show you that how this delay
function work
because here the delay is now three
seconds which is greater than two
seconds that is why my name is getting
printed later
now
moving on to the next topic which is
basics of co routine
so first is scope builder
the core routine scope is used to
declare your own scope
unlike run blocking it just suspends and
releases the threads underlined
it is used to set the scope for new core
routines
routine scope is responsible for
controlling the life cycle of a group of
core routines and their context
scopes wait for their associated
co-routines to complete before
completing themselves
the core routine builder is an extension
of coroutine scope
now next is explicit job
a job object is returned by launch co
routine builder
whose task is to explicitly wait for the
child quality completion
jobs acts as a handle to the core
routine in the queue
for every co routine that is created it
returns a job instance which identifies
the core routine uniquely and manages
its life cycle
then there is suspending functions
suspending functions are those functions
that can be paused and then continued
later
they can be used inside the coroutines
and can use other suspending functions
as well
they are used for long-running
operations and wait for it to complete
without blocking
the syntax of suspending functions is
same as that of the normal function
but with the addition of suspended
keyword
so these were some basics of coroutine
so what is kotlin jetpack compose
the jetpack compose is a modern user
interface development toolkit
it makes the app development process
easy and speeds it up
because of the jetpack compose you can
write less code as compared to the
current view building approach
which also leads to less potential bugs
it's changed the way developers create
user interface making it easier and
faster to write and more performant to
run
before the jetpack compose
xml layouts were used to make native
user interface
the jetpack compose is much better
advanced and easier than xml
with the help of
jetpack compose we can make a more
declarative user interface with less
code
so
as we have understood the kotlin jetpack
compose
so now let's have a look at why we need
or use the jetpack compose
so why jetpack compose
the jetpack compose is used because it
has huge benefits over the previous user
interface building system
first it accelerates the development
there are various features in compose
that helps in doing the task faster
for example previews
by making multiple previews we can save
a lot of time that we earlier wasted in
checking the user interface component in
different states
but with the help of multiple previews
we can easily do that
also the compose is compatible with
existing code
many libraries like kotlin co routines
view model etc work just fine with
compose
second is independent
the library of compose is not integrated
with any operating system
which means it is easy to add the new
features to the user interface
without changing the operating system
now next is intuitive
in compose the apis that are used is
intuitive and declarative
intuitive means easy to understand and
declarative means
all we need to do is to describe the
user interface and the rest will be
taken care of by compose
the components that are made with the
compose are not confined to a specific
activity
which makes the component easy to reuse
worth is powerful and feature loaded
compose is a powerful and feature loaded
that helps in making the app attractive
and user friendly you can make the app
as you desired with these animations
which are quite easy to implement
compose has the support for dark theme
material design animations etc which
makes things very easy for the
development
now
how does compose work
the word compose came from composite
which means the collection of objects
the composed jetpack
works on a composite design pattern
this pattern is used while dealing with
hierarchical data
like parent child relationship
so in compose
every view can contain
one or more child views within it
and the child views can further have sub
child views
unlike previous approaches where we
cannot introduce additional
functionalities in a view
now
as we have understood about this topic
now we will move on to the next topic
which is composable function
a composable function is just like any
other normal function of kotlin
but the only difference is
it is annoted by the composable sign
it helps in transforming the data to the
user interface hierarchy
all the functions with composable sign
indicate that this function is the
compose function and the sign tells the
compose compiler that this function is
intended to convert data into user
interface
and they can only be called from other
composable functions
the composable function doesn't return
any values like the coatland function
but instead
emit user interface elements to the
compose runtime system for rendering as
we can see in this example
composable annotation is used to make
the function message a composable
function
the element text is also a composable
function which comes from compose
library
with the preview annotation as we can
see
we are able to see how our ui that is
user interface is going to look like
the preview
are often written with composable
annotation
and multiple previews can be added to
the composable function having different
parameters
now
the output of this example would be
hello rahul
so now moving on to the next topic which
is layout
layout allows us to arrange the
components in such a way so that they
don't overlap each other
it basically arranges the components in
a proper manner otherwise they got
staggered over each other
it is one of the most important
component that helps in creating user
interface
it helps in alignment and arrangement
purposes for the user interface
a out is a compose function which allows
us to arrange elements in a row column
and box
so let's understand
here we can see in this example
there is a row keyword which means these
three words hello there mate that are
written inside the row function will be
arranged horizontally
the row function allows us to arrange
the elements in a horizontal manner
so hello there and mate will be arranged
horizontally
similarly the column function
lets you arrange the elements in a
vertical manner so in this case that is
in the case of column function
hello there meet will be arranged
vertically
so this was example of layout now moving
on to the next topic which is
box
in box layout the children
are stacked over each other by default
so we have to align them to put them in
different positions or proper positions
we use the align modifier to set the
position or alignment for children
elements
as we can see in this example we have
used a line modifier and we can also see
there is alignment dot top center and
alignment dot bottom center
these are the alignment options that are
applied to the child user interface
there are total nine alignment options
let's have a look at them
first three are
alignment.topstart
alignment.top and
alignment.top center
here
alignment.topstart will align the user
interface to the top left corner
top end will align at the top right
corner
and top center will align at top center
position
next three are alignment dot center
start alignment dot center end and
alignment dot center
here center start will align the user
interface to the mid left
corner
center end will align at mid right
corner and center will be aligned at the
mid center position in between center
start and center end
x3 are alignment dot bottom start
alignment dot bottom end and alignment
dot bottom center
here
bottom start will align the user
interface to the bottom left corner
bottom end will align at the bottom
right corner and bottom center will be
aligned at the bottom center position
that is in between bottom start and
bottom end
so these were the nine possible
alignments
now coming to material design
as the name suggests it helps to improve
the appearance using the material design
styling
there are three pillars of material
design which are color
typography shape
first is
color
by using values from wrapped theme you
can easily color wherever it is needed
inside the compose graphic package there
is a color class which is used by
jetpack compose
to define material design color system
color class is used
there are 13 attributes that can be used
and those are
primary primary variant secondary
secondary variant
background surface error
on primary own secondary on background
on surface on error
and is light
each of them having different means and
is used to color wherever it is needed
then there is typography
in the material theme there are material
typography styles which are used to
style or define a type system
with the help of typograph class we can
customize font style font weight font
family letter spacing text decoration
and many more attributes
third is shape
material design allows us to define
shape for small medium and large
components as well
just like typography we can easily
create shapes
now coming to
next topic which is list and animations
the list and animations are one of the
most important thing for building an app
we have already discussed row and column
earlier
here we will discuss about lazy
composibles
lazy composibles include lazy row and
lazy column
the lazy row makes a horizontal
scrolling list
and the lazy column makes the vertical
scrolling list
in this example lazy column is used
as we can see
here lazy columns is used
that is vertical scrolling list
and this is how we add elements or items
here we are adding a single item and
here we are adding multiple items
with items there is an integer 7
which means 7 items can be added
now
just like list
animations are also very important for a
smooth and attractive user experience
there are various apis that can give you
control and help with the animation
they are
animation visibility
it is used if you are animating
appearance and disappearance
then there is animation
it is used if you want to have fine
control over animation time
then there is crossfade
it is used to switch between composables
with a crossfade animation then there is
remember infinite transition
if the animation is state-based and
happens during composition and is
infinite then this is used
next is
update transition
it is used if you are animating multiple
values simultaneously
so these were some apis that can give
you control over the animations
today we will be discussing about
cortland interview questions the 30
questions that will be covered in this
video will help you summarize every
important concepts and serves as a
perfect programming resource for kotlin
interviews
so now let's get started with an
exciting video on kotlin interview
questions but before we begin make sure
to subscribe to our youtube channel and
press the bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
so now let's go ahead with our first
question which
is
name some of the features which are
there in kotlin but not in java
so some of the features which are there
in kotlin but not in java are null
safety feature operator overloading core
routines range expression and smartcasts
so these are some of the
features
that make kotlin better language than
java now coming to the second question
which is what is the difference between
where and well
both where and well are used for
declaration of variables however
where is a general variable that can be
assigned several times whereas val is a
final variable that is immutable and can
only be initialized once
now moving on to the third question
which is
what are the advantages of when over
switch in kotlin
in java the word switch is used whereas
in kotlin the word when is used
when is more compact and effective than
a regular switch
and it has
superior design than switch
ven can be used both an expression and a
statement but switch cannot be used as
both
it can be used as statement but it
cannot be used as expression now moving
on to our next question which is a
multiple choice question
which of the following are the types of
constructors in kotlin
so first is parameterized and constant
constructor
option b is primary constructor and
secondary constructor option c is
default and no argument constructor and
option d is none of the above so you can
take your time in figuring out the
correct option among these four options
because i am going to say its correct
option you can pause the video and take
your time
so our correct option is option b
primary constructor and secondary
constructor are the types of constructed
in kotlin
so option b is the correct option
now moving on to our next question that
is the fifth question which is
how to get the length of the string in
kotlin
so this is also a multiple choice
question our options are a
str.length of
option b
length str
option c
str dot length and option d
str dot length of with small o
so you can take your time in figuring
out what is the correct option
meanwhile
i am going to say the correct option
so a right or correct option is
option c
str.length
so if you want to
get the length of a string in kotlin you
can use str.length
now
moving on to the next question which is
which feature allows
removing the risk of occurrence of null
pointer exception
so it is an important question as well
so
there are four options first null risk
b null safety c null pointer and d all
of the above
it is a very important question
and
now the correct option
of
this question is
null safety
null safety allows us to remove the risk
of occurrence of null pointer exception
it is a very essential feature of kotlin
language
now
moving on to the seventh question which
is
what is null safety and nullible types
in kotlin
so null safety commonly referred to as
void safety ensures that no object
references have null or void values
whereas in kotlin nullable types are
references types
that are declared by appending a
question mark to the string this
question mark is what we add at the end
of the data type to make it as nullable
now
moving on to the eighth question which
is
what is higher order function in kotlin
a higher order function accepts one or
more function as arguments and returns a
function as output
it is not like any other function
the higher order functions are
frequently combined with lambda
expression to create code that is both
compact and powerful
instead of integer string or array as a
parameter to the function
we will pass anonymous function or
lambdas in higher order function
so basically we pass a function to other
function known as higher order function
now
moving on to the ninth question which is
what is elvis operator
the null safety attribute in kotlin
allows us to assign null values to the
variables
can use if else or the always operator
to see if a value has a null value
always operator returns the first
operand and if that operand is true
otherwise evaluates and returns the
other operand
now our next question is
why
is scotland interoperable with java
so this is our
tenth question
so kotlin is compatible with java
because it uses jvm byte code
jetbrains places a strong emphasis on
kotlin's interaction with existing java
code while building compatibility
the team ensures that kotlin can
interface with existing java code easily
and thoroughly
compiling it directly to bytecode speeds
up the compilation process and
eliminates the distinction between java
and kotlin on jvm
so this is the reason kotlin is
interoperable with java now coming on to
the 11th question which is
what are the range expressions
a range is a set of values defined by
their beginning and ending points
range expression in kotlin make it
easier to iterate over a set of values
to make a range in kotlin
use the range 2 and down 2 functions
we may also define a range of values by
using the double dots operator
as we can see in the example for
i in 1 double dot 10
this will print all the elements from 1
to 10
and for 10 in
down to 1
will print all the elements from 10 to 1
in descending order
the third one is which is
4
i in 1 double dot 10 step 2
this will print
elements with a gap
now step 2 means there's a gap
so it will print elements like 1
3
5 7 9 because we have used step 2 it
will use step 3 then it will give a gap
of 2
like 1
4 like that
so on
moving on to the 12th question which is
what do you understand by data class
so data classes are the classes that are
used to hold the data or information
these data classes were previously
exclusively used to generate java codes
but with the explicit implementation of
the higher and greater collection of
properties they are now important in
kotlin as well
functions like tostring and equals are
also combined with this language
now moving on to the 13th question which
is immutable variable
so this is a multiple choice question
and the options are a variable that are
changed that can be changed b a variable
that cannot change that is read only
c a variable used for string
interpolation
d none of the above
so
we have already talked about immutable
variable
and
you can pick the correct option
now i am gonna say the correct option
so the correct option is b a variable
that cannot be changed is called
immutable variable that is the variable
that cannot be changed
now
coming on to the 14th question which is
what are co-routines
it is a very important concept
so the letters co and routine stand for
cooperation and function respectively
a core routine is a coatland feature
that can perform everything a thread can
do
while still be incredibly efficient
a core routine is a lightweight code
that doesn't require any processor
background switching and doesn't map on
native threads
so this is co routines
now let's have a look at the 15th
question which is
difference between safe calls and null
check
safe call operator is used to determine
whether a variable's value is null or
not
if it is null
null will be returned otherwise the
requested value will be returned
on the other hand
when the value of the variable is null
you can use the null check operator to
throw a null pointer exception
so this is the difference between safe
call and null check
now
coming to the 16th question which is
what are init blocks in kotlin
initializer blocks that are invoked
after the primary constructor are known
as init blocks
one or more init blocks can be found in
a class file
and they will be run in order
in kotlin it is not feasible to do any
operations in the primary constructor
instead
you must utilize the init block
so this is the init blocks in kotlin
now our next question which is the 17th
question is
what are lambda's expression
so lambdas expression are anonymous
function
that can be handled as values
meaning they can be sent as arguments to
a function
returned or used in any other way that a
normal object can be used so it can be
returned and used in any other way like
a normal object can be used
so the lambda expression has no name and
is created and assigned as a separate
variable
it doesn't have any parameters and
returns no value in the function
so this is called lambda function it is
used with higher order functions
now coming to the next question which is
what is in line function
so in line functions tell the compiler
to include the entire body of the
function wherever it is called in the
code it is used to improve the
performance of higher order function as
well as the inline function call and
inform the compiler to copy parameters
and functions
to use an inline function all you have
to do is to add the inline keyword to
the beginning of the function definition
so this is
inline function
now coming to what is null safety
so null safety is a very important
feature
the type system of kotlin is designed to
eliminate the risk of null references in
code
the type system in kotlin distinguishes
between the reference that can and
cannot hold null
so here's an example of not null
reference which will show you compiler
error
so
this is the example string equals abc
after that
the other is the example of null
reference where we have used the
question mark as we have discussed
previously
so because to allow a variable to hold
null we have to declare a variable as
nullable string with question mark
so now our next question that is the
20th question is what is late in it so
late in it is an abbreviation for late
initialization
if you don't want to initialize a
variable in the constructor and instead
want to do it later and you can
guarantee the initialization before
using it
use the late init keyword to declare
that variable
it won't start allocating memory until
it's been initialized
now our 21st question is
what is the difference between const and
well
the const keyword is used to declare
properties that are immutable by nature
that is the properties that are read
only
also the values of these properties must
be known at compile time only
now if we talk about val
for read only properties the val keyword
is also used but the mean difference
between the constant val is that the val
properties can be initialized at the
runtime also
but it is not so in case of const
coming to the 22nd question which is
what is the difference between open and
public
so open for extension
is what the open keyword indicates
the open annotation on a class is the
polar opposite of the final annotation
in java
it allows others to inherit from it
on the other hand if no visibility
modifier is specified
public is used by default which means
your declaration will be visible
everywhere
if nothing else is supplied public is
used by default
so next question is
what defines a sealed class in kotlin
so it is a multiple choice question
a
it's another name for abstract class
b
it represents this restricted class
hierarchies
c it is used in every kotlin program
d
none of the above
the correct option is option b
it represents restricted class
hierarchies
so the restricted class hierarchies
defines the seed class in kotlin
now moving on to the 24th question which
is what is lazy initialization in kotlin
so lazy initialization is a feature in
kotlin that indicates that your variable
will not be initialized unless you
utilize it in your code
if it only be initialized once
after that you repeat the process with
the same value
so now moving on to our 25th question
which is what is the entry point of
every kotlin program
every kotlin program's entry point is
the main function
the main function does not have to be
written inside the class in kotlin
the jvm automatically encapsulates it in
a class when it is compiled
the command line arguments are retrieved
using the strings given in the form of
array string
so this was the answer of this question
now moving on to the next question which
is what are companion objects in kotlin
so if we wish to write a function or a
member of a class that may be called
without needing the class instance
we can do so as a member of companion
object within the class in kotlin
as a result by declaring the companion
object
we can only access the class member by a
class name
so this was the answer of companion
objects in kotlin now moving on to the
27th question
which is
where does this kotlin run cortland
programs can execute on a normal jvm
just like any other compile java code
this means that the kotlin compiler
converts cortling programs to bytecode
that the jvm can understand
as a result kotlin is a java kind that
works alongside with java so basically
kotlin is a kind of java you can say
that
it is worth noting that
bits of java code can be used to create
kotlin applications
so now our next question is
why do we need object keyword the object
keyword in kotlin allows you to declare
a class and create an instance of it in
one step
the object keyword is used to obtain a
data type with a single implementation
it has three different meanings and can
be used in three different contexts
first is object declaration
object expression and companion object
so this was the
meaning or why we need object keyword
in kotlin so now coming to the second
last question which is what is string
interpolation
so let's start with the launch
so launch is a core routine that fires
and then forgets
it's as though a new topic that has been
started
if the code inside the launch throws an
exception
it's considered like an uncaught
exception in a thread
which is normally written to
stdewr in backend jvm apps and crashes
android apps
now on the other hand async async is
used to launch a core routine that
calculates some data
you must use a weight on the result
which is represented by an instance of d
referred
uncaught exceptions in async code are
held in the resultant d referred and are
not
transmitted anywhere else
unless processed they are silently
dropped
so although async is used to start the
co routines it does so by blocking the
main thread at the await functions entry
point
and launch
launch will not block the main thread
but the rest of the code will not be
executed while waiting for the launch
result because launch is not a suspend
call
and
this was the last question that is the
30th question of kotlin interview
questions
now with that we have come to an end of
this java and kotlin programming
tutorial i hope the session was
interesting and informative
if you have any queries regarding any of
the concepts covered in this session or
if you require the resources that we
used in the session like ppt code etc
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you